WELCOME TO THE STATE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A TWENTY ONE BILLS ON
ORDER IT'S GOING TO GO DOWN TO
TWENTY HERE QUICKLY -- IT SOME
QUICK HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS ITEM
EIGHTEEN A. B. TWELVE FIFTY
THREE HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR IT WILL NOT BE RETURNING
THIS YEAR. ONE ITEM IS ON
CONSENT -- TO DAY AND THAT IS
ITEM.
AS I LOSE THAT -- A ITEM AB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN ITEM.
NINETEEN ITEM FIFTEEN A. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN WAS ON CONSENT --
AND IT IS NOW BEING PULLED FOR
OUR ACTIVE CALENDAR TODAY.
WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS WOULD LIKE TO
BE A REVIEW -- ESTABLISH WARM
MIST LANCASTER TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
WHY ARE PRESENT MORE A LOT?
MORE LIKE PRESIDENT BELL.
THEY ARE PRESENT HER THIRD
RICARDO [inaudible]
YOU.
NIELSEN PRESENT WIENER.
IN GENERAL A QUORUM IS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU A GERMAN
FOR BEING HERE WE LOVE TO SEE
THE SO THE WOMAN IN COMMITTEE.
GREAT BILL ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
ONE THIRTY THREE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
YOU A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS
INITIATIVE AT SO WE ASK FOR
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT BUT WE WELCOME YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU WILL I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB ONE THIRTY THREE AND
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK CUT THE
COMMITTEE HAS DONE ON MAKING
SURE THIS MOVES QUICKLY.
SOME PEOPLE AREN'T.
AWARE OF SOME OF THE NEW DATA
COMING OUT RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS AND ONE OF THE
PIECES OF THAT INFORMATION IS
THAT SENIORS ARE OUR FASTEST
GROWING -- CONSTITUENCY OF
HOMELESSNESS OF THIS BILL I
BELIEVE WILL DO ITS PART TO KEEP
SENIORS IN THEIR HOME BY
ALLOWING -- IF THEY ARE.
NOT ONLY A SENIOR OVER THE AGE
OF SIXTY TWO BLIND OR DISABLED
AND CANNOT PAY THEIR PROPERTY
TAX -- WITHOUT ASSISTANCE SO
WITH THAT WE WILL KEEP IT VERY
SHORT AND ALLOW -- CHRISTOPHER.
CARLISLE TO MAKE A SHORT.
MESSAGE THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MOMENT IN AGAIN THIS IS A GREAT
BILL REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
FOCUS ON THIS WE HAVE A CRISIS
ACROSS THE STATE.
IN GRATEFUL FOR YOUR HIGHLIGHTED
THAT SIR WE LOOK ME COMMITTEE OF
TWO MINUTE CARLISLE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS KEEPING
IT SHORT OF ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE BUT OTHER THAN
THAT AS FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR WE'RE
GRATEFUL WOULD LIKE TO GET
OPENING UP FOR ANY ONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FOR THIS TIME.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT.
HEARING SEE NOW WE NOW LIKE TO
HAVE TURNED OVER THOSE WHO MAY
BE OPPOSED TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
GLASCOFF PROPOSITION.
CURRENCY NOW WITH ACT THAT BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR MOTION ON THE FLOOR
WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE VICE
CHAIR.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
CURRENCY KNOWN AS SOON LIKE TO
CLOSE I JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT IN HELPING KEEP SENIORS
IN THEIR HOMES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THEN
SOMEONE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO BE TAKING
THE TECHNICAL MINUTES WORK THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR A GRATEFUL.
THERE'S A GENTLEMAN.
WE NEED -- WE HAVE THE SOMEONE
TAKING EFFECT ORNAMENTS IN
COMMON NUMBER.
FOR THIS IT HAS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS MOTION
BY THE VICE CHAIR MS LANCASTER
IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HI WIRE I WE'RE A LOT MORE LUCK
I FELL.
DOWN I HERTZBERG RICARDO.
I NIELSEN.
YES AND I WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
EARLY JOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE
SOMEONE THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GUYS ARE YOU GOOD MORNING AND
HAVE A GOOD DAY SAY THAT SORT OF
THING THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HEY THERE YOU GO.
THERE'S A GERMAN A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS WE
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO USED TO
WORK WITH US ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND WHO ABANDONED -- AND WENT
OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY -- TO LOW
LEVEL YOU HAVE JIMMY PLEASE
STAND -- AND I GO WAY DO ME A
THERE WE GO.
I DON'T KNOW AND THERE YOU GO
THERE'S JIMMY WE GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE PLEASE SO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BACK -- JIMMY
INTERNAL AND FIGURE THAT WAS BUT
I DON'T THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE
SO -- IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU SIR
AT YOU ARE ALWAYS WELCOME HERE
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE GONNA CUSS AT
YEAH -- SO HEY THERE WE GO -- WE
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPEN
BACK UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR AN
AD -- MEMBERS ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
HOW DOES THAT MISSING GESTURES
RIGHT WE HAVE NOT MOVED ITS WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
THIS IS A DO PASSED YOU VETERANS
AFFAIRS?
ON AB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN ITEM
NINETEEN THIS IS THE ONE ITEM OF
CONSENT IS LOW INTEREST IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WIRE HI.
I'M MORE A LOT MORE LIKE GOD
THEY'LL.
THEY'LL AYE HERTZBERG RICARDO.
RICARDO AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR HERTZBERG I HAD THE TWO
YEARS AND WE'RE WE HAVE A
PROCEDURE DONE -- FOR CENTER
HERTZBERG TODAY AT PLEASE GO
RIGHT AHEAD AND WILL -- WE'LL
GET MISTER TITLE PRESENTED WITH
THE AWARD -- WHEN HE GETS HERE
SO -- WHAT IS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE HERE TODAY SIR -- THAT
AWARD IS -- THE RICARDO LARA
AWARD FOR THE PERSON ARRIVING
LASTING COMMITTEE -- M. BECAUSE
THIS IS A GOOD IDEA.
IN THE HOUSING COMMITTEE WE HAD
WE DON'T WE DON'T WE DON'T LIKE
TO TRADE IN THE MIKE MCGUIRE
AWARD FOR THE PERSON RUNNING
LAST.
THANKS WIENER THAT'S LESS I'M
GONNA CALL ARE NICER WIENER.
THANKS SO MUCH.
THERE ARE WINNERS THE ONLY
INDIVIDUAL I KNOW WHO WILL TAKE
A LIFESAVER INTO IT --
IMMEDIATELY SO -- MY GOODNESS.
ALL RIGHT IN THE CENTER BILLS
CAN BE CAREER -- MORE.
THIS IN BELL. THIRTY START THAT.
THEY DID YOUR GONNA WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IT IS HEARING
HERE.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TO OUR
GENDER AB THREE OH FIVE IS THE
MEMBER WE WELCOME YOU.
SIMILARLY A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ON YOUR BILL WHICH IS FANTASTIC
NEWS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- CITY OF LOS ANGELES
HAS EMBARKED ON A SUSTAINABILITY
PROGRAM TO INCREASE ITS LOCAL
WATER SUPPLY REDUCE ITS RELIANCE
ON IMPORTANT WHILE IMPORTED
WATER AND ADDRESS THE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES OF
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINATION AND
THIS BILL.
WHICH HAS A SUNSET.
IT CONTINUES TO HELP LOS ANGELES
IN THESE EFFORTS.
AND THE WITH ME IS -- ED MANNING
ON BEHALF OF THE LED W. P. AS
WELL AS POSSIBLY JOHN PIROGUE --
WHO'S AVAILABLE ON THE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIMILAR DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ON THIS AND
WE DO APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT
MISTER MANNING IS ALSO SPENT --
WITH THIS IS WELL MISTER MANNING
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
ED MANNING WITH KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND
POWER -- THIS BILL WILL HELP --
IN THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE -- OVER
THE NEXT YEAR -- LA FINANCE
CLEANUP OF THE SAN FERNANDO
GROUND -- VALLEY GROUNDWATER
WHICH WILL SERVE EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND REPAIRS ONE CLEAN UP.
WILL ALSO FACILITATE FINANCING
FURTHER TREATMENT A SEWAGE FROM
THE HYPERION PLANNED TO RE USE
FOR DRINKING WATER -- AND IT
WILL SAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FOR LA RATEPAYERS
OVER THE LIFE OF THESE RATE
REDUCTION BONDS.
SO IT'S AN IMPORTANT FINANCING
TOOL FOR PUBLIC UTILITIES SO TO
HELP FACILITATE LARGE CAPITAL
PROJECTS AND WE THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
WHICH IS JUST SO MANY MISTER
MANY WE NOW LIKE TO GET OPEN UP
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
THIS TIME THOSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
LAST CALL.
WE NOW WELCOME ANYONE WHO MAY BE
IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
WOULD LIKE TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MISTER VICE YEAR.
YOU'RE JUST HAVE ONE QUICK
QUESTION -- BECAUSE THEE'S A
DEDICATED CHARGE.
OR THE UTILITY CUSTOMERS IS THAT
DOES THAT NEED APPROVAL FROM THE
CPUC.
WORKING AT JUST BE DONE YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S A THE CPUC
JURISDICTION IS ONLY A OVER
PRIVATE ENTITIES THAT ARE
MONOPOLY.
BOB BOB PRIVATE WATER COMPANIES
SOMEWHERE A PUBLIC AGENCY SO THE
PC DOES NOT HAVE JURISDICTION.
BUT IT WOULD HAVE TO GO TO BOTH
THE LED TO BE P. COMMISSION AND
THE CITY COUNCIL FOR APPROVAL.
WHICH IS A VICE CHAIR WOULD LIKE
TO RECEIVE HEARING EDITION ALL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE WE ALSO WOULD WELCOME
A MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
THREE OH FIVE WITH A MOTION BY
CENTER TITLE.
MR SIMMONS LIKE CLOSER.
AT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU NO THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS AMENDED THIS HAS TO DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS MOTION.
MOTION ON THE FOUR BY CENTER
TITLED MISSILE INTERESTED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HI.
MORE LOCK.
I BILL.
I HERTZBERG FURTADO.
THE BILL SAID.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
WIENER.
THE CURRENT ENJOYS A SIX ZERO
VOTE NECESSARY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME UTILITIES AND MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR.
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN TO ALLOW CENTER HERTZBERG
TO BE A READ ON LAZY JENNA WE'RE
GONNA WALK IN THE CHAIR WOMAN
THE CHAIRWOMAN OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE ASSEMBLY HERE.
THIS IS MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SHE'S
TWO BILLS ISSUES PRESENTING
APPRECIATE ALL OVER WORK ON ITEM
NUMBER.
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB.
SIX THIRTY TWO AND CHAIR ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR YOU DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT -- IN AGAIN
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK WE LOVE
WORKING WITH YEAH IT DAY IN AND
DAY OUT -- THE SIMPLY VERY LUCKY
TO HAVE YOU THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AN ITEM NUMBER FOUR WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I DON'T FEEL
LIKE DOING ANYTHING JUST GETTING
THE COMPLIMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
RESEARCHER MEMBERS AB FIVE
THIRTY ALLOWS THE FAIRFIELD
SYSOON SEWER DISTRICT TO EXTEND
THEIR SERVICES TO MIDDLE GREEN
VALLEY.
IF IF APPROVED BY LASKO AND MAKE
MINOR CHANGES TO THE ACT.
MIDDLE GREEN VALLEY IS
UNINCORPORATED COUNTY LAND JUST
OUTSIDE THE CITIES OF FAIRFIELD
ANSWER SOON.
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
SOLANO COUNTY APPROVED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF FOUR HUNDRED NEW
HOMES THERE.
THESE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
REQUIRE A PUBLIC SEWER SYSTEM
THE FAIRFIELD SYSTEM SEWER
DISTRICT IS THE BEST QUALIFIED
SYSTEM TO SERVICE ML GREEN
VALLEY.
IN ORDER TO FOR THE DISTRICT TO
SERVICE THESE NEW HOMES THEY
MUST MAKE CHANGES TO THEIR
ENABLING ACT VIçT LEGISLATION.
AB FIVE THIRTY DOES JUST THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE AYE VOTE IN AYE
WITH ME TODAY HAVE GREAT.
VIEWS ME GREG BAY TRIP GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE FAIRFIELD TOO
SOON THIRD DISTRICT WE WELCOME
YOU COMMITTEE MISTER JENNER
MANAGER YOU A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL -- IT YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES SIR OKAY -- IN
INTERESTED KEEPING IT BRIEF I
THINK OF THE REPORT THAT HAS
BEEN PRESENTED TO USE OF AND ARE
FOR REPRESENTATION.
I THINK WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
GIVE US OPPORTUNITY TO NOW MOVE
FORWARD ON LOCAL ISSUES WITHOUT
HAVING TO BRING BACK THE
QUESTIONS EVERY TIME TO PROVIDE
SERVICE OUTSIDE TO DISTRICTS
SERVICE AREA -- TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FOR RESOLUTION AT AT
ACES -- LEGISLATION NOW THAT
WOULD LOOK FOLLOW LAUGHTER RULES
AND REGULATIONS WHICH WE ARE
PLEASED TO WOR WITH AN AND WE
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AND ASKED
YOU -- SUPPORTED AS WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE AS WELL BUT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO SEE THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
PERSON LAST NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE -- JIM'S PARENTS SOLANO
COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN SUPPORT
DIVISORS COULD YOU SEE SIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO ATTEND.
I WANT TO PERSONALLY APOLOGIZE
TO THE SUPERVISORS BEARING.
FOR CALLING HIM ON A TAPE AT THE
MTC MEETING LAST WEEK ON OLD
TIMER.
SO I'M SORRY -- WE'RE IN TROUBLE
THAT OUR CASEY THERE WE GO NOT A
MOTION HEY THAT'S A THAT'S RIGHT
EXACTLY.
HEY IT'S ALWAYS GOOD HAVING
COMMITTEE SUPERVISOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK SIR.
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
JOIN SUPERVISOR IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
PLEASE WELCOME.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING FALCONS
OFFICE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF FAIRFIELD.
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND WILL IT BE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COMPORT.
CURRENCY NINE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE A GOOD OPPOSITION.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WELCOME MA'AM.
IF YOU LIKE TO TO JOIN US UP
FRONT IF THAT BE EASIER AS WELL.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES WE ALLOW --
EQUIPPED JUNIOR PROPOSITION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR FIRST LAST NAME
ORGANIZATION WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS NOR THE SON FAIRFIELD
RESPONSIBLE GROWTH.
I REPRESENT THE SECTION OF
FAIRFIELD THAT WILL BE MOST
IMPACTED IF THIS PASSES.
WE HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM IN OUR
AREA WE'VE GOT LOTS OF HOUSING
WHICH IS GOOD FOR THE HOUSING
PROBLEM BUT UP WE DON'T HAVE ANY
NEW SCHOOLS WILL.
HAVE A SCHOOL CAPACITY PROBLEM
BUT I'VE MENTIONED THIS BEFORE
SOMEHOW IT GETS CONFUSED WITH.
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL OPERATIONS
THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT I'M TALKING ABOUT CAPACITY.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY AT
CAPACITY IT IS A IT'S BEEN
REPORTED BY THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND WE ALREADY HAVE. EIGHT
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX HOUSING UNITS
IN JUST OUR SECTION OF FAIRFIELD
THAT ARE APPROVED THAT ARE YET
TO BE BUILT WE'VE GOT THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE UNITS THAT
ARE.
IN THE PROCESS -- CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS ARE BEING BUILT NOW SO
WE DON'T KNOW HOW OUR AREA CAN
HANDLE ALL THE KIDS THAT ARE
GOING TO NEED TO GO TO SCHOOL --
ALSO IN FAIRFIELD.
ARTS BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE IN
APPROVING HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
THERE IS A PLAN TO NOT
EVERYTHING'S APPROVED BUT STILL
THE GENERAL PLAN.
OUR HAS ABOUT ELEVEN OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND UNITS.
POSSIBLE FOR AREA AND NEITHER OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE A
SINGLE NEW SCHOOL THAT IS
PLANNED I CHECKED WITH THE STATE.
WITH THE PERSON WHO IS IN CHARGE
OF THE GRANTS FOR SCHOOLS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- WHEN SHE
TOLD ME THERE ISN'T ANY SUCH
PROJECTS SUBMITTED?
I EVEN WENT THROUGH AND LOOK
THROUGH ALL THE PROJECTS AND A
VERIFIED THERE IS NO NEW SCHOOL
THAT'S PLAN.
FOR OTHER PROBLEM IS WROTE.
IN OUR SECTION OF FAIRFIELD
WE'VE GOT [inaudible] FOR
SCHOOLS.
AND THE MAIN ROADS CALLED RED
TOP ROAD IS FAMOUS FOR HOW BAD
THE TRAFFIC AT THIS.
IT'S OF IT NARROWS DOWN TO JUST
TWO LANES.
COMES TO A FULL STOP. FIFTY COME
TO A FULL STOP BEFORE YOU CAN
EXIT ON I EIGHTY EAST.
IF YOU WANT TO GET TO THE WEST
YOU GOT IT GO TO ANOTHER
STOPPING GET SO TRAFFIC IS
HORRIBLE -- ONE OF THE PARENTS --
DESCRIBED IT AS I COULD BE GOING
TO SAN FRANCISCO.
EVERY DAY ON THE TIME THAT IT
TAKES FOR ME JUST TO GET MY KIDS
TO SCHOOL.
IT IS HORRIBLE [inaudible]
DE.
THE PROJECT ITSELF IS YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT A HORRIBLE PROJECT THE
GREEN BELT BUT THE PROBLEM IS.
ONCE THIS IS ALLOWED WHERE
COUNTY DEVELOPMENTS ARE ALLOWED
ACCESS TO CITY [inaudible]
WHO WERE?
THEN THE DEVELOPMENTS GOING TO
BE MUCH FASTER.
AND THE DENSITY IS GOING TO BE
[inaudible]
MORE INTENSE.
WE'VE ALREADYHAD ABOUT THIRTY
SECONDS WE'LL ANSWER OKAY GOOD
YOU'RE GOOD SO -- BASICALLY LET
ME JUST SAY THAT I REPRESENT.
THE PORTION OR THE COMMUNITY
THAT LIVES THERE.
WE LIVE IN THE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THE HOMES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
BUILT ARE GOING TO BE MILLION
DOLLAR HOMES.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM
TO MAKE MULTI MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROFIT OKAY WE GET THAT BUT WE
DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WE PLEAD BUT YOU THINK ABOUT
US WHO LIVE IN THE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND THINK ABOUT OUR QUALITY OF
LIVES AND WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL HOUSING.
THANK YOU NO THANK YOU SO MUCH
MA'AM WILL HAVE YOU HANG THERE
IF THAT'S OKAY IN CASE WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS.
WE LIKE TO BE RECEIVED AS ANYONE
ELSE WHO IS IN OPPOSITION THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FOR THIS TIME.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONVERSATION [inaudible]
PLEASE.
THIS IS THEIR THEN [inaudible]
A QUESTION.
I WANT TO LAUGH GO THE TERM AND
THE ADEQUACY OF THE URBAN
SERVICES.
THAT'S THEIR JOB OF COURSE WITH
THE STATE LAW.
AND ARE THEY GOING ABOUT THAT
PROCESS.
IF THIS IS APPROVED.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT I
LAUGHTER WOULD APPROVE THE
PROCESS OF EXTENDING THE ARE
APPROVING THE OUT OF VERY
SERVICE AGREEMENT WITH RESPECT
TO SEWER.
THOSE PORTIONS OF OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE OR ARE ALSO TO BE
CONTEMPLATED WHEN THOSE PROJECTS
MOVE FOR WHETHER THEY'RE AT THAT
COUNTY LEVEL THROUGH.
THIS SPECIFIC PLAN PROCESS IS
THE PUBLIC PROCESSES THAT OCCUR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTATION
OCCURS IN THE PROCESS OF
APPROVING SPECIFIC A PLANTS.
AND WITH THE MIDDLE GREEN VALLEY
THAT HAS ALL BEEN PROVED IN THE
MIDDLE.
GREEN VALLEY SPECIFIC PLAN.
FURTHER THE GENERAL PLAN IS GONE
FOR TO THE PUBLIC IN THE VOTERS
AND THEY HAVE -- APPROVED IT
OVERWHELMINGLY OF THE CHIP BUT
FOR THE GENERAL PLAN ARE THEY
GOING THROUGH SEVERAL PROCESSES
AND PUBLIC HEARINGS FOR WELL
OVER TEN YEARS YES THIS PROCESS
IS GOING TO PLAY.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
SENATOR NIELSEN.
LIKE TO PROCEDURES ANY FURTHER
CONVERSATION BY THE COMMITTEE.
WITH THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR
WHICH IS A DO PASSED TO THE
FLOOR.
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE -- I SIMPLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE IN JUST TO REITERATE --
I'M VERY CONFIDENT I WOULD NOT
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD TO YOU IF I
DIDN'T HAVE THE CONFIDENCE -- IN
SPEAKING WITH THE SUPERVISORS IN
THE DISTRICT TO MAKE SURE
THEY'VE DONE A PUBLIC PROCESS
THERE'S STILL MORE TO COME THEY
HAVE TO TO GO TO LIVE CO SO%
THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE PUBLIC IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY LIKE TO DO.
SO AGAIN I ASK WHERE I WROTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MANAGER WE DO HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION MR MEISTER YES.
THE GLITTER TOOK [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY CENTER NIELSEN THIS%
IS THE TO PASS TO THE FLOOR.
THIS RANGERS REVIEW COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HI WHY I'M MORE A LOT MORE LIKE
AYE BELL.
I HERTZBERG THE TOTAL.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
THEN I WINNER WIENER.
TURNING ENJOY THE SIX YOU'RE
GONNA KEEP ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
SOMEONE WOMAN THANK MISTER
JENNER MANGER IN MA'AM THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US TODAY AND
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AS WELL
YOU'RE ALWAYS WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I GET MY
LAZY GEMMA NOW CAN BE MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN THIS IS AB
SIX THREE TWO ITEM.
SEVEN SB.
SIX THIRTY TWO AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS -- THIS IS AB SIX
THIRTY TWO ALLOWS LAKECOUNTY TO
CONSOLIDATE THE ELECTED OFFICES
OF AUDITOR CONTROLLER AND THE
TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR.
MANY OF YOU KNOW LIKE IT IS A
RURAL COUNTY AND MY DISTRICT
THAT HAS BEEN DID IT HAS BEEN
DEVASTATED IN RECENT FIRES AND
FACING.
EDIBLE FINANCIAL CHALLENGES.
ASA PART OF THE FISCAL CRISIS
MANAGEMENT PLAN LAKE COUNTY
PROPOSE COMBINING THE COUNTY
AUDITOR CONTROLLER.
AND THE COUNTY TAX A TREASURE
TAX COLLECTORS OFFICES. FIVE
OTHER COUNTIES HAVE TO HAVE THIS
AUTHORITY COMBINE THESE TWO
ELECTED OFFICES CAN LEAD TO
GREATER EFFICIENCY AND
COLLABORATION WALK CUTTING DOWN
THE COUNTY COSTS.
SB SIX THIRTY TO SIMPLY GIVES
LAKE COUNTY ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX TO HELP THEM GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET.
I ASK FOR YOUR IBM BY VOTE AND
WITH ME TODAY IS MATT MATTHEW
WROTE ROTHSTEIN ON BEHALF OF
LAKE COUNTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEDICINE WOMAN
PLEASE SIR GOOD TO SEE.
OUR FIRST ONE IS A SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUILAR CURRY -- YOUR SUPPORT OF
LAKE COUNTY AND SOME OF OUR
DARKEST HOURS AS WE FACE WILD
FIRE AND FLOOD.
AND YOUR ONGOING WORK ON BEHALF
OF LEE COUNTY RESIDENTS AND
OTHER CONNECTED INDIVIDUALS IS
TRULY EXTRAORDINARY.
I WILL JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
KNOWLEDGE AT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT WORK YOU'RE THE ONES
I'VE BEEN WORK IN YOUR TAILS OFF
CANDIDLY SO VERY GRATEFUL.
AND AS THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M DEEPLY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING ON
BEHALF OF LAKE COUNTY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
AS YOUR COMMITTEE IS AWARE OF
LAKE COUNTY'S GOVERNMENT IS
FACING NUMEROUS AND COMPETING
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES AND ON
DECEMBER FOR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN OR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
ADOPTED A FISCAL CRISIS
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
YOU'RE PROBABLY ALSO WHERE THAT
LAKE COUNTY HAS NO IMMEDIATE
PLANS TO CONSOLIDATE OUR
FINANCIAL OFFICES WITH RECENT
ELECTIONS HAVING ESTABLISHED
BOTH OFFICES LEADERSHIP FOR THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS.
HOWEVER SEEKING THE FLEXIBILITY
TO CONSOLIDATE OFFICES IS
CONSISTENT WITH MULTIPLE
PRIORITIES AND FISCAL CRISIS
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE BEFORE
YOUR COMMITTEE TODAY.
IN LAKE COUNTY WE'RE IN A TIME
OF CONSIDERABLE TRANSITION AND
EXPLORING MANY PATHWAYS TO MAKE
OUR ORGANIZATION MORE FLEXIBLE
TO MEET EMERGING OPPORTUNITIES
AND CHALLENGES.
AND IN PREPARING FOR THE FUTURE
WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
AND PLAN IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
FACT THAT MAINTAINING
APPROPRIATE STAFFING IN OUR
PHYSICAL FUNCTIONS HAS BEEN AN
AREA OF LONG TERM AN
INTENSIFYING CONCERN.
MULTIPLE RECENT RECRUITMENT FOR
HIGH LEVEL FISCAL STAFF HAVE
BEEN UNSUCCESSFUL.
AND OTHER POSITIONS HAVE BEEN
UNDER FILLED WHICH OF INCREASE
THE TRAINING NEEDS OF ALREADY
OVERBURDENED DEPARTMENTS -- ONE
OF THE REALITIES WE FACE IS THAT
16% OF LAKE COUNTY RESIDENTS
HAVE A COLLEGE DEGREE IN ANY
SUBJECT.
THE POOL WITH A SIGNIFICANT
FISCAL BACKGROUND IS
CONSIDERABLY SMALLER.
AS AN ATTRACTING HIGH PERFORMERS
FROM OTHER GEOGRAPHIC AREAS HAS
LIKEWISE BEEN DIFFICULT.
AJUDAR RELATIVE ISOLATION AND
LAGGING EMPLOYEE SALARIES AND
BENEFITS.
ELECTED OFFICIALS FURTHER NEED
TO MAKE THE CHOICE TO LIVE IN
LAKE COUNTY AND WE'VE BEEN
UNABLE TO CONSISTENTLY ATTRACT
DEPUTY LEVEL STAFF.
THEY CAN ESTABLISH ROOTS AND
GROWING TO OUR NEXT GENERATION
OF ELECTED OFFICERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN LAKE
COUNTY'S AUDITOR CONTROLLER
ASSESSOR RECORDER AND TREASURER
TAX COLLECTOR.
ALL RAN UNOPPOSED.
IN FACT PER OUR REGISTRAR OF
VOTERS OFFICE THERE HASN'T BEEN
A CONTESTED ELECTION FOR ONE OF
THESE POSITIONS IN THREE DECADES.
SO AS YOU CAN APPRECIATE
CREATING THE FLEXIBILITY TO
CONSOLIDATE OUR FINANCIAL
OFFICES AT A FUTURE DATE JUST
MAKES SENSE FOR LAKE COUNTY.
SO -- WERE ALSO I WANNA BEEN
ASSURE YOU THAT WE'RE AWARE THAT --
ADDRESSING CHECKS AND BALANCES
SHOULD BE MOVED TO CONSOLIDATE
THESE OFFICES IS VERY IMPORTANT.
AND WERE OPEN TO EXPLORING
MODELS THAT OTHER COUNTIES ARE
PURSUED AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OF MECHANISM SUCH AS
STRONG TREASURY OVERSIGHT AND
AUDIT COMMITTEES AND WORKING
GROUPS.
AND ALSO LIAISON POSITIONS WITH
STAFF WORKING OUTSIDE OF ANY OF
THOSE OFFICES DIRECT CHAIN OF
COMMAND AND ABLE TO READILY
RAISE ISSUES THAT COME TO THERE
WERE IN THIS WITHOUT FEAR OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTION -- WE
RECENTLY DEVELOPED A TAX
ADMINISTRATOR POSITION THAT DOES
JUST THAT AND HAS ENHANCE THE
WORKING RELATIONSHIP OF OUR
<c.green>OARD OF SUPERVISORS WITH A BIT</c>
OF BOTH ADMINISTRATION AND THE
TREASURE TAX COLLECTOR'S OFFICE.
TODAY I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT AB.
SIX THIRTY TWO AS YOU CAN
UNDOUBTEDLY APPRECIATE.
THIS IS ABOUT MORE THAN JUST
FINANCES.%
THE FLEXIBILITY THE A. B. SIX
THIRTY TWO OFFERS IS RIGHT FOR
LAKE COUNTY.
NOW AND IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND TO KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS ARE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR EVEN HERE TODAY SIR PLEASE
GIVE OUR BEST A SUCH AS SOON AS
WELL AS SPECIAL BOARD.
WE LIKE WE ARE OPEN IT UP TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME.
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LAST CALL WITHOUT LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TURN OVER THOSE WHO MAY
BE OPPOSED IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD LOOKING FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSED.
WE LIKE TO BETTER BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONVERSATION
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER I JUST FOR THE
RECORD MR ROTHSTEIN ONCE YOU
GIVE US YOUR TITLE YES OBSERVE
MINUTES MATTHEW ROTHSTEIN DEPUTY
COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
THE COUNTY OF LAKE.
AND HAVE YOU GONE TO THE BALLOT
YET TO MERGE THESE TWO OR IT WAS
A SUCCESSFUL.
OKAY I KNOW WE HAVE NOT GONE TO
THE BALLOT ANSWERED THIS BUT
JUST LISTEN BEFORE YOU WOULD
ALLOW US TO CONSOLIDATE THE
OFFICES BY ORDINANCE -- I ASK
ALL THE TOUGH QUESTION --
BECAUSE WE ARE TRYING TO SAVE
COSTS HAVE YOU DISCUSSED.
MAGNA BASS THE WITNESSES AT
ACADEMY.
HAVE YOU DISCUSSED MERGING WITH
THE NEIGHBORING COUNTY OR
COUNTIES.
MERGING WITH A NEIGHBORING
COUNTY.
A NO WE HAVE NOT THIS TIME.
ARM JUST ONE S. R..
IN MY PREVIOUS LIFE I WAS A
COUNTY TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR
AND I'VE.
I'VE HAD DIFFICULTY WITH MERGING
THE OFFICES -- BUT I I TAKE IT
WHEN IT'S DONE IT SHOULD BE DONE
THROUGH A BALLOT SO IF YOU SEE
ME VOTING NO.
IT'S JUST BECAUSE I'VE GOT.
THESE OLD IDEAS STILL STUCK IN
MY HEAD AND THAT'S THE COURSE I
THINK THIS IS THE MOST
APPROPRIATE [inaudible]
AND SO.
LOOKING PAST ALL THE
CIRCUMSTANCES I'M JUST.
FOCUSED ON THAT ON THAT --
PRINCIPLE.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A VICE CHAIR I HAVE SOME
QUICK CLOSING COMMENTS.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS TIME.
AT LOOK AT APPRECIATE WHAT WHERE
THE VICE CHAIR IS COMING FROM
AND AND THE VICE CHAIR COMES
FROM A LONG TERM SERVICE.
I IN THE COUNTY OF ORANGE -- I
KNOW THAT THIS DECISION TO BE
OVERCOME IN FRONT OF US TODAY
DID NOT COME LIGHTLY.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF COMMUNITY
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS ISSUE --
BOTH PRO AND CON.
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN HAS STUDIED
THIS BILL.
A SIGNIFICANTLY AT WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE COUNTY --
AND AGAIN I THINK THAT -- THE
COUNTY IS PREPARED BAD MOVE
FORWARD I BELIEVE THAT THE
RESIDENTS ARE PREPARED TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS -- CONSOLIDATION
AS WELL AND THERE WILL BE
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION WHEN
THERE WOULD BE AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION AT THE BOARD -- IN A
BOARD HEARING.
MADAM SOME NUMBER WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF YOU LIKE TO BE A CLOSE
AND WILL ASK FOR A MOTION TO
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE -- QUITE FRANKLY I I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT --
SENATOR BECAUSE YEAH WHEN TO BE
GREAT TO CONSOLIDATE.
IN A RURAL AREAS IT'S IS JUST AS
DIFFICULT FOR TO HIM A COUNTY
COLUSA COUNTY TO GET -- OF
PEOPLE TO WANT THOSE JOBS UP
THERE
AND AS MATTHEW HAS ALLUDED TO IS
THAT.
TRYING TO FIND PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO LIVE IN A RURAL DISTRICT.
THE PERSON MAY ONE OVER THE
FAMILY MAY NOT WANT TO STAY VERY
LONG SO THAT WE WE SHUFFLE
THROUGH QUITE A FEW PEOPLE IN IN
OUR REAL COMMUNITIES -- AND IT'S
FRUSTRATING -- IT'S NOT.
THE MONEY THAT IS NOT THERE.
AND I STRUGGLE EVERY SINGLE DAY
FOR THIS COUNTY.
AS AS THE SENATOR DOES I MEAN
THIS IS JUST BEEN DEVASTATING TO
A 75% OF THE LAND IS GONE.
THE JOBS ARE NOT THERE WERE
TRYING TO BRING BACK ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
ALL THESE THINGS FOR THE COUNTY.
AND IF I CAN GIVE IN THIS ONE
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX SO WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD -- THAT'S WHAT I
ARE I'D BE HONORED FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY AND I KNOW THIS IS TOUGH
SO I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU TODAY
AND I ASSEMBLY AS RIVALS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH W. CAN A
MINISTRY -- WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
MOTION AN ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX THREE TWO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY THE DEAN OF THE
SENATE CENTER NIELSEN.
THIS IS A DO PASS TO THE FLOOR.
MISS LANE JUST CHECKING PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HI WHY I'M MORE A LOT.
WARLOCK NOBEL [inaudible]
RICARDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ENJOY THE THREE ONE VOTE MADAM
CHAIR I WILL KEEP THIS HOPING TO
BE ABLE TO ADD ON THANK YOU
MISTER AND GET THE CAN
ADMINISTRATOR SERVICE YOUR
PLEASE RICHARD AGAIN ARE BROUGHT
UP THE QUESTION OF MERGING.
I AM THE REASON I DID IS.
ABOUT NINE YEARS AGO I I
CONTACTED ALL THE COUNTIES THE
CAN I HAVE YOUR FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS.
AND MODOC COUNTY.
THE SAID NOTE WITH WE CAN'T EVEN
AFFORD OUR CPA FIRM TO THE AUDIT.
AND I STILL CAN YOUR BEHAVIOR
AUDITOR CONTROLLER CALL ME BACK.
HE SAID SHE SAID YEAH WHAT'S DO
YOU HAVE A TOLL FREE NUMBER.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
MAKE LONG DISTANCE PHONE CALLS
AND SO I'M SITTING HERE GOING
LOOKING AT LOOKING AT TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS IS A LONG TERM ISSUE
FOR MISTER CHAIR.
I DON'T KNOW IF IF IF THE
LEGISLATURE'S EVER LOOKED AT
MERGING COUNTIES I KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE SPLIT OFF WE'VE GOT I'VE
GOT I'VE GOT THE MAP THANK YOU
SHOW YOUR FROM. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ON HOW THESE COUNTIES HAVE.
BUT IT MAYBE IT'S TIME TO LOOK
AT SOMETHING A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THAT'S WHY.
I BROACH THAT SUBJECT I
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK RICHARD
YOU'RE DOING I GET IT.
THANK YOU.
I THINK SO MUCH AS THE PRESSURE
THANK YOU MENTION HERE THAT THE
DC THANK YOU TO SHOP.
THANK YOU GENERAL WE HAVE.
THREE THREE VERY CAPABLE AUTHORS
IN THE ROOM WE'RE GONNA START
WITH ASSEMBLY WOMAN WEBER WE ARE
GOING TO WELCOME HER.
ON ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY FOUR
AND NINETY EIGHT CINNAMON IT IS
WONDERFUL TO HAVE YET IN
COMMITTEE -- AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
RELATED TO VETERANS.
BUT YOU DO A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
SOME MOMENTS IS THIS IS
FANTASTIC NEWS THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MA'AM.
THANK YOU I ALWAYS LIKE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THAT THAT
FLOWS KEEPS OF LIVE.
BOB I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TO PRESENT TO YOU I'M
SORRY WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE BIT
LATE BIG BUT I WAS STUCK IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE PRESENTING A
BILL.
AND I'M ON ANOTHER COMMITTEE YOU
GUYS UNDERSTAND ASSISTANCE INTO
SISSIES THREE THREE SO I'M HERE
TO PRESENT TO YOU AB FOUR NINE
EIGHT WHICH WOULD EXEMPT
VETERANS.
WHO OWN SERVICE BUSINESSES FROM
LOCAL BUSINESS LICENSES THIS
EXEMPTION ALREADY EXIST FOR THAT
VETERANS WHO MAKE AND SELL
TANGIBLE GOODS?
HOWEVER VETERANS WHO PROVIDE
SERVICES SUCH AS GRAPHIC
DESIGNER LANDSCAPING COULD NOT
RECEIVE THE EXEMPTION -- WE KNOW
THAT THE WORLD IS CHANGING AND
MORE AND MORE INDIVIDUALS ARE
INTO THE SERVICE INDUSTRY MUCH
MORE THAN PROVIDING OR MAKING
GOODS.
AB FOUR NINE EIGHT WOULD
MODERNIZE A LOT TO REFLECT THE
SERVICE ORIENTED TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ECONOMY THIS BILL WILL
ONLY HAPPEN APPLY TO VETERAN
OWNED BUSINESSES WHO ARE SOLE
PROPRIETORS OF THEIR BUSINESS.
AND WOULD NOT APPLY TO STAY
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES SUCH AS
COSMETOLOGY OF CONTRACTORS
LICENSES.
AB FOUR NINE EIGHT WOULD
INCREASE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WITH VETERANS WHO
SELL SMALL WHO OWN SMALL SERVICE
BUSINESSES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOTH.
SO MUCH IS ALUMINUM.
MA'AM WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE TESTING TODAY THE
STAFF -- I APOLOGIZE THANK YOU
SO MUCH IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU IN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
GOD KNOWS BILL BETTER THAN I DO
ALL RIGHT.
WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
WELCOME ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
THIS TIME [inaudible]
LAST CALL.
WE WELCOME ANYONE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION HE COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
LAST CALL.
WE NOW LIKE TO WELCOME ANY
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MISTER
VICE CHAIR.
SURE I'D REALLY LIKE TO HEAR
FROM STAFF [inaudible]
GO.
SHE'S ACQUIRED A STEP I HAVE I'M
NOT KIDDING.
TELL YOU SOMETHING I WANT TO
HEAR.
TO THE SMART THOUGH HEY ANDREA.
ALL RIGHT ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT FROM
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
HEARING SEE.
NINE BEDROOMS IN THE ROAD LIKE
TO CLOSE YES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE AYE VOTE THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AS MOST OF YOU KNOW
SAN DIEGO HAS A LARGE IS
PROBABLY VETERAN POPULATION IN
THE STATE.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF YOUNG OF
JOB INDIVIDUALS WITH BUSINESSES
AND THIS WOULD HELP THEM
SIGNIFICANTLY AS THEY BEGIN TO
MOVE INTO ESPECIALLY THOSE WILL
COMING OUT OF THE MILITARY.
RIGHT NOW AND ALL ALTHOUGH AN
OPENING VARIOUS KINDS OF SERVICE
INDUSTRIES AT BAY A BRING
EXPERTISE TO AND THIS WOULD GIVE
THEM AN AN OPPORTUNITY A
RECOGNITION THAT THEY ARE JUST
LIKE ALL THE OTHER VETERANS WE
RECOGNIZE IN THE STATE.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASPEN AYE BOAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS THE MEMBER
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
ON ITEM NUMBER THREE A BEFORE.
NINETY EIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
THE GOOD CENTER CENTERNIELSEN
THIS IS A DO PASSED TO VETERANS
AFFAIRS ON EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
EIGHT MISS LANE CHESTER CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI I'M MORE LONG.
WALK AYE BELL HERTZBERG FURTADO
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
WIENER I'D.
SAY THAT BY PARTISAN FOUR ZERO
VOTE FOR HE THAT ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH BOTH YOU SOON THANK
YOU GOOD TO SEE YOU THE SHOP
TODAY.
SO WE GOT A PROBLEM NOW THAT --
EVERYBODY LEFT.
SO WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER TO
CENTER NIELSEN IF -- ANY ITEMS
HE LIKED BETTER DISCUSS A SONG
YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE TO BRING
FORWARD.
HEY THERE YOU GO [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT HELD A I
NOW OWN I KNOW.
YEAH IDAHO NO YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
WE HAVE -- AS YOU CAN TELL OUR
CANDY SUPPLY TODAY IS FULL OF
TWISTS SERVICES BECAUSE IT'S THE
MOST UNPOPULAR SO WE WELCOME YOU
TO THE CANDY JAR WE HAVE -- IT.
DOES IS IT TOO IS THERE'S A FEW
OF THE DICE AS WELL WE WELCOME
YOU TO THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
BRIEF MOMENT.
BUT AS WE ARE TRACKING DOWN
AUTHORS WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
YOU
[inaudible]
BILLS
THE HERE [inaudible]
YES.
WORK.
DONE.
WINNER WINNER CHICKEN DINNER.
THAT'S RIGHT LET'S GENERAL FROM
THE GREAT CITY BY THE BAY THERE
YOU GO THANK YOU.
SORRY WE'RE GONNA WELCOME MISTER
TING A. B. TWELVE OH EIGHT TO
COMMITTEE.
HAS A PLEASURE VETO TO WORK WITH
CENTER WIENER -- IS WELL IT'S AN
WIENER ANY ITEMS YOU LIKE ME TO
TALK ABOUT MR TING ANY GOOD
STORIES.
OKAY Và ALL RIGHT THERE YOU GO.
THAT IS IN THERE THANKS FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND ITEM SIXTEEN
A. B. TWELVE OO EIGHT PERFECT
THANK YOU A. B. TWELVE WHAT
WEIGHT IS AN EXTENSION.
OF THE CLEAN ENERGY UTILITY
USERS TAX EXEMPTION.
WHAT IT DOES IS RIGHT NOW THE
UTILITY USERS TAX COULD BE
OPPOSED BY LOCALJURISDICTION?
ON THE CONSUMPTION OF UTILITY
SERVICES THIS PROHIBITION ON
IMPOSING THIS TAX ON CLEAN
ENERGY WAS ESTABLISH BY SOMEONE
NUMBER MULLIN IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN WE ARE JUST
EXTENDING THIS OUT FURTHER.
SO WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOME MEMBER WE
WELCOME YOU SIR TO COMMITTEE.
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND
LAST IN ORGANIZATION TWO MINUTES
MY NAME IS BEN DAVIS I'M A
POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH EIGHT IS
A BENEFICIAL AND RELATIVELY
SIMPLE PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THE UTILITY USER TAX EXEMPTION
ON THE ENERGY THAT GOES FROM THE
SOLAR PANELS ON A ROOF.
DIRECTLY TO THAT HOME WHERE THAT
CUSTOMERS A LIGHT OUTLETS
APPLIANCES AND OTHER LOADS.
IS SET TO EXPIRE IN JANUARY OF
NEXT YEAR.
AB TWELVE AWAY WOULD EXTEND THAT
EXEMPTION TO JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN WHEN-CALIFORNIANS GENERATE CLEAN
ENERGY SAFELY ON THEIR OWN ROOF
FOR ON THEIR ON PREMISES THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO USE THAT
ENERGY.
THAT CLEAN ENERGY WITHOUT
OBSTRUCTION INTERFERENCE OR TAX
FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
THE STATE AS YOU KNOW HAS
AMBITIOUS GOALS TO TACKLE
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE SHOULD BE
INCENTIVIZE IN ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO USE RENEWABLE ENERGY.
NOT PUTTING UP COSTS BEAR YEARS
BY TAXING THEM.
AB TWELVE AWAIT ACCOMPLISHES
JUST THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU SO MUCH SIR AND THANKS FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL WOULD NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPEN IT
UP FOR ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR
THIS TIME OF THE CAN FOR SUPPORT.
HEARING SEEING NONE WE NOW LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO THOSE WHO MAY
BE OPPOSE LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION.
WELCOME.
IF YOU WANT TO JOIN US HERE OF
THE DICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS ON AB
TROUBLING THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CARA ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF PASADENA.
OUR OPPOSITION TO THIS REALLY
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH RENEWABLE
ENERGY THIS IS ABOUT THE
EXTENSION ON THE UT WE OPPOSED
IT WHEN IT WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED
IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN WE CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE THE DECISION BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO OVER RIDE OUT OF
A LOCAL AGENCY WHERE OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IN PASADENA THE VOTERS APPROVED
THIS TAX THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE RELY ON IT SO WE BELIEVE THAT
IT'S HARD TO SHOULD BE AT OUR
DISCRETION WHETHER OR NOT.
AND HOW THIS TAX IMPOSED AND FOR
THAT REASON WE WOULD OPPOSE THE
EXTENSION OF THE BILL OR THE
EXTENT OF THE TAX AND THERE BY
THE BILL ITSELF.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR AT WORDS
TODAY WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME TO THIS
MICROPHONE THIS TIME LOOKING FOR
THOSE FOR OPPOSE.
LAST CALL.
WE'D LIKE TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR CONVERSATION
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. TO
MAINTAIN DO WE KNOW WHAT DOLLAR
AMOUNT OF LOST REVENUES WERE
TALKING ABOUT THAT'S A QUESTION.
I DO NOT BECAUSE SEVERAL.
THE CITY OF PASADENA KNOW WHAT.
TO WHAT DOLLAR AMOUNT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
IF YOU DON'T MIND JOINT IS BACK
UP THE DICE PLEASE.
AND IF YOU DON'T MIND JUST
REDUCING YOURSELF AS WELL THE
QUESTION IS.
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT LAS.
WE DON'T KNOW THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
ON MY JUST REDUCE HIM SORRY I'M
SORRY CARE ROSS AGAIN ON BEHALF
THE CITY OF PASSING IT WE DON'T
HAVE AN EXACT DOLLAR FIGURE I
DON'T BELIEVE THIS IS COULD
CURRENTLY COLLECTED.
SO IT'S SOMETHING WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT LONG TERM -- I DO
KNOW FROM THE CITY OF PASADENA
STANDPOINT WE COLLECT I BELIEVE
IT'S ABOUT TWENTY FOUR DOLLARS
PER -- PER PER HOME UP HEALTH
HOLD ON IN FOR OUR TOTAL YOU UT
SO THIS WOULD BE ONE SMALL
FRACTION.
AND IT'S A THIS JUST APPLIES TO
THOSE THAT ARE.
HAVING A SOLAR PANELS FOR FOR
SOMEONE ELSE NOT NECESSARILY
JUST FOR YOURSELF RESERVE FOR
EVERYBODY WAS SOLD [inaudible]
IT.
VISIT WHERE YOU'RE JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE ELECTRONS THAT GO FROM
THE FROM YOUR PANELS DIRECTLY
INTO YOUR OUTLETS IF I'M SO IF
YOU HAVE SOLAR PANELS ON YOUR
ROOF YOU WILL STILL.
BE PAYING A TAX ON THE
ELECTRICITY YOU TAKE FROM THE
GRANT.
OKAY DOES THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION YOU KNOW THE SIZE I I I
THOUGHT THAT IT WAS -- A UNIQUE --
THAT IT WOULD THAT IT WAS FOR
PROJECTS TO A MORE DIFFERENT
THAN JUST SOLAR PANELS.
SO I APOLOGIZE FOR MISTER STATE
I THOUGHT THE RELATIVE AMOUNT
WOULD BE RATHER DE MINIMUS.
BUT I APPRECIATE THE LOCAL
CONTROL ISSUE [inaudible]
SO I'M.
TRYING TO YOU KNOW IF IT'S A
DIMINISH MISS AMOUNT THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHY WERE HAGGLING BUT
IN A LITTLE BIT BUT I GUESS I
GUESS I'D LOVE TO SEE A
QUANTIFIED.
IN A IN NOT AT ALL GOING TO BE
ABLE TO NAIL DOWN A SPECIFIC BUT
BASED OFF OF COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
WE BELIEVE IT'S A USED THE TERM
NEGLIGIBLE ACROSS THE STATE IN
REGARDS.
TO LOSSES FOR MUNICIPALITIES --
BUT CAN'T NAIL THAT DOWN BUT IT
IS [inaudible]
VERY SMALL.
IN AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT WE
THINK THIS IS A VERY SMALL.
INCENTIVE TO WORK AGAIN
ENCOURAGE CLEAN ENERGY WE HAVE --
GOALS THAT WE'VE ALREADY PUT
INTO LAW TO TRY TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE.
GAS EMISSIONS WE THINK THIS IS A
OF GET UP ON THE L. AWAITED DO
IT -- WITHOUT HAVING A VERY
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL IMPACT.
I WOULD JUST ADD OUR OPPOSITION
IS LESS ABOUTTHE RENEWABLE
ENERGY WORK STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE
OF RENEWABLE ENERGY WE ARE A%
CITY THAT THROUGH OUR MUNICIPAL
WATER AND POWER AGENCY WE ARE
WELL ON OUR WAY PAST 40% FOR
CLEAN ENERGY WERE.
CONSTANTLY GO IN THAT DIRECTION
THIS IS ABOUT THE LONGER TERM
PICTURE ON A UT ON A TAX THAT
WAS LOCALLY SUPPORTED LOCALLY
PASSED AND SO THE STTE COMING
IN EVEN ON A DE MINIMUS.
EXEMPTION WE BELIEVE IT'S REALLY
NOT THE ROLE OF THE STATE TO
TELL US WHAT TO DO ON A LOCALLY
ENACTED TAX ABOUT THE DOCTOR
BROUGHT FOR US.
AND JUST JUST THE PLAYED OUT A
LITTLE BIT.
I DO YOU HAVE A COST OF LIVING.
ADJUSTMENT FOR YOUR YOU TT I
WOULD IMAGINE BUT I CAN'T I
DON'T KNOW FOR SURE.
YOU YOU T. UT.
IS THAT YOU COULD.
IN A MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE WITH
A TEMP RIGHT JAIL SMALL.
INCREASE EVERY YEAR BUT THEN
YOU'RE NO YOU'RE BE SET THE THAT
THE NON SOLAR WE SUBSIDIZING THE
SOLAR PRACTICE ANOTHER WHOLE
WRECKED OLD ISSUE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER NO
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S VICE
CHAIR.
BUT SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION FROM
COMMITTEE.
WE ALSO WELCOME MOTION AND ITEM.
SIXTEEN WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER NIELSEN THIS IS TO PASS A
FLOOR A SIMILAR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSER.
DISRESPECT FOR F. RAFAH THANK
YOU SO MUCH EARNS GOOD TO SEE
YOU MISS LANCASTER IF YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HI REQUIRE UNDER LOCK.
MOORLACH I BELL HERTZBERG
FURTADO NIELSEN.
YES AND I WIENER HI.
LOOK AT THAT THAT IS A FOUR
EIGHT ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THEIR OPENNESS AND NUMBER AND
WE'LL ADD ON'S FOLKS CAN MAKE
YOU THANK YOU SO COULD YOU SEE
SIR.
THERE'S A GENTLEMAN.
NOT ONE BUT TWO WE HAVE ITEM
FOURTEEN AN ITEM SEVENTEEN IN
ONE AUTHOR MR EDUARDO GARCIA WE
WELCOME MR GARCIA THAT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO SOME NUMBER CHEN.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH ITEM
FOURTEEN WHICH IS FOCUS ON THE
DE DESERT HEALTHCARE DISTRICT.
THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO ITEM.
SEVENTEEN IN REGARD TO CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS IN THAT INCENTIVE
PROGRAM.
MR CELL NUMBER IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU SIR HE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND ITEM.
FOURTEEN GOOD MORNING -- WAS
CHAIRED.
ASSEMBLY BILL. TEN NINETY FIVE
IS A A DISTRICT BUILD UP CLEAN
UP.
A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP DISTRICT
BUILD THAT -- AIMS TO INCREASE
BORDER PRODUCTIVITY.
A TO THE DESERT HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT -- FOR FORMER
BACKGROUND.
AB TWENTY FOUR FOURTEEN WAS A
CHAPTER TO TO LONG.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IT ALLOWED
FOR THE HEALTH CARE DISTRICT
RESIDENTS TO VOTE ON AN
EXPANSION OF THE DISTRICT -- IF
APPROVED THE BOARD EXISTING
BOARD WOULD ADD TO MEMBERS OF
THE NEW TERRITORY -- THERE WAS
SOME CLARIFICATION QUESTIONS THE
CAME BACK THAT THE TWO
APPOINTEES WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED.
TO RUN FOR THOSE SEATS -- IF --
DESIRE TO AND SO THIS BILL AIMS
TO CLARIFY THAT -- LANGUAGE
ALLOWING THEM -- TO CONSIDER
RUNNING FOR THOSE POSITIONS IF I
THE SOLDIERS TO AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR RIVAL THANK YOU SO MUCH
INTEREST SOMEONE WOULD LIKE ME
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD THIS TIME.
WAS ALSO BACK.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS ALL OF US HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
INDIAN WELLS WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE STILL IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME
LOOKING FOR SUPPORT.
HEARING SEEN NINE WOULD NOW LIKE
TO TURN OVER THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD THIS TIME.
HEARING SEE NO OPPOSITION WITH
ACT BETTER TURN IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE AND ITEM FOURTEEN A.
B..
TEN NINETY FIVE WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
HERE AND SEE NINE IS THERE A
MOTION TO BE ABLE TO APPROVE
ITEM FOURTEEN AB.
TEN NINETY FIVE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR BALLOT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THIS HAS A MOTION TO PASS
TO THE FLOOR.
DELIVER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSER
BACK YES FOR RIVAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO WORK WITH THE
SEARCH GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
SCIENTISTS REFERRAL CALL VOTE.
HI WHY I'M MORE LOCK.
WELL.
I HERTZBERG RICARDO NIELSEN.
WIENER HI THERE I CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A THREE ZERO VOTE SOME
MEMORY TO KEEP THIS FROM OPEN IN
WILL ADD ONS FOLKS COMING THANK
YOU.
WE'RE DOING A DOUBLE HEADER HERE --
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN A. B.
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT MR GARCIA THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THE BILL TWELVE
FORTY A WILL PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TOOL TO INCENTIVIZE
OF REDEVELOPMENT AND
REHABILITATION.
FACILITIES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
BY ATTRACTING INVESTMENT FROM
SMALL AND MID SIZE MANUFACTURERS.
THE BILL WILL ALLOW. FOR
GOVERNMENT -- GOVERN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO USE THE CAPITAL
INVESTMENT INCENTIVE PROGRAM --
HERE WITH ME IS A JOE COOK WITH
THE COMPANY MANUFACTURES AND
TECHNOLOGY STATION TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS SUMMER
YOU'RE GONNA TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS AS WELL YES WE ACCEPT
THOSE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY
GRATEFUL SEEM TA IS IN THE HOUSE
WE WALKED ME SIR YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
THANK YOU I THINK THE CHAIR AND
AND THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS A
MEMBER GARCIA MANY MISTER I'LL
COOK I REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION.
BUT WE ARE THE PROUD SPONSORS OF
A. B. TWELVE FORTY EIGHT HERE
TODAY ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPERS -- WHO COULD
NOT MAKE IT HERE TODAY BECAUSE
THEY'RE SCHEDULING CONFLICT
WHO'S ALSO IN SUPPORT -- WE SO
AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT HAS
ENJOYED A BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AS IT IS MOVED TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ARE HOPING TO HAVE THE SAME
AS IT MOVES THROUGH THE SENATE
THE PROGRAM THAT.
WE ARE LOOKING TO CREATE HERE IS
A PARALLEL PROGRAM WITH IN THE
CIP -- WHICH WAS EXTENDED LAST
SESSION. TO ALLOW FOR THIS
PROGRAM -- TO ABOUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OFFER INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS FOR MANUFACTURERS THAT
ARE INVESTING FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE -- IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WE THINK THAT THIS
IT PROVIDES AN EXCELLENT MODEL
THAT PROVIDES A WIN WIN WIN FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY AND FOR MANUFACTURERS.
FOR MANUFACTURERS WE SEE WE
RECEIVE -- AN INCENTIVE PAYMENT
IN THE BASEMENT ON THE THAT'S
VALUE BASED ON THE PROPERTY TAX
THAT WE BRING TO THE COMMUNITY.
FOR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT THEY'RE
ALLOWED.
TO COMPETE IN ATTRACT
MANUFACTURING INVESTMENT THAT
THEY WOULD NOT RECEIVE OTHERWISE
FOR THE LOCAL.
COMMUNITY -- THE CIP REQUIRES A
COMMUNITY SERVICE PAYMENT THAT
REPAIR IS PAID TO CREATE A
DIRECT BENEFIT -- AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM MORE -- WE SEEM
SEVERAL EXAMPLES LIKE A PARK
THAT THE COMMUNITY WOULD BENEFIT
FROM -- DIRECTLY.
ALSO.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
NECESSARY -- BECAUSE THE CITY
ITSELF -- IS TARGETED TOWARDS
MAKE IT INVESTMENT OF A HOW A
GEAR TOWARDS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE.
THIS JUST ISN'T MATCHING WHERE
THE MANUFACTURING INDUSTRIES
TODAY WE SEE THE MOST INVESTMENT
THE MOST JOB CREATION THE MOST
BENEFIT IS FOR MANUFACTURING
ABOUT SOME BETWEEN FIVE TO FIFTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN FACT.
THAT INVESTMENT IS -- ABOUT
PREACH ABOUT FOUR TIMES THE ONE
OF JOBS CREATED -- FROM BEST OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE -- MANUFACTURING
HAS BEEN THE ENGINE OF EQUITY --
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS THE ENGINE
OF EQUITY FOR MAJOR CITIES FROM
SAN FRANCISCO -- TO FAIRFIELD --
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO AND
ONE OF OUR SEIZE DISTRICT IN --
BRAWLEY -- AND SO WE THINK THAT.
THE ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO HAVE THIS TOOL INCORPORATE
THIS IN THEIR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PLANS WILL ALLOW
THEM -- TO FURTHER SEE THE
BENEFITS OF THIS -- ECONOMIC
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A COOK
THANK YOU FOR BEING HRE.
THAT VISITORS ANYONE ELSE'S FOR
THE BILL PIC PLEASE COME FOR
THIS TIME.
LOOKING FOR SUPPORT PERSON
LASSEN ORGANIZATION.
PERRANCE THE NUMBER NOW TO TURN
OVER OPPOSITION.
NOT ALL AT ONCE PLEASE.
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
CONVERSATION SO BY SHEER.
RIGHT.
IN DOING.
A REVIEW OF THE BILL I I SEE
THAT.
WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE ONE
MANUFACTURER YET THAT'S TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS.
OPPORTUNITY TO IS THAT CORRECT.
WE HAVE HAD MANUFACTURERS THAT
HAVE STARTED -- IN ENTER INTO
AGREEMENTS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS -- BUT IT HASN'T
THEY HAVEN'T COMPLETED THAT YET
IT DUE TO DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES A LOT OF THESE ARE
OUR DEFENSE CONTRACTORS IN THE
BIDDING PROCESS THEN THE BLUES
IN THE CONTRACT -- AND WE HINK
THAT'S PART OF WHY THIS PROGRAM
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL -- WE DON'T
SEE A LOT OF MANUFACTURING
INVESTMENT AT THE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR MORE LEVEL
NATIONWIDE IT'S ONLY ABOUT 4% OF
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA -- SO
THE FIVE TO FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR RANGE IS ABOUT A THIRD OF
OF INVESTMENT SO.
THAT'S PART OF WHY OF EVERYTHING
AS IT.
IS IS THAT -- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
STUDIES FROM THE ALLEY OVER
GOBIZ OR ANYONE THAT SAYS WHY
THIS IS WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THIS
IS.
THE RESULT -- AND SO WE WE HAVE
SEEN A THIS YEAR I WE HAD A BILL
TO TO DEAL WITH -- CITIES THAT
WE'RE GIVING MASSIVE SALES TAX
REBATES.
TO RETAIL WAREHOUSES WHICH BOY
WE STOPPED THAT PRACTICE THOSE
CITIES ARE GOING TO BE LEFT HIGH
AND DRY -- IT'S GONNA BE REAL
AWKWARD BUT I'M I'M SO SO
LOOKING AT THAT IS AS THE YOU
KNOW THE POTENTIAL FOR ABUSE OF
A STEP -- THE FIRST WAS NOW
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE MAYBE TWO
CITIES COMPETING AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
YOU KNOW WHO'S GONNA OFFER THE
BASTROP THEY ARE FOR THE SAME.
AND THE OTHER WAS WHAT DO YOU DO
FOR THOSE.
THAT DID INVEST.
AND HAVE BUILT THEIR
MANUFACTURING BUSINESS A CITY
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN A
COMPETITOR COMES AND GETS ALL
THESE BENEFITS.
AND THEN PUTS THEM AT A
DISADVANTAGE.
WHICH THEY DON'T THEY DON'T HAVE
SO WE DO FOR PRE EXISTING.
MEMBERS OF YOUR ORGANIZATION
[inaudible]
SO -- TO IN TERMS OF THE ISSUE
WITH DATA IS THAT WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF A CHICKEN AND EGG
PROBLEM IN THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE GOOD DATA BECAUSE
WE HAVEN'T HAD A GOOD PROGRAM
THAT WOULD SORT OF GEARED
TOWARDS WERE IN THE INVESTMENT
IS A WE DO ADD MORE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE SMALLER
INVESTMENT IN THIS PROGRAM AND
SO -- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL
HAVE TO REPORT OUT -- THE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY THAT'S
GENERATED BY THESE INVESTMENTS
AS WELL AS THE DIRECT BENEFIT TO
THE COMMUNITY SO.
HOPEFULLY WHAT WE WILL GET IS
MORE INFORMATION THAT WILL HELP
US IN THE FUTURE IF WE CHOOSE TO
EXPAND THIS PROGRAM.
THEN IS ELIMINATE THE CALIFORNIA
DO WE HAVE ANY PROGRAMS OF THIS
NATURE IN OTHER STATES WHERE WE
CAN SAY ALL THIS IS WHAT IT.
THIS IS HOW BENEFITTED IN AND WE
CAN HAVE SOME HARD DATA YES ALSO
THERE ARE SEVERAL STATES THAT
HAVE -- EITHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE
LIKE A SIP OR JUST IS FLAT OUT
IN INDUSTRIALIZATION
REVITALIZATION INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS -- AND NBC THAT IN --
OF THOUGHT MY HEAD I CAN THINK
OF KENTUCKY INDIANA VIRGINIA
GEORGIA -- AND I BELIEVE BY THAT
TO MY OFFICE DEFINITELY OFF
TODAY I I DON'T WANT TO CREATE A
PROBLEM.
THE THE RULE OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SOLELY OFF OF DO
SOME MORE RESEARCH.
IN AND SEE IF I I'M SATISFIED
WHEN IT GETS TO THE FLOOR
ALTHOUGH I DON'T THINK I'LL MAKE
A DIFFERENCE.
BUT I'M JUST I JUST WANNA BE
CAREFUL.
NO THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR I
NEED TO GO THROUGH -- MR GARCIA
WOULD AFFECT ME TO DO IS WHEN
YOU DO COMMUNICATE IF YOU COULD
JUST MAKE SURE THAT -- YOU COPY
A GOVERNMENT FINANCE ON THAT TO
ALSO PROVIDED TO THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEES WE ALWAYS USE -- JUST
A STANDARD FOR COMMITTEE JUST
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE SEES
EVERYTHING COMING IN.
WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE IF IN
REALLY APPRECIATE AT MISTER VICE
CHAIRS -- QUESTIONS ON THIS END
AGREE FOR FREE BRING IN A FOR
THANK YOU TO SEE IF PLEASE
CENTER ABOUT -- IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE TAKING AMENDMENTS THE
WILL.
PRECLUDE US FROM ALLEN IMPACT.
ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN -- PERHAPS
MAYBE WE CAN GET.
AN EXPLANATION ABOUT HOW THIS
BILL WOULD IMPACTS SCHOOLS --
AND IS IT -- THE ARE THERE
DIFFERENT THERE'S DIFFERENT
TYPES OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS BASIC
A SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
OF OTHER OTHER KINDS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DOES IT IMPACT THOSE
KINDS OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DIFFERENTLY [inaudible]
AND IN TERMS OF THINGS LIKE DEBT
SERVICE OTHER KINDS OF THINGS.
SO CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW IT
IMPACTS THE SCHOOLS.
THERE WAS AN AMENDMENT I DON'T
KNOW IF THE MEMBER COVERED DISH --
SO IT SHOULDN'T IMPACT SCHOOL
FUNDING AT ALL -- THE WAY THAT
IT WORKS IS THAT WE HAVE THE THE
VALUE OF THE INCENTIVE PAYMENT
IS BASED ON THE PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE -- THAT THE MANUFACTURER
PAYS TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT VAN TAKES
PERMITS GENERAL POT OF MONEY
THAT IT HAS -- AND INCREASE THE
INCENTIVE PAYMENT BASED ON THAT
SO.
I GUESS IT'S IT COMES OUT OF ITS
GENERAL FUNDING AND ENDED WITH
AN AT THE ROOT THE ITEM SIX IN --
PAGE FIVE OF A STAFF REPORTS
ABOUT SCHOOLS.
HAVING TO PAY ANYTHING FOR THAT --
YES -- L. IS A 100% CORRECT THAT
THE THE AMENDMENT -- MEANS THAT
SCHOOLS CANNOT PROVIDE FUNDING
FROM THERE GENERAL FUND TO
MANUFACTURES -- FUND FOR THE
GENERAL FUND -- IN -- OTHER
SPECIAL DISTRICTS CAN'T BUT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD BE
PRECLUDED -- UNDER THIS BILL.
SO IF SCHOOLS A PROPERTY TAX.
ARRANGEMENT WITH THE COUNTY.
THAT IS NOT COUNTED.
LIKE SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
ARRANGEMENTS WITH COUNTIES AND
CITIES ON XTO -- PROPERTY TAXES
SO THAT'S NOT INCLUDED
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I DON'T BELIEVE SO OUR TO FIGURE
OT OF A DOZEN AND I THINK THE
AMENDMENT ADDRESSES YOUR
QUESTION AND DOOR CONCERN WELL.
I'M LOOKING TO THE AIR IN THE
CONSULTANT GUY ABSOLUTE SIDE
TALKING MISSIONS PIECE IN AGAIN.
CORRECT -- NO IMPACT AS WELL.
IN WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS THAT
MISTER PETERSON'S GOING TO
FOLLOW UP.
WITH THE DETAILS IN THE MOMENT
THAT WILL GO TO COMMITTEES BUT
UNDER THE AMENDMENT. TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I SHOULD SAY
AS WELL AS THE AUTHORS OFFICE --
SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- WILL NOT BE
IMPACTED AND OR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE JUST.
PRIOR TO THIS AMENDMENT LIKE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE.
LIKE IN ANY EDUCATIONAL.
ASSESSMENT -- WERE.
COMMUNITY CALL LETTERS OR
THERE'S OTHER KINDS OF
INSTITUTIONS OF FUND SCHOOLS.
THROUGH THE PROPERTY TAX SO
PRIOR TO THAT WE DO NOT.
HAVE THAT CLEAR.
THAT WAS KIND OF WONDERING WHY
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
HAD NO POSITION ON THIS BILL. TO
BE DETERMINED ON THAT ONE AND
THEY HAVE NO PRISONERS.
THEY DIDN'T OKAY I'M I'M JUST
ASKING THE QUESTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTRE BELL
VERY GRATEFUL.
WOULD LIKE TO IT MR BY CHER
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
ARE PUTTING ON MY CPA PRO
BUSINESS HAD AND I BRING ON MY
COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
HAD SO FOR MY COUNTY SUPERVISOR
AT 9092% OF OUR COUNTY REVENUES
ARE NOW PROPERTY TAXES
[inaudible]
SO.
IN TRYING TO SEE IF I WOULD WANT
TO ADOPT THIS POLICY -- I I
WOULD ENCOURAGE MANUFACTURED
COMMENDED TAPPED INTO TOWN BUT I
WOULD THEN LOSE REVENUES
[inaudible]
AND HOW WOULD I MAKE IT OUT
BECAUSE IF I HAVE MORE EMPLOYEE
MORE PEOPLE EMPLOYED WHICH IS
GOOD.
BUT THEN I HAVE TO HOUSE THEM
WHICH IS WHICH I DON'T HAVE NOW.
AND THE GUY GENERATE SALES TAX
WHICH I DON'T GET AS AS AS A
COUNTY.
IT'S ALSO HOW HOT HEADS FOR THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS HOW DID HOW
DOES THIS.
WORK HOW DO I HELP YOU.
HELP THIS WORK.
BACK AT IF IF I MAY REPRESENTING
THE UP COUNTY.
YOUR NOR YOU I APOLOGIZE
REPRESENT THE COMING WITH THE
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AT 60% OF PRO
COUNTY THAT IS -- THESE ARE THE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT TO TRY TO STIMULATE
ECONOMIC INVESTMENT INTO THE
REGION.
AND SO WHAT YOU KNOW YOU LOOK AT
THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS OF
CREATING.
COUPLE HUNDRED JOBS -- PEOPLE
THAT WILL THEN ADD BY HOME AND
ULTIMATELY HAVE SOME DISPOSABLE.
INCOME TO SPEND THEIR LOCALLY --
THOSE ARE THE DECISIONS THAT ARE
MADE BY THE LOCAL JURISDICTION
AT TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT --
PROVIDING THIS TYPE OF INCENTIVE
IS WORTHWHILE IN THE CASE OF A
COUNTY LIKE A PRO COUNTY THERE
CERTAINLY LOOKING AT THIS AS A
TOOL -- GIVEN THAT REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES ARE GONE ENTERPRISE
ZONES -- WERE DONE AWAY WITH --
THAT THIS MAY BE A WAY TO HELP
WILD INVEST IN THE REGION AND
TURN AROUND THOSE -- ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAVE PLAGUED
THIS COUNTY HISTORICALLY AGAIN --
AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CELEBRATES THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES IN QUITE SOME
TIME OF THE QUEUE WE HAVE A
REGION THAT -- IS PLAYED WITH
FOUR TIMES THE AMOUNT SO
ULTIMATELY IT'S A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
A DECISION RIGHT TO MAKE THESE
AND INVESTMENTS ARE THESE
AGREEMENTS AND THAT DIED.
THE HOPE THAT HELPS KIND OF
UNDERSTAND WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE SPECIFICALLY AND UNIQUELY TO
THE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT.
DOMINANT GARCIA IS VERY
PERSUASIVE THANK YOU.
GIVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WE ALSO WELCOME THE MOTION ON
THIS BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SEN HER
TITLE ON A. B. TWELVE FORTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
THE MANAGER PREPARATIONS LAST
CALL FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
WOULD LIKE BETTER TURN OVER THE
SUMMER FOR THE BETTER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON THE MATTER
AND RESPECT AS RIVAL THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MEMBER -- OUR
FOLLOW UP FROM THIS ITEM IS THAT
THAT WILL WORK WITH THE SOME
MEMBERS OFFICE TO BE ABLE TO GET
THOSE QUESTIONS BY THE VICE
CHAIR.
WASABI CENTER AROUND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
CLARIFYING -- SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES TRICKS
WITH -- SOME ANALYSIS BY MISTER
PETERSON THE CONSULTANT ON THE
BILL IS LANCASTER IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WIRE BY WIRE I'M MORE LOCK.
BELL.
WELL I HERTZBERG RICARDO RICARDO
AYE NIELSEN.
THE FOOD AYE WIENER AYE WIENER
AYE. FIVE TWO ZERO LAYS IN
GENERAL MARIN KEEP THAT WERE
STILL.
ON CALL AN ADVERSE AS THEY COME
IN.
THERE'S A GENERAL COMMITTEE WE
HAVE THREE AUTHORS ARE GRATEFUL
THAT THEY'RE HERE WE'RE GONNA
START WITH ITEM TWENTY SOME
NEVER CHAIN NUMBER AND GO TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FRIEDMAN NEVER GONNA GO TO ITEM
NUMBER.
SIX SOME MEMBER Q..
SO -- WE WELCOME AS A MEMBER
CHEN AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN I CAN
SHARE A SIMILAR YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AS WELL ON
THIS BILL SO IT'S GOOD NEWS THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND MEMBERS.
I WANNA START OF AFFECTING THE
COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
I REALLY PRESSURE EXPERTISE
EXCEPT ALL THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
OTHER OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT WE HOPE TO
SEE BRAVE REFERRED ITS TAX
DOLLARS BACK TO THEIR PARAMEDIC
PROGRAM.
THERE ARE MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS A PAST VOTER APPROVED
LOCAL TAXES TO FUND PARAMEDIC
PROGRAMS ARE RUN THROUGH THEIR
FIRE DEPARTMENTS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THE VOTERS AND
BRAVE PRINTED PARAMEDIC TAX TO
FUND PARAMEDIC SERVICES.
IN THE CITY THE INTENT OF THE
TAX WAS THE FINANCE LOCAL
PARAMEDIC PROGRAM.
WENT REDEVELOPMENT WAS CREATED
IN THE PORTION OF THE PARAMEDIC
TAPS WAS CAPTURED BY THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY AND IS A
VERSION REMAINS IN EFFECT TODAY.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN RESTORE
100% OF THE TERMINATE TAX TO
FUND THE PARAMEDIC PROGRAM WHICH
IS ITS FIRST INTENDED PURPOSE.
THE OUTSTANDING REDEVELOPMENT
OBLIGATIONS WOULD PAY FOR FROM
OTHER TAX REVENUE RESOURCES FROM
THE CITY OF BREA.
THEREFORE THE PAYMENT TASCAM
ALLOCATED FOR THE PURPOSE
INTENDED BY THE VOTERS. FOR A
PARAMEDIC PROGRAM.
THERE HAVE ISSUE BILLS OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ADOPTED IN THE
PAST THAT DEAL WITH SIMILAR
VOTER APPROVED TAXES AND THIS
BILL WILL ADD PERMITTED PROGRAMS
TO THAT LIST.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS
COUNCIL MEMBER CECILIA HOSTAGE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IS ALSO
A FIRE CHIEF THE ZEBRA AND ADAM
LOANS SHARES OF PRECISION MANTRA
BILL GRAY ARTEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOME
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS FOR
AND TURN OVER THE COUNCILMAN
COUNCILMAN WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HANGING WITH US WE APOLOGIZE
ABOUT THE DELAY.
NO PROBLEM YOU HAVE TO MAKE IT
TWO MINUTES MA'AM AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BLIND SHADE I'D LIKE
TO START BY GIVING YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND ON THE CITY OF
BREA.
I'M IT WE'RE ONE OF THE SMALLEST
CITIES AND ONE OF THE OLDEST
CITIES IN NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
WE'RE ON NESTLED IN THE HILLS
SCIENCE BORDERED BY AND
INCORPORATED LA COUNTY AND SAN
BENITO COUNTY.
WHEN THIS UP TAX WAS PASSED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WE WERE
CITY OF SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE WE HAVE SINCE GROWN TO
OVER FORTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE?
WITH A DAYTIME POPULATION THAT
EXCEEDS A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND SO OUR NEEDS ON ON UP
PARAMEDIC HAVE CHANGED
SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE THIS TAX WAS
PASSED -- WE I LOST MY TRAIN OF
THOUGHT THERE I'M SORRY I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT 81% OF OUR FIRE
CALLS RIGHT NOW ARE PARAMEDIC.
SO BY RESTORING THE FULL AMOUNT
OF THIS TAX INCREMENTS FOR WHAT
THE VOTERS INTENDED IT TO BE WE
WILL NOT HAVE TO BACK FILL THE
PROGRAM WITH APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION.
OF OUR GENERAL FUND WHICH WOULD
ALLOW US TO DO A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS WITHOUT MONEY.
SO IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS WE
ARE HERE TO ANSWER THEM.
CONSUMER THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GONNA HOLD QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FOR ONE MOMENT WE'RE GOING TO
ALLOW FOLKS TO BE ABLE -- TO
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
COMES THAT WORKS FOR YOU AND
AGAIN WE WILL COMMUNICATE ANY
THANK YOU -- IN APPRECIATE ALL
THE HARD WORK BY THIS IN MEN AS
WELL WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO GET A
WELCOME ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR
THIS TIME.
WE LOOK AT THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
LAST CALL NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
GET A LOOK FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN OPPOSITION.
GLASCOFF OPPOSITION.
WOULD LIKE TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
WILL START WITH A VICE CHAIR AND
GO TO SENATE ABOUT. ONE QUICK
QUESTION IS ROMAN CHEN HI HOW
DID.
HOW DID THIS GET INTERTWINED
WITH ART WITH REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AT?
BECAUSE AS A FORMER TAX
COLLECTOR JUST WOULDN'T KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
REDEVELOPMENT AREAS ALL OF THE
TAX INCREMENTS.
IS DEDICATED TO PAYING OFF WITH
JUST THE TAXI INDEBTEDNESS RIGHT
TO THE PARAMEDICS RIGHT.
IT'S IT'S NO IT'S ALL IT'S ALL
THE PROPERTY TAX INCLUDING THE
PARAMEDIC TAX IN THE
REDEVELOPMENT AREAS IS BEING
USED TO PAY OFF THE BOND DEBT
FOR THE REDEVELOPMENT AREAS WE
DON'T NEED THE PARAMEDIC TAX
PORTION OF IT. TO PAY OFF THAT
DEBT WE HAVE SUFFICIENT FUNDS TO
PAY IT OFF WITHOUT THE PARAMEDIC
TAX IN THAT AREA.
JUST A CASUALTY OF THE IT
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY AND
SOMETHING NEAR AND DEAR TO YOUR
HEART IS THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO TAKE SOME OF THOSE SAVINGS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO GO
TOWARDS PAYING DOWN OUR UNFUNDED
PENSION LIABILITY. TO REALLY
PULL.
WELL I WILL TELL YOU A BRAILLE
WAS THE FIRST ORANGE COUNTY CITY
TO SET UP A PARS ACCOUNT FOR
UNFUNDED LIABILITY WITH SIX
MILLION THAT HAS GROWN IN THREE
YEARS TO SEVEN POINT FOUR AND WE
JUST ADDED ANOTHER SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND TO IT.
MOST OF ORANGE COUNTY HAS
FOLLOWED SUIT SO YOU OF BRIGHT
CATNIP FOR AYE MR MORLOCK SO HEY
THERE WE GO.
IT'S GOOD STUFF.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR.
WHERE TO TURN OVER TO CENTER
ABOUT?
JUST HAD A SUMMER COURSE IN THE
LAST -- ONE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THIS BILL -- BY.
ADOPTING THE BILL WILL.
IMPACT SCHOOL FUNDING BY
DEFERRING.
PROPERTY TAXES THAT OTHERWISE.
GO FROM THE SUCCESSOR AGENCY TO
WRECKED PROPERTY TAX THE WOULD
GO TO SCHOOLS.
IS THAT CORRECT.
AB.
CHAIRED BY MAY I ANSWER THE
QUESTION SO LET US INTRODUCE
YOURSELF ARSON LASSEN ORGAN OF
JAIL GUARD A CITY MANAGER FOR
CITY OF BREA.
WHAT WAS NOT IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IS THE CITY BRAY HAS
TAKEN SIGNIFICANT STEPS OVER THE
PAST THREE YEARS TO LOWER OUR
ENFORCEABLE OBLIGATIONS?
IN OTHER WORDS GIVE BACK TO THE
TAXING ENTITIES.
JUST TWO YEARS AGO WE LOWERED
OUR DEBT SERVICE ABOUT TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
BENEFIT OF THE TAXING ENTITIES
WITHIN THE NEXT TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS THE ENFORCEABLE
OBLIGATIONS WILL DROP ANOTHER
TWO POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS I
KNOW I KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE DOING
THAT.
SURE BECAUSE YOU'RE REQUIRED TO
BY STATE LAW CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT INTEREST YOUR
YOUR YOU'RE REQUIRED TO DO THAT
BECAUSE OF YOUR CREATION OF
SUCCESSES AGENCY AND OTHERS A
PLAN. FOR THE SUCCESS OR AGENCY
RIGHT TO REDUCE.
THE PROPERTY TAX SO WHAT I'M
SAYING IS [inaudible]
BY.
THE FRIEND OUT AND THEN EITHER
STANDARDS. FIVE OTHER CITIES IS
THAT ALL WE KNOW THERE MIGHT BE
MORE.
THERE MIGHT BE MORE CITIES IT
LOOKS LIKE FREMONT SAN ANSELMO.
REDLANDS IN GARDEN GROVE.
IN WHAT IS YOUR LIMON IN THIS
JUST TO THE CITY BREA.
YEAH YEAH THE CENTER WHICH IS
WHAT IF WE DO THIS FOR THEM IT.
IT MAY APPLY TO OTHER WE MAY SEE
OTHERS COMING FOR TARA FOR FOR
THE SAME REASON SO WHICH KIND OF
SET THE PRESS.
SO SO IT WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON
SCHOOLS.
I WAS QUITE HEAVY HAVE YOU
COMMITTED WITH THE SCHOOLS ON
THIS ISSUE.
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT RAIL INTO
SCHOLARSHIP UNDERSTANDS WHAT
WE'RE DOING.
THERE SUPPORTIVE OF IT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
OF THE TAKEN IF NOT TAKEN A
POSITION HAVEN'T OKAY THEY JUST.
THEY'RE LETTING THE PROPERTY TAX
BE DIVERTED.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU WE BELIEVE IT'S GOING
TO BE.
NO THANK YOU YEAH IT'S IT'S A
ROUGH ESTIMATE ABOUT
500-260-01000 DOLLARS
APPROXIMATE -- AGAIN APPROXIMATE
NUMBER THAT WERE AT WE'RE TAKING
A LOOK AT ON ALL RIGHT.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONVERSATION -- FROM
THE COMMITTEE ON THIS ISSUE ON
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN ITEM.
TWENTY ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR THIS MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS A MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE.
RESPECT RESTAURANT ON OVER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS AND WE WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THINK OF THE
COUNCILMEN CITY MANAGER FOR
BEING HERE AS WELL IT'S GOOD TO
HAVE YOU IN COMMITTEE TODAY.
AGAIN DO PASSES AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS AS LANCASTER CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI WHERE I'M MORE LOCK LOCK AYE
BELL.
I HEARD THERE RICARDO.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
AYE WIENER HI.
CURRENTLY YOU IS A SIX YEAR VOTE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THINK SO MUCH
THAT YOU REMEMBER VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU ALL.
ALRIGHT LADIES ARE NOW MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE THIS IS AB
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN THIS IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
WERE THEN GOING TO GO TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB SIX HUNDRED SOME
EVER TIãU.
THEY WERE GOING TO GO TO ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
ONE SOME NUMBER WARNER FOR BACK.
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO MISS
FRIEDMAN ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT MA'AM THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIMILAR WORK WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL -- THAT WE WILL TAKE
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS.
THIS IS A VERY GOOD AT YOU BILL
THAT HAS HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION AND WHAT
IT DOES IS IT BUILDS ON A VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM AT HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY DEVELOPED AND THEY
ARE THE ONES WHO BROUGHT THE
IDEA FOR THE BILL TO US -- IN
SANTA CRUZ WHERE THEY WERE ABLE
TO BUILD THE WAY THEY NORMALLY
DO BUILD A HOUSE AND THEN THEY
BUILT IN EIGHTY YOU BEHIND THAT
HOUSE AND WHAT THEY'RE ALLOWED
TO DO IN SANTA CRUZ IS A DIFF
SUBDIVIDE THOSE LOTS EVEN THOUGH
NORMALLY YOU CAN'T SUBDIVIDE A
SINGLE FAMILY.
LOT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
ALLOWS LOCALITIES IF THEY SO
CHOOSE TO PARTNER WITH NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS LIKE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY AND SET UP A PROCESS BY
WHICH THEY COULD SELL THE FRONT
HOUSE.
AN EITHER SELL THE EIGHTY YOU
TO ANOTHER LOW INCOME FAMILIES
OR IF THEY CHOOSE TO RETAIN IT
THEMSELVES AND RENTED OUT AS A
LOW INCOME RENTAL THIS IS AN OPT
IN FOR COMMUNITIES.
THE COMMUNITIES WHEN IT COMES TO
HABITAT ANOTHER LOW INCOME
DEVELOPERS ARE THE PARTNERS WITH
THESE DEVELOPERS SO YOU'RE DOING
THIS WITH THE CONSENT OF THE
LOCALITY BUT IN MANY LOCALITIES
SUCH AS LOS ANGELES THERE WAS NO
WAY THERE IS NO MECHANISM TO DO
THIS.
SO WE WORKED ALSO WITH THE TOP
WITH -- JEFF PRANG THE ASSESSOR
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY COULD
DEAL WITH ALL OF THE TAX
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE WE COULD
CLEAR THE WAY TO ALLOW MORE OF
THESE INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IS SO SAD
ABOUT IT OUT FOR OUR FROM
HABITAT FOR ME FOR HUMANITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT THE MOMENT
WE DO A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL -- IN AT DO APPRECIATE
THAT WORK WITH US A CINNAMON
TRULY ON THE ISSUE.
OF THE CONNECTION IS WELL WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT PLEASE OF
FORESHORES ME.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AS A MATTER
THAT HERE BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY -- CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
PROUD SPONSORS OF THE BILL THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY -- AS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FRIEDMAN STATED AS YOU ALL KNOW
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF HOUSING
CRISIS AN ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS ARE JUST ONE TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
I'M WE BELIEVE THAT AB FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN IS A MODEST
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THIS
CRISIS BY CREATING AN AIR
EXEMPTION TO THE EIGHTY WILL LAW.
AND ALLOWING NON PROFITS LIKE
HABITAT -- TO DOUBLE THE NUMBER
OF IT AVAILABLE HOMES WHILE
PROVIDING HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
AND BY ALLOWING OWNERSHIP OF
THESE INDIVIDUAL UNITS WITH A
TENANTS IN COMMON AGREEMENT IT
GIVES THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE SOME MODEST EQUITY IN
THOSE HOMES [inaudible]
I'M.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT -- UNDER
THIS MODEL WITH THE BLESSING OF
THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY SANTA CRUZ MONTEREY
BAY HAS BEEN.
ABLE TO DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF
HOMES THAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BUILD FROM FOUR TO EIGHT AND WE
KNOW THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
BUILD TWELVE INSTEAD OF SIX ON A
NEWLY DONATED PLOT OF LAND.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
MODEL NOT ONLY -- FOR
COMMUNITIES -- COASTAL
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO THOSE THAT
ARE REBUILDING AFTER NATURAL
DISASTERS SUCH AS BUTTE COUNTY
WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR AFFILIATE
AND YOU COUNTY THAT THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO BUILD SIX INSTEAD OF
THREE HOMES UNDER THIS MODEL.
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO SPEAK ON THE
BILL TODAY AND AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY NOW LIKE TO
BETTER TURN OVER TO THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT FIRST LAST
ORGANIZATION GOOD MORNING YES
GOOD MORNING JESSICA GAGO WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES WE JUST WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
TAKING THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
DAY THEY REMOVE.
ALL OF OUR OPPOSITION OUR
CONCERNS ROUTE RATHER RELATED TO
THE UTILITY CONNECTIONS AND
ONGOING SERVICE THAT THANK YOU
THE TRAINING WITH US
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
WHAT'S GOING ON MORNING MALLORY
SPOKE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
LIKE VISITORS ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE REMOVED
FOR BUT THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED
TO PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE AND ITEM NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN WELCOME
CONVERSATION OR MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE FLOOR.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OUR CONVERSATION OF
COMMITTEE.
CURRENCY NOTICING ONLY LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SONORA THANK
YOU SIR IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
I REQUIRE.
WELL LIKE I FELT NO I HERTZBERG
RICARDO.
LARA AYE NIELSEN.
YES AND I WIENER.
WIENER AYE. SIX YOUR VOTE TO
COMMITTEES IN TWO DAYS FOR THE
SETTLEMENT ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU NICE JOB.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BECAUSE YOU.
GREAT WORK OUT.
NOW TO BE MOVING ON TO AB SIX
HUNDRED THIS IS A MEMBER CHIU.
ITEM NUMBER SIX WE WELCOME THE
ASSN NEVER TO COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE --
HAS TO THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR
THEY WERE GONNA GO IN TURN OVER
TO LOOSEN THE WOMAN BORDER
FORMAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER
CHAIR THE AND SENATORS SB SIX
HUNDRED WILL CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE
IN CURRENT LAW.
BY PREVENTING CITIES FROM DOING
SELECTIVE AN EXHORTATION TO
AVOID ANNEXING A NEARBY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL TO
CLARIFY THE CITY MUST OFFER AND
NEXT TO DISADVANTAGED BERMAN
INCORPORATED A COMMUNITIES WHERE
ANNEXING NEARBY TERRITORY THEY
ARE INDIVIDUALLY LAST STAND TEN
ACRES.
BUT TOTAL MORE THAN TEN ACRES
WITHIN FIVE YEARS. FOR FOR TO
LONG MANY OF THOSE -- VULNERABLE
COMMUNITY THROUGH ALL CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN LEFT BEHIND.
GENERAL GENERALLY SPEAKING THOSE
OMMUNITIES ARE HOME TO PEOPLE'S
OFF COLORED WHO ARE LOW INCOME
AND THE FACE POLITICAL ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL GAPS DATA NEGATIVE
NEGATIVELY IMPACT YOUR LIFE THE
HOLE -- THIS IS THE WORD IN THE
FIFTH.
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND
THAT THIS BILL WILL MOVE A A
SMALL STRAP TO ME TO ENSURE.
THE ALL CALIFORNIA HOUSES THE
CLEAN RELIABLE DRINKING WATER.
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTTO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
IS -- JULIA JORDAN FROM THE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
A CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER.
WELCOME IS JORDAN WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE HERE YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO FLOOR SHORES.
THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- MY
NAME IS JULIE JORDAN LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY -- WE WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
IN THE EASTERN COACHELLA
VALLEY'S.
MANY OF THE RESIDENTS THAT WE
WORK WITH OUR LIVING IN
DISADVANTAGED UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES A LACK ACCESS TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER AND ADEQUATE
WASTE WATER SYSTEMS.
AS WELL AS OTHER BASIC SERVICES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE DESPITE THE
FACT THAT MANY OF THEM ARE IN
VERY CLOSE PROXIMITY TO OR
SURROUNDED BY CITIES THAT
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES.
HISTORICAL AND PERSISTENT
NEGLECTED UNDER INVESTMENT IN
LOW INCOME UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
UNDERMINES THE STATE'S EQUITY
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH PRIORITIES.
EACH PLANNING AND LAND USE
DECISION AS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO MOVE FORWARD IN ACHIEVING
SAFE ADEQUATE AND EQUITABLE
SERVICES FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
SB SIX HUNDRED BY ENSURING THAT
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE ABLE
TO SHARE IN THE BENEFITS OF AN
ADJACENT ANNEXATION.
IS ONE SIMPLE STEP THAT WE CAN
TAKE TOWARDS THESE GOALS. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TEST
INSTRUMENTS GOOD TO SEE YOU WHEN
I WOULD LIKE TO BETTER TURNED
OVER TO THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT OF BILL FIRST LAST NAME
ORGANIZATION GOOD MORNING.
MORNING THE END OF US AS WITH
CALIFORNIA FROM SAYS SCIENCE
OFTEN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU THANKS FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
HEY GOOD MORNING.
MICHELLE RIGHT WITH THAT THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND THE
CENTER FOR CLIMATE ODD.
SORRY CLIMATE CHANGE AND HEALTH
IN SUPPORT OF ALL RIGHT ON THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
WATCH OUT MORNING FROM RYAN
ADDRESSED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND ALSO
CONVEYING THE SUPPORT OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
THANK YOU MISTER GUESTS.
GOOD MORNING MORNING CAME WHEN
DEAN WITH POLICY LINK IN THE
LINES FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH RAIN WITH US TODAY.
THEY GO TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT THE BILL IF YOU
CAN COME ON DOWN WOULD LOVE TO
TALK.
TO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE WHO'S IN OPPOSITION.
WELCOME WHAT HAVE YOU COME JOIN
US HERE AT THE FRONT.
THE SWISS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA LEFT COVERED BODY.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE THE FORESHORES ON
A. B..
SIX HUNDRED YOU KNOW MANY
INTRODUCING YOURSELF AS WELL.
WHOA -- THE CHAIR OF THE LAW --
AND WE LOST A WHEEL.
NOT THE FIRST TIME THE WHEELS OF
FALLEN OFF FOR CAL AFTER -- SO
IT'S OKAY WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
WHAT WE SWAP OUT THAT WE DO SAID
THE WHEELS FELL OFF [inaudible]
BE CAREFUL.
WE'RE GONNA SWAP OUT THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA TURN THAT OVER TO
THE PIT CREW HERE IN A SECOND
[inaudible]
OUR SERVICE -- CERTAIN MODELS.
IS IT UNDER PRESSURE.
THANK YOU SERGEANTS AND DO
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AND ONCE AGAIN ALL RIGHT.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN IRES
SENATORS I AM PAMELA MILLER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION.
I WANNA THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
CHIU FOR ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE
CAL ASCO AND ALL OF OUR MEMBER
LEFT BECAUSE ACTUALLY SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF DISPARITY OF LOCAL
PUBLIC SERVICES.
ESPECIALLY FOR RESIDENTS AND
PROPERTIES LOCATED WITHIN
DISADVANTAGED UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES -- DOCKS.
WE SHARE THE NOTION THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE ADEQUATE.
AND SAFE DRINKING WATER AND
WASTEWATER FACILITIES THAT'S
NEVER BEEN A QUESTION.
I ALSO WANT TO THINK OF THE
MEMBER AND HIS STAFF.
OF FOR HAVING ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH US ABOUT OUR
CONCERNS HOWEVER WE STILL REMAIN
OPPOSED -- AGAIN WE WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR NOT OPPOSED TO THE
IDEA.
OF ENSURING SAFE INADEQUATE
DRINKING WATER HOWEVER THERE ARE
SOME SUBSTANTIAL POLICY CONCERNS
WITH SB SIX HUNDRED AS THE BILL
IS.
THE LEGISLATURE GAVE LAUGH
BECAUSE CERTAIN STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS TO FILL INCLUDING
ENSURING ORDERLY GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT.
THIS IS DONE IN A VARIETY OF
WAYS INCLUDING THE AUTHORITY TO
ADOPT SPEARS OF INFLUENCE FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES.
AND PREVENT EXHORTATIONS TO
ENSURE ORDERLY GROWTH WHEN A
LAUGH CO APPROVED A SERVICE
EXTENSION OUTSIDE THE
JURISDICTIONAL BOUNDARY BUT
WITHIN THE SPHERE THEY DO SO IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE LATER CHANGE
OF ORGANIZATION IN THIS CASE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
ANNEXATION.
CHANGES IN AB SIX HUNDRED AD THE
EXCLUSION OF AN ANNEXATION INTO
A QUALIFIED SPECIAL DISTRICT.
THE LONG STANDING POLICIES OF
ANNEXATION ARE NOT ONLY GOOD
PLANNING POLICIES IN MANY CASES
THEY ARE COMMONSENSE APPROACH TO
MANAGING LIMITED RESOURCES.
BUT LET'S LOOK AT THIS ALSO FROM
A SOCIAL JUSTICE PERSPECTIVE
RATHER THAN PLANNING PERSPECTIVE.
THESE ANNEXATION POLICIES
ACTUALLY PROTECT THE PEOPLE
RECEIVING THE SERVICES WITHOUT
ANNEXING THE TERRITORY BEING
SERVE THESE RESIDENTS DO NOT
HAVE A SAY IN WHO REPRESENTS
SOME ON THE GOVERNING BOARD OF
THE AGENCY PROVIDING THE SERVICE.
NOR DO THEY HAVE A SAY IN ANY
POTENTIAL RATE CHANGES THAT MAY
BEBE BE PUT BEFORE THE VOTERS
TAXATION WITHOUT REPRESENTATION.
OR WITHOUT A VOICE ONLY SERVES
TO FURTHER DISENFRANCHISE THESE
ALREADY DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES.
FURTHER IS THE BILL ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THE LANGUAGE DOES NOT
ACTUALLY REQUIRE THE EXTENSION
OF SERVICE IT MERELY STATES THAT
THEIR SHALL BE NO ANNEXATION.
IF THE DOT PREFERS TO ADDRESS
THE SERVICE DEFICIENCIES STERN
EXTENSION OF SERVICE.
THERE'S OF CONFLICTS AND
EXISTING STATUTE FIFTY SIX THREE
SEVEN FIVE AID TO NEW SECTION
SEE.
I'M A ALLOWS FOR CURRENT STATUE
US FOR COMMISSION POLICIES TO
GUIDE THE COMMISSION IN
DETERMINING THE SIZE OF THE AREA
TO BE ANNEXED.
WHICH ALLOWS LAUGH BECAUSE TO
CONSIDER LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND
CONDITIONS AND WE'VE REQUESTED
THAT -- THAT PROVISIONAL SO BE
ADDED IN TO SEE.
OUR I WANT TO CLOSE BY SAYING
THAT WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE A
MEMBER AND THE SPONSORS APPROACH.
TO AND TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
THIS IS NOT A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION TO A VERY LARGE PROBLEM
WHICH IS THE DRINKING WATER
ISSUE.
AND THE PROPOSED POLICIES
ACTUALLY CREATE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THE BILL GOES FAR
BEYOND THE SIMPLE STATEMENT OF
PREVENTING SMALL INDIVIDUAL
ANNEXATIONS THAT INCLUDE DUCKS
THIS BILL DOES WAY MORE THAN
THAT -- WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS
IN GOOD FAITH MADE NUMEROUS
SUGGESTIONS FOR AMENDMENTS AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE STILL REMAIN
OPPOSED AND WE MUST ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORDS
WERE HEAVY HANG WITH US RIGHT
THERE -- IN CASE WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE%
TO ADD A WELCOME. TO MAYBE IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD LOOKING FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME.
HEARING SEE NINE LAYS DOWN WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA START WITH VICE
CHAIR IN WHAT MANY OTHER
CONVERSATIONS MEISTER.
RESEARCHER I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF SERVING ON LAUGH GO FOR EIGHT
YEARS -- IN ORANGE COUNTY -- AND
I JUST MADE IT ONE OF MY
INITIATIVES. TO INCORPORATES --
ISLANDS INTO A CITY -- EVERY
YEAR I TRY TO DO ONE OR TWO IN
HIS IT WAS HARD WORK -- AND IN
THE END SOME A LOT OF SUCCESSES
ADDED WHEN REAL DISTURBING
FAILURE I'VE.
BUT I HAD -- AN APARTMENT
COMPLEX THAT WAS ON THE BORDER.
OF A CITY AND I WEEKLY WE WORK
TO GET IT INTO ONE CITY AT THE
AT THE AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY
SAID ALL WE DON'T WANT TO BE IN
THAT CITY WE WANT TO BE IN.
THE CITY NEXT DOOR I MEAN JUST
ALL KINDS OF I MEAN THIS IS A
HARD WORK IT'S EMOTIONAL IT'S
IT'S CRAZY -- BUT WE DID.
AND I I'M SITTING HERE LOOKING
AT THIS PARTICULAR BILL SIMMONS
CHIU AND I'M I'M WONDERING IF.
IT AS HARD EVERY IT WAS AS HARD
AS THIS IS -- WE WILL VICIOUS
WILL THIS BILL EVEN MAKE IT
HARDER.
AND AND THAT'S MY FEAR AFTER --
GET THE YOUR YOUR THAT YOU'LL
NEVER REACH THE GOALS IF YOU
MAKE MAKE IT SO UNTENABLE.
AND SO I I I THINK MISS MISS
MILLER HAS SOME REALLY GOOD
ARGUMENTS COULD YOU HELP ME OUT.
WELL ADDING.
THIS THIS BILL TAP ON THE HE NON
MAKING LEFT CO WORKERS AT ANY
EASIER.
L. AND M. WHEN I WAS ON THE
SOUTH THE CITY COUNCIL WHAT YOU
HAVE TO EXPERIENCE.
WORKING WITH -- WITH A LAUGH
COAL SO DEAN CAN OF THIS BILL IS
NOT REALLY MAKING THE WORK OF AN
EASIER BUT I IN RECENTLY RESPECT
AND APPRECIATE DURING INPUT.
AND DEFINITELY BE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH
PHILOSOPHICAL.
AND SEE WE CAN -- MAKE THEIR
LIFE A LITTLE BIT EASIER.
TO HARD FOR LAUGHS SO THAT THE
THE ISSUE WAS GETTING A CITY TO
STEP UP.
CITIES WOULD SAY NO.
AND AND SO I GET WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO THAT.
THEY'RE GONNA SAY NO EVEN LOUDER.
BUT WE WE DON'T NEED THOSE
ISLANDS AND I CAN I CAN GIVE YOU
A LITANY OF THE REASONS WHY.
YOURS IS IS NOT -- OF JERMAINE
PERHAPS TO ORANGE COUNTY BUT I
CAN GIVE YOU A LIST OF OTHER.
THINGS THAT THAT THAT WERE WERE
THE SEEDS WOULD SAY THERE'S
THERE'S NO WAY.
AND AND SO.
IF YOU IF YOU DON'T ALLOW.
AT LEAST SELECTIVE DANIEL YOU'RE
YOU'RE NOT GET THEIR ALL GONNA
STAY ISLANDS I DON'T KNOW
FOREVER.
THE I. R..
WITH A POSSIBILITY MAYBE MAYBE
JUST FROM MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
ARE YOU BRING BACK ALL KINDS OF
FUN MEMORIES.
IT IS THE CITIES AND I I TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE CITY MANAGER'S AND
TRY TO EXPLAIN WHY.
THIS TO BE IMPORTANT TO TO TAKE
THEM ALL IN THE END AND I TELL
YOU THAT IT WORKING WITH CITY
COUNCILS GETTING TOGETHER. FOR
BREAKFAST THIS OKAY OW DO WE
YOU KNOW DO AN EXCHANGE YOU TAKE
THAT PARCEL YOU TAKE THAT AREA.
I MEAN THERE IS [inaudible]
SO I FOR THAT REASON BECAUSE I
SEE THIS IS IS NOT -- PROVIDING
MORE INCENTIVES I SEE THIS IS A
DISINCENTIVE IN SO AYE BOBBY
PROBABLY LAYOFF OPPOSED.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER ASHER.
THAT WAY TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONVERSATIONS PLEASE CENTER TILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OF SO I REALLY WANTED THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS IN
TRYING TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE IN THE
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
AS AS YOU KNOW I'M FROM A SMALL
CITY SINGER.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I'M VERY
WELL AWARE OF THE ISSUES AND
WHAT BRINGS.
US HERE BUT I I THINK THAT THIS
BILL REALLY.
KIND OF IT CREATES CHALLENGES
THAT -- FOR THE COMMUNITIES.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THE THE
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES AND
WE'RE TRYING TO CONNECT THEM TO
SERVICES WE ALL WANT THAT IN THE
IN THE VALLEY AND DOES IT DON'T
HAPPEN -- BUT I THINK THAT IT'S
WE'RE NOT THINKING ALSO THAT
THIS THE CITY'S AT THE TRYING TO
CONNECT TO ARE ALSO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES -- SO
WHEN IT COMES TO COST IT'S IT'S
NOT THAT.
US CITIES OR COMMUNITIES DON'T
WANT TO ANACS -- UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES AS IT THEY JUST
CAN'T AFFORD IT -- AND I DON'T
SEE ANYTHING IN THIS BILL THAT
ADDRESSES THE COST -- I THINK
THAT THERE MAY BE SOME LEGAL
CHALLENGES ARE POTENTIALLY POSED
IN THIS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS BILL AND --
YOU KNOW FOR THE FOR THOSE
REASONS SIDE I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
I BELIEVE THE COST ISSUE WAS THE
ADDRESS IN THE PREVIOUS BILL
FROM LAST YEAR.
THAT THE DID THE DID THE STATE
IS PAYING FOR THE CONNECTION.
OF OF OF THE WATER TO THE
DISPROVED DISADVANTAGE
CONCOMITANT SO THIS BILL DOES
NOT IMPOSE ANY ADDITIONAL COST
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
[inaudible]
SOLD. FOR EXAMPLE IF THERE'S AN
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITY.
THAT WANTS TO BE A NEXT TO
ANOTHER CITY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
WHO WHO WHAT UP THERE'S A COST
TO ANNEXATION?
RIGHT THE CONNECTION YES
DEFINITELY SO WHO WHO WOULD PAY
FOR THAT COST OF ANY BUSINESS
DISS STATE WILL PAY.
FOR OVER MY PROOF OF A BILL FROM
LAST YEAR I CAN REMEMBER IN THE
BILL NUMBER.
SO SENATOR IF IT WORKS YOU CAN
HAVE BEEN JORDAN ALSO -- CHIME
IN ON THIS ONE PLEASE THANK YOU --
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT [inaudible]
ADD.
ANY MORE. TO THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THEN.
IS IN CURRENT LAW IT'S BASICALLY
CLOSING.
THE LOOPHOLE AROUND THEM AMOUNT
OF AREA [inaudible]
THAT'S PROPOSE FOR ANNEXATION
ALREADY EXISTING LAW ALREADY.
STATES THAT IF IF A CITY IS
ATTEMPTING TO ANNEX IN AREAS
NEAR AN ADJACENT DUCK A
DISADVANTAGE ON THE CORPORATE
COMMUNITY.
THAT IS TEN ACRES OR GREATER
THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE TO KIND
OF GO THROUGH THIS EXACT SAME
PROCESS -- SO WE'RE NOT CHANGING
ANYTHING ABOUT THE PROCESS WE'RE
NOT PROPOSING ADDITIONAL COSTS
WERE ESSENTIALLY.
JUST TRYING TO CLARIFY THE
INTENT OF PRIOR LEGISLATION SB --
TWO FORTY FOUR AND IT'S REALLY
KIND OF AS A PRETTY SIMPLE --
FIX TO SOMETHING WE SEE IS A A
PROBLEM IN CURRENT LAW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR AND WE'RE GOING TO TURN OVER
MISS MILLER I THINK THAT THE
IMPORTANT.
PIECE ON THIS IS WELL AS IT IT'S
THE TRIGGER ONLY HAPPENS WHEN IT
ANNEXATION IS ALREADY MOVING
FORWARD BUT A MISNOMER
[inaudible]
SO AM.
THE COUPLE THINGS IN TERMS OF
THE THE FINANCING OF EXTENDING
THE SERVICES THAT IS ALSO A
CONCERN OF OURS THAT IS NOT
ADDRESSED HERE.
AND THE I BELIEVE IF I
UNDERSTOOD THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CORRECTLY HE WAS REFERRING TO
THE BILL THAT WAS PASSED LAST
YEAR THAT PAYS -- FOR SHOULD BE
APPROVED BY THE WATER BOARD --
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO EXTEND THE
SERVICES BUT WHAT I'M HEARING
SENATOR HER TADO ASK ABOUT IS
THE ACTUAL ANNEXATION PROCESS
WHICH HAS TO BE PAID FOR LOCALLY
THE STATE DOES NOT PAY FOR
ANNEXATION.
AND I'M.
OF THE WAY WE'RE INTERPRETING
THIS BILL IT DOES FAR MORE THAN
LIMIT THE SIZE OF A TERRITORY TO
BE ANNEXED.
NO I APPRECIATE THAT -- SOME
EVER ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD ON
THE WAY TO GO TO CENTER BELL.
ANY ANY OTHER ITEMS YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ADD ON TO THAT BEFORE WE
GO TO SENATOR BILL.
OVER I'M I'M DEFINITELY I KNOW
THERE'S STILL SOME.
WRINKLES I HAVE TO WORK -- WAS.
TO THE LEFT WILL ALL BE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE -- WORKING WITH SOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A MEMBER
CENTERVILLE -- I'M I'M
SYMPATHETIC TO THE FISCAL ISSUES
[inaudible]
HOWEVER.
A LOT OF THE COUNTY POCKETS.
IN OUR COMMUNITY BECAUSE KANSEN
CHU REPRESENTS SAN JOSE NEEDS
SALAS A COUNCILMAN AND SO I WAS.
HISTORICALLY THE COUNTY POCKETS
A AS A WAY OF EXCLUDING RACIAL
GROUPS.
FROM LIVING IN THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE BY PUSHING CARRY WORKERS
HISPANICS.
AND OTHER PEOPLE INTO THE COUNTY
POCKETS.
AND ALLOWING THOSE SMALL HOMES
TO BE BUILT IN THOSE AREAS --
THE CANNERIES AND SOUND WAS A
CREATED CANNERY TOWNS OUTSIDE
THE CITY LIMITS.
OF SAN JOSE AND AS A RESULT --
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WERE NOT
ANNEX IN FACT A NUMBER
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT EVENTUALLY
WE'RE TOTALLY SURROUNDED.
BY THE THE THE THE CITY.
LIMITS AS THE CITY GREW -- AND
IT WASN'T UNTIL THE SEVENTIES
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES.
THAT THE CITY STARTED TO ANNEX.
THESE AREAS IN ACCORDANCE WITH
STATE LAW THAT REQUIRED.
ANNEXATION OF THE INFILL.
THE THE THE AREAS THAT WERE
COMPLETELY SURROUNDED BY A CITY.
WHERE YOU HAD A COUNTY IRELAND
INSIDE?
THE CITY SO A LOT OF THOSE AREAS.
JUST JUST FOR FOR MY PURPOSES.
LOOKING OUT AT HISTORICALLY ALSO
I THINK WHAT I'M SAYING APPLIES.
TO I I WAS A NUMEROUS CITIES --
WHERE -- HOUSING TRACTS WERE
BUILT OUTSIDE THE CITY LIMITS.
BASED ON RACIAL [inaudible]
RACIAL PREJUDICE.
OKAY IT'S BASICALLY RACIAL
PREJUDICE CARRY WORKERS TENDED
TO BE -- OF RACIAL MINORITIES
AND HISPANICS.
PORTUGUESE ITALIANS OF WERE IN A
LOT OF THESE NEIGHBORHOODS OF
STILL EXIST AND ALLOW THE FAMILY
STILL EXISTS IN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
HOWEVER.
WE HAD A COMMUNITY LEADER THAT
CAME BY AND SAID.
WELL OUR STREETS ARE ALL.
ON PAY WE DON'T HAVE PROPER SUE
THE AGE -- WE NEED.
TO CHANGE THIS NEIGHBORHOOD.
WHICH WAS CALLED SOUTH
SUPPORTERS.
AND THIS LEADER CAME IN AND SAID
WE NEED TO ANNEX CAESAR IS TO
THE CITY AND MAKE A PART OF THE
CITY ANDPAVE THE STREETS.
PUT THE CURBS AND GUTTERS IN --
SEWERAGE SCHOOLS ALL THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT HAPPEN TO BE SAYS
ARE TRAVIS.
SO WE CAME INTO SAN JOSE AND HE
HE LED TO COMMUNITY SERVICE
AGENCY.
AND AN IN THE IMPROVEMENT OF
THESE FORMER.
COUNTY AREAS IN THE EAST PART OF
SAN JOSE SO.
SO FOR ME FOR MAY THIS IS MORE.
KIND OF A SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUE I
DON'T KNOW THE AUTHOR WOULD
REFLECT ON THAT I'M I'M GIVING
YOU SERVE HISTORICAL.
KIND OF CONTEXT TO THE BILL I
BELIEVE RIDE RIGHT AND THE
CONTEXT IS THAT [inaudible]
COUNTY PARKER'S.
THAT WERE NOT ALLOWED TO ANNEX
TO THE CITY WERE USED AS
EXCLUSIONARY AREAS BASED ON
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION.
SO SO I TAKE A CHECK.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SOME FORM OF REMEDY WITH THIS
BILL CORRECT RIGHT AM I RIGHT
THIS IS A REMEDY TO PASS.
INJUSTICES THAT HAPPENED.
MY SO I TAKE MY CONTACTS OF THE
BILL IS.
I KNOW THE CITY'S FISCAL ISSUES
A REALITY WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT.
EVERY AREAS DIFFERENT.
BUT QUITE FRANKLY -- I THINK THE
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUE
PREDOMINANCE MY DECISION.
OF AND I THINK WE SHOULD DEAL
WITH THE FISCAL ISSUES.
BUT THE FISCAL ISSUES WERE NOT
CAUSED BY THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE
IN THESE AREAS.
THEY WERE CAUSED BY OTHER PEOPLE
THAT EXCLUDE THESE PEOPLE FROM
JOINING THEIR CITIES THANK YOU
SO THAT'S GOT IT THAT'S SORT OF
MY STATEMENT AND IT'S SAN JOSE
WE BEEN VIGOROUSLY TRYING TO
ANNEX THESE AREAS.
OF SO I HOPE WE CONTINUE TO DO
SO.
AND WE'RE NOT DONE YET.
BUT I THINK WE I THINK THIS BILL
IS MORE OF AYE AYE PERCEIVE IT
MORE OF A SOCIAL JUSTICE BILL.
AS ACT AND I WANT DOCTOR TO
MAYBE COMMENT ON THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU BEFORE THE AUTHOR
COMMENTS I JUST WANNA DO A QUICK
TIME CHECK.
SO THERE IS GOING TO BE A CAUCUS
THAT -- MOST OF US ARE GONNA
HAVE TO GO.
TO AT NEW.
OUT WE HAVE MISSED BURNER
HORVATH IS WELL AS MR MULLIN
HERE THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
BE ABLE TO TACKLE A AND
ACCOMPLISH THEIR THREE BILLS.
I JUST WANT TO DO A QUICK CHECK
IN ON THIS ISSUE AND TURN OVER
THE VICE CHAIR.
RICHARD THIS CENTER BELT -- WILL
JUST MAYBE A COUNTERPOINT IS IS
IN THE ATTEMPT TO TRY.
TO NXT'S ISLANDS Là THESE
ISLANDS DID NOT WANT TO BE AN EX.
BECAUSE THEY LIKE WHAT THEY HAD.
IN IN ONCE THEY KNEW THEY WERE
GONNA GO INTO THE CITY.
THE RULES ARE GOING TO CHANGE
WHETHER IT WAS EVEN HAVING
CHICKENS ON THEIR PROPERTY AND
ALL KINDS OF ISSUES -- SO I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT.
EVEN THOUGH YOU TRIED TO ANNEX
SOME OF THESE COMMUNITIES
ACTUALLY.
PUSH BACK AND FILE THE NECESSARY
SIGNATURES TO OPPOSE -- SO.
THERE IS A REAL INTERESTING DEAL
AND AND WHY I BRING IT UP IS.
IS I DON'T WANT TO MAKE THAT
PROCESS MORE DIFFICULT FOR THOSE
THAT ARE TAKING THE POLITICAL
RISK.
MY CITY MANAGER FOR ONE OF MY
CITIES THAT WORK TO GET THIS
APARTMENT IN PLACE WORK REALLY
HARD TO GET HERS HER CITY
COUNCIL TO APPROVE THE DEAL.
AND THEN WATCH LAUGH GO TURN
AROUND AND PUT IT INTO THE OTHER
CITY.
SHE LOST HER JOB.
BECAUSE THE COUNSELORS ARE UPSET
THAT THE TO TOUCH A POLITICAL
RISK BECAUSE THEY WERE BEING
CRITICIZED BY THE RESIDENTS
[inaudible]
AND SO.
THIS IS A LABORIOUS DIFFICULT
PROCESS ANNEXES ART ANNEXATIONS
ARE NOT EASY SO.
I I I WHAT I WANT TO TRY TO FIND
A WAY TO INCENTIVIZE ANNEXATIONS --
NOT MAKE THE MORE DIFFICULT IT
IS FOR LIKE THE CENTER COTTO'S.
LEAST REFERENCE ARE YOU KNOW
WHAT WHERE DO WE GET SOME MORE
CASH MORE MONEY TO HELP.
IN THE SITUATIONS ARE.
THE I TURN OVER SAID HER TITLE
IN A MOMENT I EIGHT NEGLECTED --
TO HAVE THE SIMILAR NUMBER
RESPOND TO SENATOR BELL -- WITH
AN AFFIRMATIVE -- IN HIS
COMMENTS SO I SENT OVER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND SENATE ABOUT
I SHOULD HAVE DONE THAT PRIOR TO
GOING TO THE VICE CHAIR AND I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT BUT IT'S
SUMMER WOULD YOU LIKE TO COMMENT
PLEASE.
THE GOVERNOR EARLIER THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO I CANNOT AGREE
MORE WITH WHAT HAS BEEN SAID TO
YOU KNOW FROM OUR EXPERIENCE.
BEING ON THE SOUTH IS CITY
COUNCIL IN SANTA CLARA.
BUT THIS BILL DOES ALLOW THE D. --
AREA TO OPT OUT OF ANNEXATION IF
THEY CHOOSE -- TO WHILE YOU USE
TO YOU.
PLAIN DRINKING WATER AS A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY THE CARD
COMMITTEE.
ALL HEALTH RELIABLE WATERS FILL
IF THE WALLET TO OPT -- TURN
OVER DAYS IN THE REFERRED TO
CLOSE BUT PLEASE MADAM CENTER.
THE CHAIR I'LL MAKE IT QUICK I
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE -- THAT
THAT OF MY OPPOSITION IS IS NOT
SAYING THAT I'M.
OPPOSED TO ANNEXATION I AM.
I THINK THERE IS A PROBLEM IN
THE VALLEY AND IN TRYING TO
ANNEX AND I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT DOWN THE ROAD I
JUST -- YOU KNOW WANT TO SAY
THAT THE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE
A YOU KNOW TWENTY THREE CITIES.
AND AND THE SENATE DISTRICT AND
IT'S VERY RURAL AND YOU HAVE A
LOT OF AN INCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES WITHIN.
THOSE -- WITHIN THAT SENATE
DISTRICT WITHIN YOU KNOW A CLOSE
PROXIMITY.
TO THOSE CITIES IT'S IT'S A VERY --
IT'S IT'S JUST A IT'S IT'S IT'S
A BIG ISSUE THAT REQUIRES A A I
THINK MORE.
MORE PLANNING -- I'D BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU ON ON A DRESS SEEN
AT THE ANNEXATION PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE IN THE VALLEY AND IT'S
STILL REMAIN IN OFFICE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL.
GOV FINALLY I'LL BE HAPPY TO
WORKING WITH YOU JUST TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT ALL THE RESIDENTS YOU YOUR
COMMUNITY IN YOUR SENATE
DISTRICT HAVE OF CLEAN RELIABLE
DRINKING WATER.
THIS IS NOT JUST A SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUE.
THIS IS -- YOU KNOW MAKE SURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE.
TO THE LOCAL QUALITY OF DRINKING
WATER.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU MR GONNA GO TO QUICKLY
AND THEY WERE GONNA GO TO THE
SAN NUMBER FOR CLOSENESS MILLER
THANK YOU AND CHAIRMAN CHOIR.
UP IN I WANT TO THANK A SENATOR
BELL -- FOR HIS PERSPECTIVE AND
THE HISTORY I ALWAYS ENJOY YOUR
HISTORY LESSONS -- WE ALSO THINK
THIS IS A SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUE --
BUT WE VIEW IT ACTUALLY THE
COMPLETE OPPOSITE WAY -- WE WANT
TO SEE THESE AREAS ANNEXED ONCE
THE SERVICES EXTENDED TO THEM WE
WANT TO SEE THEM ANNEXED.
BY THEM NOT BEING ANNEXED THEN --
THEY DON'T GET A SAY IN WHO
REPRESENTS THEM THEY DON'T GET
TO VOTE.
IF THERE'S THE OF A RATE
INCREASE THEY DON'T GET TO VOTE
ON THAT BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
PART OF THE OF THE DISTRICT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT BEEN AN IN.
THIS BILL ALLOWS HIM TO OPT OUT
ONCE THE SERVICE HAS BEEN
EXTENDED WE DO WE WANT TO SEE
THEM INCLUDED WE WANT TO SEE
THEM ANNEXED.
ONCE THE SERVICES EXTENDED AND
THAT IS ALIGNED WITH EXISTING
STATUTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- NO VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO BETTER TURN OVER THIS IN THE
NUMBER. TO OFFER CLOSE THE
COMMENTS BUT BEFORE WE DO IT
LIKELY TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
SO WITH THAT TURN OVER THE
SUMMER FOR CLOSING COMMENTS
ORGAN -- LOOK FOR A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR MR SOMEONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHOWN AGAIN
A HUNT AB ONE SIX HUNDRED WILL
ENCOURAGE ARTICLE EQUITABLE
DEVELOPMENT TO ENSURE.
THAT THOSE COMMUNITY ARE BEING
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT AND NOT TO BE
FORGOTTEN IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
BE AN AXE -- WHAT WHAT WAS TO DO
OUR BEST TO PROVIDE A QUALITY
DRINKING WATER?
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIMILAR TO
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
WITH A MOTION BY CENTER BELL ON
AB SIX HUNDRED THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE FLOOR.
MISS LANCASTER CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WIRED BY WHY I'M
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NOBEL.
I HERTZBERG FURTADO.
I DON'T KNOW NIELSEN.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE TWO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN AND ITEM. SIX FOUR SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN SENATOR NIELSEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION TO SEND HER A
GRATEFUL THANK YOU IT'S GOOD TO
SEE SOME NUMBER [inaudible]
SELECT [inaudible]
THANK RESTORED.
LAYS THERE WERE NOW MOVING ON TO
MISS BURNER [inaudible]
THAT.
I ANNOUNCE MISS BOERNER HORVATH
I DON'T KNOW FOUR TIMES IN
MISPRONOUNCING NAME -- IN SO I
OVER AN APOLOGY -- AND I WILL
NOT DO THAT AGAIN.
BUT WE DO WELCOME THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN TO COMMITTEE -- I ALSO A
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THIS IN A WOMANWE HAD THE
ABILITY TO BEABLE TO SIT DOWN
AND AND WORK OUT SOME.
JUST MINOR ISSUES -- IN
APPRECIATE HER WILLINGNESS TO BE
A TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE.
OF THE FLOOR IS YOURS ON A
REALLY GOOD BILL THAT'S
PROMOTING A VITAL BECAUSE I'D BE
A. B.. NINE THIRTY ONE FOR
SOURCE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
THINK OF THE CHAIR AS WELL AS
THE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK N THIS
BUT ONE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE IN THE MEN'S.
AS YOU KNOW WOMEN HAVE FACED A
STORK DISCRIMINATION AND
POLITICAL SPACES IN AB NINE
THIRTY ONE IS NARROWLY TAILORED
TO ADDRESS THIS HISTORIC
INEQUALITY.
AB NINE THIRTY ONE INCREASES THE
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN ON
PUBLIC LOCAL APPOINTED BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS AND CITIES OVER.
500-005-0000 BY REQUIRING THE
FOLLOWING.
BY.
TWENTY THIRTY ALL ARE NUMBERED
LOCAL POINTED WHAT A LOCAL
POINTED AND NON SALARY BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS HAVE AT LEAST
ONE LESS.
THAN THE MAJORITY MEMBERS BE
SELF IDENTIFIED WOMEN ALL EVEN
NUMBER LOOK LOCAL POINT ABOARD
THE NON SALARY BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS HAVE AT LEAST 50%.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED IN
THIS COMMITTEE EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY ONE ALSO PROVIDES OF THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF APPOINTED BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS WITH IN ANY
JURISDICTION.
SHALL BE NO LESS THAN 50%.
AT EIGHTY NINE THIRTY ONE WE
HAVE A SUN SUN RISE OF TWENTY
THIRTY IS ANEW WORD I LEARNED
TODAY SO I LOVE THAT WE ARE ALL
OF OFTEN TALK ABOUT SOME SENSE
NOW WE HAVE A SUNRISE.
A TWENTY THIRTEEN THAT GIVES
CITIES OVER FIFTY THOUSAND A
DECADE TO RECRUIT AND ENCOURAGE
MORE QUALIFIED WOMEN -- TO APPLY
FOR LOCAL BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
I'M VERY I ENCOURAGE I THINK YOU
KNOW WITH LETTING WOMEN KNOW
THAT THEIR SEATS AT THE TABLE
ONE KOREJE MORE PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY TAKE THOSE SEATS AND I
WAS ASKED FIVE TIMES TO DRUM THE
PLANNING COMMISSION S. FIVE
TIMES TO RUN.
AND YOU KNOW IF YOU ANYBODY
KNOWS MAN PRETTY TYPE A AND YOU
WOULDN'T NORMALLY EXPECT THAT I
THINK THAT'S A SYMPTOM.
OF HOW WOMEN FEEL EXCLUDED FROM
POLITICAL SPACES SO AB NINE
THIRTY ONE IS REALLY ENCOURAGING
WOMEN TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
DECISIONS THAT EALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR OUR DAILY LIVES
RIGHT.
OUR LOCAL BOARDS AND COMMITTEES
AND SAID HE'S THE DECIDER ROSES
SUTTER BUILT ENVIRONMENT THEY
TALK ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO WITH
PLASTIC BAGS AND HOW WE PROTECT
THE OCEAN AND WHAT WE DO ABOUT
STORM WATER.
THESE ARE ALL REALLY VITAL --
DISCUSSIONS AND ISSUES THAT
WOMEN SHOULD BE AT THE TABLE AT
AND IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE
KNOW THAT QUALIFIES WOMEN FOR
HIGHER OFFICE SO.
YOU KNOW IN WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA
WOMEN MAKE UP 52% OF THE
POPULATION AND IN CITIES A FIFTY
THOUSAND OR MORE IT'S OFTEN EVEN
MORE THAN THAT.
SO WHILE WE'RE GONNA MAKE
CONSIDERABLE ADVANCES IN THE
WORK FORCE IN RECENT YEARS WE
STILL FACE THESE INEQUALITIES
THAT OFTEN PREVENT US FROM
REACHING OUR FULL POTENTIAL I'M
ONE OF THOSE THINGS IS WHAT WE
WOULD DO WE DO IN OUR PUBLIC
SPACES.
WHAT WOULD YOU KNOW IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE GREAT AT
HAVING AT THE STATE LEVEL A GOOD
GENDER EQUALITY NUMBER -- FOR
MANY OF OUR STATE BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING THAT TALKS ABOUT THAT
FOR LOCAL BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
AND WE KNOW THAT'S THE PATH TO
HIGHER OFFICE SO -- YOU KNOW AND
I JUST WANT TO MAKE THIS
PERSONAL SO WHEN I WAS ASKED TO
BE ON THE PLANNING COMMISSION
WAS ALL MALE PLANNING COMMISSION.
I WAS THE ONLY WOMAN I GOT
ELECTED TO HIGHER OFFICE WE
REPLACED THAT WITH ANOTHER WOMAN
THAT WOMAN GOT ELECTED HIGHER
OFFICES NON ALL MALE PLANNING
COMMISSION AGAIN.
AND ONE OF OUR ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES WANTED TO YOU KNOW
GET APPOINTED TO THE PLANNING
COMMISSION AND AND AVERY MAYOR
SAID.
YOU WILL NEVER GET A PLANE TO
THE PLANNING COMMISSION THAT'S A
STEP FOR HIGHER OFFICE AND THEY
DON'T APPOINT WOMEN TO THOSE.
THESE ARE REAL THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW AS IT IS A REAL PROBLEM WE
NEED ADDRESSED TO REPEAT TO REDO
THIS SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK EITHER AND
HAVE TWO WITNESSES HERE THAT
THEY WILL ALSO ON TIME AND ON
THEIR SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU THE HOUSTON EVER DO
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL WHO WOULD LIKE ME
TO GO FIRST IN WHOEVER WOULD.
FIRST LAST ORGANIZATION YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES.
I'M MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
LAND TRITON TODAY REPRESENTING
AND FIND HER I AM A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF THIS ORGANIZATION
WHICH IS DEDICATED TO WOMEN'S
EQUALITY AND BRING IN MORE WOMEN
TO ELECTED OFFICE.
AND I I THINK THERE IS REALLY NO
BETTER SALES PITCH FOR THIS BILL
THEN THE WOMAN SITTING NEXT TO
ME WHO STARTED ON A LOCAL
COMMISSION.
WE KNOW THAT LOCAL BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS MORE THAN EVER
REALLY THAT CON CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE COMMUNITY.
AND THE ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
WAIT THEY BRING IDEAS AND
CREATIVITY TO ISSUES THAT ARE SO
CRITICAL AND CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW.
HOUSING POLICE OVERSIGHT
TRANSPORTATION AND A WOMAN'S
VOICE REALLY DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
ON THESE COMMISSIONS IN INDIA
WHERE WOMEN ARE IN THE MAJORITY
ON BOARD TO SEE MORE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER PROJECTS IN
NORWAY.
WHERE THERE'S A MAJORITY OF
WOMEN ON BOARDS WE SEE MORE
STRIDES AND HEALTH CARE?
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
THAT WE GET WOMEN INTO THIS
TRAINING GROUND TO BRING THIS
VOICE.
TO NOT ONLY LOCAL POLITICS BUT
STATEWIDE AND FOR THAT REASON
FIND HERS A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THIS BILL AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF AN ATTACKER WITH THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS THE
CALIFORNIA ALSO HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB.
NINE THIRTY ONE HE MENTIONED
ENSURING EQUAL PRESENTATION ON
BOARDS THE VERY IMPORTANT STEP
TO ENSURING WOMEN HAVE A VOICE
AND THIS LEADS TO LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS AND AS AN EXAMPLE HERE
AND THIS BUILDING AT LESS THAN A
THIRD OF THE WOMEN LEGISLATOR.
I WILL THAT LESS THAN A THIRD OF
LEGISLATORS ARE WOMEN.
THOUGH THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
STEP TO ENSURE THAT WE KEEP
TAKING THESE STEPS FORWARD TO
ENSURE EQUAL RISEN TATIAN AND
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SOCCER
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE WITH
LIKE THAT OPEN UP TO ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE THIS WE CAN SUPPORT
THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD LOOKING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
HEARING SEE NUMBER NOW LIKE TO
TURN OVER TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR
THIS TIME LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION.
CURRENCY NEVER GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. TO TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONVERSATION OR MOTION.
BUT WE HAVE A QUESTION AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO A MOTION --
CENTER TITLE.
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR AND
FOR THIS BILL IN THERE WE HAVE
SOME REAL ISSUES WHEN IT COMES
TO REPRESENTATION WOMAN ON LOCAL
BOARDS AND JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT I GET AN UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE BILL -- IF IT'S UNDER
FIFTY THOUSAND POPULATION AND
THERE'S THAT ED BOARD THAT OR
COMMITTEE THAT STRUGGLING TO
RECRUIT WOMEN.
OF FOR A POSITION I MEAN WHAT IT
THERE'S NO -- WHAT WOULD HAPPEN?
THE BILL SILENT ON A CITIES
UNDER FIFTY THOUSAND THIS BILL
ONLY APPLIES TO CITIES FIFTY
THOUSAND OR MORE OKAY THERE WAS
A CONCERN -- AND WE'LL SEE HOW
THIS BILL RUNS AND I AM AND HOW
IT GETS IMPLEMENTED AT MY HOPE
IS THAT WITH THIS BILL CITIES
WILL BE VERY PROACTIVE ABOUT
RECRUITING MORE WOMEN -- THERE
WAS A CONCERN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
ESPECIALLY WORLD COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY STRUGGLE TO FIND EVEN
VOLUNTEERS BECAUSE THESE ARE
UNPAID USUALLY LARGELY UNPAID --
APPOINTMENTS -- THERE WAS A
CONCERN ABOUT HAVING ENOUGH
QUALIFIED PEOPLE GENERALLY OR
EVEN LIKE THEIR VACANCIES
CURRENTLY SO THAT'S WHY WE CHOSE
FIFTY THOUSAND AND ABOVE.
BUT EVEN IF A COMMUNITY IS OUR
CITY IS A FIFTY THOUSAND OR
ABOVE AND STILL HAS CHALLENGES
[inaudible]
WATER.
THEY HAVE A DECADE TO FIGURE IT
OUT [inaudible]
YEAH.
I DON'T I DON'T THINK THEY WILL
I THINK WOMEN.
ARE THERE'S NO COMMUNITY I'VE
EVER BEEN IN AND WHEN THE AND
CITIES WITH FIFTY THOUSAND ABOVE
WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE QUALIFIED
WOMEN WHO CAN COME TO THE TABLE
ANSWER SO.
I I THINK WE HAVE A DECADE TO DO
THAT RECRUITMENT AND AND I
EXPECT THAT CITIES.
ARE WHO TAKE THIS BILL VERY
SERIOUSLY WILL GO INTO PROGRAMS
AND HOW YOU KNOW TALK ABOUT HOW
DO WE GET MORE WOMEN ON
COMMISSIONS AND FOURTH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR -- BY
SENATOR BAIL -- THE FIFTY
THOUSAND AND LESS BUT WHAT TO IT
AND THEN IT WAS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
AND ON THIS ISSUE WHAT IS
PROVIDE SOME FLEXIBILITY ABOUT
HOW TO BE A TO GET TO THAT 50%
OVERALL NUMBER -- IN DO
APPRECIATE THAT AND OUT REALLY
GOOD BILL.
MADAM ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
LIKELY TO SEE IF WE HAVE A
MOTION TO PASS AS A MANAGER JUST
VERY IN THE FINAL -- QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
XENON WE LIKE TO CLOSE YES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE LOW --
FOR ON A BILL THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF WOMEN.
IN COMMISSIONS AND BOARDS AND
AND CORRECT A HISTORIC INEQUITY
ANARCHIC STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
LANCASTER THAT'S REAL.
WIRE HI WHY I'M MORE LONG.
BELL BILL I HERTZBERG RICARDO
[inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE. THREE ZERO ABOUT.
THAT BILL IS EVER GONNA LEAVE
OPEN AND WE'RE GONNA ADD FOLKS
ON AS THEY COME IN THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS SOON.
LAYS IN GENERAL ARE NOW GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO MISTER MALL IN --
SO WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
DO IS.
THESE ARE GOING TO BE OUR FINAL
TO BILLS PRIOR -- IT TO HAVING
TO RECESS.
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS. TWO ONE
THIRTY ISHE -- IF YOU'RE ASKING
FOR WHERE THE ROOM IS GOING TO
BE WE'LL FIGURE THAT OUT -- AS
THERE ARE NO ROOMS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE AS IT IS A BUSY DAY IN
THE CAPITAL.
SO -- STAY TUNED AS FAR AS WHERE
THE ROOM WILL BE WHEN WILL
RECONVENE FOR OUR AFTERNOON
EDITION OF GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
WE WANT TO WELCOME -- SIMILAR
MALL IN ON TWO BILLS A. B..
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR CELL NUMBER
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
I IN IN WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU
PERCENT ALSO ON ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS ON AB SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB SEVENTY FORMAL EXAM ZERO
EMISSION TRANSIT BUSES --
SEABEES FROM THE STATE PORTION
OF THE SALES TAX UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IN
ORDER TO ADVANCE THE DEPLOYMENT
OF CBS IN CALIFORNIA. ZERO
EMISSION BUSES RELY ON BATTERY
ELECTRIC AND OR HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL TECHNOLOGIES AND A LIMITED
EXPOSURE TO CONTAMINANTS
EXCEPTIONALLY BENEFITING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THAT UTILIZE TRANSIT AT HIGHER
RATES CURRENTLY ALMOST HALF OF
THE STATE'S BUS POPULATION
CONTAINS DIESEL ENGINES WHICH
AMID A COMPLEX MIXTURE.
OF AIR POLLUTANTS THAT CAUSE
CANCER PREMATURE DEATH AND HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS TOP
CONTRIBUTORS TO CLIMATE CHANGE
MANY TRANSIT AGENCIES IN THE
STATE OF BEGUN TO REDUCES
EMISSIONS BY DEPLOYING SEABEES.
AND DUE TO THE PASSAGE OF THE
CLEAN TRANSIT REGULATION IN
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IS NOW REQUIRING
THE STATE'S TWO HUNDRED PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES. TO BEGIN
PURCHASING THESE BUSES AS SOONAS TWENTY TWENTY THREE WITH THE
GOAL OF CONVERTING ALL BUSES
OPERATING IN THE STATE TWO ZERO
MISSION TECHNOLOGIES BY.
TWENTY FORTY AB SEVENTY FOUR
WILL ASSIST THESE AGENCIES IN
CONVERTING THEIR FLEETS TO ZERO
MISSION TECHNOLOGIES BY
EXEMPTING OF THE CBS FROM THE
STATE PORTION OF THE SALES TAX
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP AS WELL
AS CAL START. TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU THINK THANKS
SO MUCH OF SMALL AND WE DO HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER ABOUT
WHICH IS TO PASS AS A MANAGER
PREPARATIONS WERE GOING TO ASK --
WITNESSES TO BE TO PROVIDE IS A
TRUMPCARE DE DE TRUNCATED
TESTIMONY WHO'D LIKE TO KICK US
OFF FIRST LASSEN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE WE HAVE OUR COMMITTEE
RULES TO WITNESSES.
AMERICA ALEXANDER HERE ON BEHALF
OF CAL START -- I WILL BE FREE
FOR THAN I HAD PLANNED -- SO
WE'RE A NONPROFIT FOUNDED OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO FOCUSED ON
SPRING DEVELOPMENT OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY.
SO AS A RESULT OF CALIFORNIA'S
POLICIES WE'VE SEEN ZERO
EMISSION BOSS MANUFACTURERS
FLOCKING TO CALIFORNIA SUCH AS
PRO TERRA MOTIVE YOU IDEA OTHERS --
WE ARE ONE OF THE ONLY STATES IN
THE COUNTRY THAT.
I CHARGES A SALES TAX ON TRANSIT
DISTRICTS AND THESE ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE BUSES MANY OF THEM
COSTING OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
SO THE SALES TAX IS A
SIGNIFICANT HIT.
AND WHAT WE'RE REALLY ASKING FOR
HERE IS TO INCENTIVIZE TRANSIT
DISTRICTS THAT ARE REALLY
LEADERS AND EARLY ADOPTERS OF
ZERO EMISSION BUS TECHNOLOGY.
AND AND AS I WAS MENTIONED THE
AYE THE NEW TRANSIT ROLE IS
PHASING AND BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SO WE'RE REALLY
JUST TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE EARLY
ADOPTION WHICH WILL HAVE MAJOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND GREENHOUSE GAS
BENEFITS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE IT AND THANKS FOR
YOUR FLEXIBILITY TODAY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BETTER PROVIDE OUR
SECOND.
SYSTEM PLEASE REQUIRE VICE VICE
CHAIRMAN OF MORE LIKE I'M HEIDI
SIGLER WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN.
FOR INTRODUCING IN SENATOR HILL
FOR CLATTERING AB SEVENTY FOUR
AND THREE LEADERSHIP FUNDS
REMISSION VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND A THREE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
MEMBER COMPANIES CONTRIBUTE
NEARLY THREE TRILLION DOLLARS TO
THE WORLDWIDE ECONOMY.
AND PROVIDE NEARLY ONE OF EVERY
THREE PRIVATE SECTOR JOBS AND
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
SUPPORTS AB SEVENTY TWO FOR
LEGISLATION THAT WILL HELP
REDUCE THE UP FRONT CAPITAL COST
OF YOUR MISSION BUSES BY
EXEMPTING THEM FROM THE STATE
PORTION OF THE SALES TAX UNTIL
JENNY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY FOUR IS CRITICALLY
NEEDED TO HELP PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES RAMP UP TO CALIFORNIA'S
1100% THREE MISSION BUS
PURCHASING MANDATE BY TWENTY
TWENTY NINE AMENDED LEADERSHIP
GROUP SUPPORTS BECAUSE IT
STRENGTHENS IN STATE
MANUFACTURING JOBS.
INNOVATION CLEAN TRANSIT OPTIONS
AND ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND
OUR COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE THANKS FOR
FLEXIBILITY AS WELL AND BOTH
HAVE YOU BEEN HERE. FOR THE
MORNING AND WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU
SPEND WITH US SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH WOULD LIKE TO RECEIVE
ANYONE ELSE IS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MADELINE COOPER ON
BEHALF OF MARIN COUNTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
A GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WERE TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WORD UP MORNING STEVE WALLICH
ARE HERE TO EXPRESS THE SUPPORT
OF THE GOLDEN GATE TRANSIT
DISTRICT OUR GOAL GIVERS
DISTRICT -- THE NAPA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY ALMOND
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
RECORDED TRANSIT ALL SUPPORT
THANK YOU AS WELL.
GOOD MORNING CAROL SOME HAVE THE
CITY OF SANTA ROSA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL I DON'T THINK SO MUCH
KAREN LÏNG UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
AND ADVANCE ENERGY ECONOMY BUT
THAT'S PART.
DISTILLING.
CHARLES WATSON ON BEHALF OF
PREPARING SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING DAUGHTER MOM ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING RUBBER FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING.
BUT DRAW COOK CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MICHAEL DAFT WITH
THE PRAM KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
CHARGE POINT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
WOULD LIKE TO DO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
SUPPORT.
NOW LIKE TO TURN OVER TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSE LAST.
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED LAST CALL.
THEY CAN BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
WE ALSO WOULD WELCOME A MOTION.
WE OWE AYE THAT'S RIGHT I DO
APOLOGIZE -- MR BELL'S BEEN ALL
OVER THIS I DO APOLOGIZE THIS IS
A MOTION TO DO PASS AS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MR SOME MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO CLOSE JUST SIMPLY
NOTE THAT WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS AND I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SERVICES CAN ASK YOU THAT
VERY GRATEFUL MUSLIMCHESSER.
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI.
I'M MORE A LOT MORE WORK AYE
BELL.
HI HERTZBERG.
HELLO I NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
I CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE EIGHT
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN ON THIS THANK YOU
SO MUCH YOUR WITNESSES WELL.
SO WE HAVE AN UPDATE LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA BE NEEDING IN
THIS ROOM IN THIS ROOM.
AT THREE PM ISHE.
WE HAVE BANKING AND FINANCE
BANKING AND FINANCE GOES IN AT
ONE THIRTY THEY HAVE I GUESS ONE
CRUNCHY BILL.
SEVERAL BILLS BUT ONE IN
PARTICULAR IS GONNA BE CRUNCHY --
IN SO THEY'LL GO TO APPROXIMATE
THREE PM MISSION WILL KEEP YOU
ALL IN THE LOOP BUT AFTERNOON
EDITION OF GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE THREE PM ISHE.
IN THIS ROOM IT WILL KEEP YOU IN
THE LOOP.
I'M SIMILAR MULLIN I DO NOT MEAN
TO BE RUDE I'M GONNA TURN THE
GAVEL OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR.
OF THE VICE CHAIR WILL BE
RUNNING ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE AS I AM GOING
TO A CAUCUS MEETING AND I
APOLOGIZE SIR -- BUT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
PRESENTING AB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
SEA LEVEL RISE IS ONE OF THE
MOST SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AS YOU KNOW.
WHILE SOME COMMUNITIES MAY THINK
OF SEA LEVEL RISE AS AN
INCONVENIENT REALITY OF THE
DISTANT FUTURE THIS IS NOT THE
CASE FOR MY DISTRICT IN SAN
MATTEO COUNTY.
SAN MATEO COUNTY AS MORE PEOPLE
AND PROPERTY VALUE AT RISK FROM
RISING SEA LEVELS THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTY IN THE STATE.
PROPERTY RISK INCLUDES PERSONAL
RESIDENCES STATE REGIONAL
HIGHWAYS COMMERCIAL PROPERTY AND
OTHER CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
WHILE MANY EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THE THREAT OF SEA LEVEL RISE
FLOODING IN.
COASTAL EROSION ARE ALREADY
UNDER WAY SAME TALE COUNTIES
TWENTY CITIES NEED A COORDINATED
APPROACH TO ADEQUATELY PREPARE
FOR THESE THREATS ACROSS THE
COUNTY AS A WHOLE.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE WOULD
MODIFY THE EXISTING SAN MATTEO
FLOOD CONTROL DISTRICT AND
RENAME IT THE FLOOD AND SEA
LEVEL RISE RESILIENCY AGENCY.
THE AGENCY LIKE THE EXISTING FCD
WOULD BE A COUNTY WIDE SPECIAL
DISTRICT THIS MODIFY LOCAL
ENTITY WOULD BE TASKED WITH
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING FLOODING
COASTAL EROSION AND SEALEVEL
RISE TO BEST PROTECT.
AND PREPARE THE COUNTIES
COMMUNITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
THIS IS A COORDINATED IN
PROACTIVE APPROACH TO THE
COMMUNITIES OF SAN MATEO COUNTY
NEED TO DEVELOP A COLLECTIVE
PLAN. TO PROTECT AGAINST VARIOUS
THREATS THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
POSES TO OUR COMMUNITY WITH ME
TODAY IS PAUL OKADA CHIEF DEPUTY
COUNTY COUNSEL FOR SAMITY OF
COUNTY TO OFFER ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS.
IN SUPPORT -- GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- I
ECHO -- ASSEMBLYMAN MULLINS
COMMENTS AND I'LL KEEP MY Y
COMMENTS BRIEF.
WE DO THINK IT'S SOME WOMEN
MULLIN FOR SUPPORT.
AB TWENTY FIVE IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO THE COUNTY IN ITS TWENTY
CITIES ALL OF WHICH HAVE --
PASSED RESOLUTIONS IN SUPPORT OF
AB -- EIGHT TWENTY FIVE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST -- YOUR AYE
VOTE AND AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER OKADA ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MALLORY SPOKE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THE MIND AT LEAST.
ONE WE HAVE A MOTION ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MY COLLEAGUES.
I HAVE ONE QUICK QUESTION ASSUME
AND MULLIN -- YOU ARE --
EXEMPTING.
OF THIS ORGANIZATION FROM THE
TYPICAL 50% VOTER APPROVAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE ISSUANCE OF
REVENUE BONDS AND COULD YOU
EXPLAIN THAT WHAT IS IT NOW.
IS A TWO THIRDS YES YES I I CAN
ADDRESS THAT FOR YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CONNOR -- CURRENTLY IT IS
IT IS 50% -- IF IT IS CURRENTLY
50%.
THE ISSUE IS THAT -- YOU KNOW
THIS PROVISION APPLIED. TO
DISTRICTS LIKE THE FLOOD CONTROL
DISTRICT EVEN PRIOR PROP
THIRTEEN PROP.
TWO EIGHTEEN AND SO WE'RE LEFT
WITH THE SITUATION WHERE IF OF
THE DISTRICT WE'RE GOING TO GO
OUT TO THE VOTERS TO GET
APPROVAL.
FOR ANOTHER TYPE OF REVENUE AS
SPECIAL TAX OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT -- WE'D HAVE TO GET THE TWO
THIRDS VOTE WHICH IS -- YOU KNOW --
FINDING -- BUT AFTER THAT IF WE
WANTED ISSUE REVENUE BONDS WOULD
HAVE TO GO INTO A SECOND TIME
FOR A 50% VOTE.
AND THE FEELING WAS SIMPLY THAT
THIS WOULD -- THIS WOULD-STREAMLINED THE PROCESS GIVEN
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE TO GO OUT
FOR THE FOR THE GREATER VOTE.
FIVE A MOTION TO DO PASSED IN
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLE FIRE WARLOCK.
WARLOCK AYE BELL.
I HERTZBERG HER CONDO.
KINDA AYE NIELSEN.
WIENER [inaudible]
WINNER IPHONE.
BEST THREE BOATS OR VOTE.
SO WILL HOLD IT OPEN UNTIL
SOMETIME TONIGHT.
WHEN WE HAVE THE OTHER MEMBERS
AVAILABLE?
TO CONCLUDE OUR MEETING THANK
YOUR CELL.
PHONE THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
WE'LL BE IN RECESS INTEL. THREE
O'CLOCK AND YOU'LL BE TEXTED
BE STARTING THE AFTERNOON
EDITION OF THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WE'RE GONNA BE ASKIN ALL MEMBERS
IN THE SOUND OF THE VOICE TO BE
ABLE TO HEAD TO COMMITTEE NOW AS
WE HAVE -- SEVERAL BILLS THAT WE
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DISPENSE WITH
WE'RE GONNA BE KICKING OFF WITH
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE THAT'S AB
NINE FORTY FIVE THIS MCCARTY.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO STRAIGHT TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON RIGHT
AFTER THAT.
SO MISS MCCARTY A YOU PREPARE 2%.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA WELCOMED
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY ON EIGHTY
NINE FORTY FIVE HIS FACE THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
MCCARTY -- FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- ON THIS BILL -- IN
IT IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH YOU SERVE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AND WE WELCOME YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
STRONG CHAIR.
YOU'LL COMMITTEE OF ONE RIGHT
YEAH VERY INFLUENCE ALL RIGHT
HERE TODAY.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE FOR VOTES IN
YOUR BACK POCKET READY SET ONE
VOTE.
YES.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR FOR WORKING
WITH US -- HERE TO PRESENT
EIGHTY NINE FORTY FIVE IT'S A
MEASURE BROUGHT TO ME BUT BY
SOME OUR OUR LOCAL BANKS WILL
HEAR FROM IN A SECOND.
WHICH ALLOW LOCAL AGENCIES OF
GOVERNMENT TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF THEIR SURPLUS FUNDS
THAT THEY MAY INVESTED SECURE
FINANCIAL INVESTMENTS CALLED.
RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS AND AGAIN
THE KEY WORD HERE IS MAY I'LL
START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES -- SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS MEASURE --
YOU KNOW THIS MEASURE AGAIN
DOESN'T REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DO THIS PROVIDES
THEM WITH AN OPTION.
FRANKLY MOST STATES ACROSS THE
NATION ARE YOU DOING THIS A
CURRENT LAW PLACES MANY
RESTRICTION THE TYPE INVESTMENTS
THAT SURPLUS FUNDS.
FROM LOCAL AGENCIES MAY BE
INVESTED IN.
YOUR COLLEAGUE HERE A LITTLE BIT
MISTER MOORE LOCLE KNOW THIS
FROM THIS TIME AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE.
INVESTMENTS ARE SOUND.
THESE RESTRICTIONS INCLUDE.
PROVISIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
INVESTMENTS HAVE HIGH LIQUIDITY
AND DON'T POSE A HIGHER RISK TO
THE LOCAL AGENCY.
THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE ANY OF
THOSE RESTRICTIONS IT SIMPLY
INCREASES BY 20% THE AMOUNT.
OF AN AGENCY SURPLUS THAT MAY BE
INVESTED FROM 20% 250% A
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE IN
THE NATION WHICH HAS SUCH A CAP.
OF THIS MEASURE WE WILL PLACE AT
SUNSET ON HERE TO MAKE SURE WITH
A BETTER.
UNDERSTANDING GOING FOR THAT
MAKE TO MAKE SURE IT'S IT SOUNDS
AYE WINNERS IN THIS NEED FOR
CAUTION WHEN IT COMES TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCES.
BUT THERE ARE REASONABLE --
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE THE LIFTING
HIS CAP WON'T PLACE UNNECESSARY
DO RISK ON OUR LOCAL FUNDS -- WE
ME TODAY.
OUR STEVEN FLEMING THE
PRESIDENCY OVER FOR CITY BANK
AND JAMES BACK WITH PRESIDENT CO
A FIVE STAR BANK.
I WILL ASK THEM TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH A
GERMAN YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES WE
WERE COMMUNICATING THANKS FOR
TAKING THE TIME.
ABSOLUTELY BUT I'M MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY OF
BEING ABLE TO PRESENT AND ALSO --
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR THIS --
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I'M JAMES
BACK WITH ON THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO FIVE STAR BAN.
WERE COMMUNITY BANK IT'S LOCATED
IN THE CAPITAL REGION WE DO
BUSINESS PRIMARILY AND THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY BUT WE ALSO
GET OVER THE CINEMA COUNTY AND
AND TRY TO HELP BUSINESSES OVER
THERE.
THIS BILL AB -- NINE FORTY FIVE
SKEWS ME AND ALSO WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY FOR HIS FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP.
THIS BILL AB NINE FORTY FIVE IS
REALLY ABOUT BUILDING CAPACITY --
CAPACITY FOR COMMUNITY BANKS TO
SERVE THEIR CONSTITUENCY TO
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S THREE WAYS OF
COLLATERALIZED PUBLIC FUNDS A
YOU CAN DO A THREE YEAR
INVESTMENT SECURITIES PORTFOLIO
YOU CAN DO IT WITH THE LETTER OF
CREDIT FROM THE FHL BEING SAN
FRANCISCO OR YOU CAN PLACE THOSE
DEPOSITS THE COLLATERAL THOSE
DEPOSITS IN RECIPROCAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
OUR FOCUS IT FIVE STAR AND ALL
OTHER COMMUNITY BANKS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS REALLY TO PROVIDE THE BEST
SERVICE WE POSSIBLY CAN FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES -- PUBLIC FUNDS IS
AN IMPORTANT SOURCE OF DEPOSITS
FOR COMMUNITY BANKS IN
CALIFORNIA IN THIS BILL WILL
GIVE US ANOTHER ARROW IN THE
QUIVER TO INCREASE OUR CAPACITY.
BY RAISING THE LIMIT.
OF LIQUID FUNDS FOR ANY MINUTES
POWER YEAR OR SPECIAL DISTRICT
OR COUNTY FOR THAT MATTER.
FROM 3250%.
STEPHEN A NIGHT OF ABOUT A YEAR
AGO CREATED PROGRAM CALLED THE
RISE PROGRAM.
THE RISE PROGRAM SIMPLY PUT.
ENABLES LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES ANYBODY A
SOURCE OF PUBLIC FUNDS. TO PLACE
DEPOSITS WITH US WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WOULD TURN
AROUND AND LAND AT LEAST 50%.
OF THOSE DEPOSITS OF THOSE FUNDS
BACK INTO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
IN THOSE JURISDICTIONS.
A JURISDICTIONS AWARE WE RECEIVE
THESE DEPOSITS.
TODAY -- THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
QUITE SUCCESSFUL.
WE'VE RAISED ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION IN DEPOSITS AND IT MADE
PRETTY CLOSE TO A HUNDRED
MILLION IN LOANS SO THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE.
OF WHAT CAN BE DONE WITH PUBLIC
FUNDS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WITH
COMMUNITY BANKS WE'RE ASKING YOU
TO INCREASE OUR CAPACITY TO DO
THAT BY APPROVING THIS THANK YOU.
I THINK THANK YOU. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK -- MY
NAME'S STEVE FLEMING ON
PRESIDENT CEO OF OF RIVER CITY
BANK -- WHICH LIKE FIVE STAR
BANK IS BASED IN SACRAMENTO AND
CONSIDERED A COMMUNITY BANK.
PUBLIC SENT SECTOR ENTITIES ARE
IMPORTANT TO US IN A GROWING
SECTOR -- SEGMENT OF OUR
CUSTOMER BASE -- BACK -- IT LAST
YEAR THE CITY OF DAVIS I DECIDED --
TO GO OUT TO PUT ITS BANKING
BUSINESS OUT TO BID THEY WERE
WITH ONE OF THE LARGE NATIONAL
BANKS ON THE MATTER -- YOU WOULD
HAVE SEEN IN THE NEWS QUITE A
BIT AND THANKFULLY FOR US THEY
MADE THE DECISION TO TO BACK
LOCAL TO KEEP THEIR DEPOSITS
LOCAL KNOWING THAT THE MONEY
WOULD BE LENT OUT -- LOCALLY SO
WE'RE PROUD OF THAT MAYBE MORE
IMPORTANTLY DIVERSITY BANK AS
THE LEADING BANK. FOR THE
COMMITTEE CHOICE AGGREGATION I
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
YOU'LL ALL BE AWARE OF WAS
CREATED THE LEGISLATION APPROVED --
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE BAKE FIFTEEN OF THE
TWENTY CCA ENTITIES -- WHOSE
WHOSE MISSION IS TO PROMOTE A
CLEANER CLIMATE AN OFFER --
CHOICE MORE CHOICES FOR
CONSUMERS INCLUDING BETTER
BETTER PRICING. EIGHTY NINE
FORTY FIVE IS IMPORTANT FOR
RIVER CITY BANK IN OUR CLIENTS
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS NUMBER
ONE ALLOW US TO OFFER HIGHER
RATES OF INTEREST TO OUR PUBLIC
SECTOR CLIENTS ON THEIR DEPOSITS.
AS GOOD FOR THE TAXPAYERS TO
DEPOSITS CAN BE MAINTAINED IN
MONEY MARKET OR CD'S ALLOWING
FOR FULL LIQUIDITY IF THAT'S
WHAT THE A PUBLIC ENTITY DESIRES.
100% FDIC INSURANCE.
TOTALLY SAFE NO NO MONEY IS EVER
BEEN LOST NO PRINCIPLES EVER
BEEN LOST ON ON A A PLACE A
PLACE WITH SERVICE DEPOSIT.
AND EIGHTY MOST IMPORTANTLY IS
JAMES ALLUDED TO CURRENTLY WE
AFTER COLLATERALIZED THESE
DEPOSITS AT A HUNDRED AND 10% --
WITH SECURITIES WHICH MEANS WE
CAN'T WIN THE MONEY OUT.
AND WE'RE ALL ABOUT.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT -- GROWING
DO THAT BY LENDING MONEY --
LOCALLY -- THIS THIS BILL WILL
HELP US DO THAT -- SO WITH THAT --
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND AN
**** I RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I DON'T
THINK SO MUCH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR FLEXIBILITY ON
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS SCHOOL.
FOR HANGING WITH US FOR THE
AFTERNOON AS WELL SO WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL E'D LIKE TO GET OPEN
UP FOR ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
YOU ALL CAN COME FORWARD FIRST
LAST NAME AN ORGANIZATION ROBERT
WILSON CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE AND SUPPORT THANKS WASN'T.
OUR GREAT GLAD STAY IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BANKING
NETWORK IN SUPPORT MARKET HAS
BEEN IN AND OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE ALL DAY SHE'S LIVING
THE DREAM.
AND A MYSTERY WHAT.
STORM STRUCTURE IS PLEASE MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS COMMINGLED
WITH CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE SPONSOR
OF THE MEASURE WE APPRECIATE.
THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND HELPINGTO ADVANCES MEASURE
THANK YOU THINK THE SCHOOL
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE THIS
BEGIN SPORTS ME LAST CALL FOR
SUPPORT.
CURRENCY NUMBER NOW WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GENERAL WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU
MAKE ROOM.
FOR INDIVIDUALS CAN BE SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION UP MR GOLD IS
GONNA BE DOING THAT
THE WELCOME IS LAYING WHO'S BEEN
HERE ON A VARIETY OF ISSUES
MISSING WELCOME TO COMMITTEE.
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE CAROLING ON OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURER'S AND TAX COLLECTORS
AT THE OUTSIDE OWNERS SAY
THERE'S BEEN.
CONVERSATION THAT'S BEEN ONGOING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF IN
THE SPONSORS TO TRY TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING.
THAT WORKS FOR THE TREASURE TAX
COLLECTORS ASSOCIATION THEIR
OPPOSITION -- COMES FROM THE
FACT THAT -- WHEN THEY MAKE
THEIR INVESTMENTS ON BEHALF OF
THEIR POOL PARTICIPANTS ARE
OBLIGATED TO OF TO MAKE SURE
THAT DIVERSITY IS IS PART OF
WHAT THEY'RE DOING?
TO HEDGE AGAINST ANY POTENTIAL
FLUCTUATIONS IN ANY ONE
PARTICULAR -- INVESTMENT THAT
THEY HAVE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS I GUESS YOU INSURANCE
IF IT'S CUT UP INTO THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
SEGMENTS.
ANOTHER CONCERN WE HAVE IS JUST
MAKING SURE THAT IF USING MORE
THAN ONE PLACEMENT AGENT.
THIS PLACEMENT AGENCY NO.
IF THERE'S ALREADY MONEY.
INVEST IN ONE OF THOSE BANKS SO
THAT A SECOND INVESTMENT FROM
THE DIFFERENT EMPLACEMENT A
DIFFERENT PLACEMENT AGENT
DOESN'T BUT THE SAME TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ANOTHER TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
THE SAME BANKS WERE WORKING ON
THAT WITH AUTHORS OFFICE.
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
PRICE BECAUSE ARM MULTIPLE
PLAYERS IN THIS MARKET.
AND THIRDLY IF YOU LOOK AT THE
STATE TREASURER'S INVESTMENT
GUIDELINES THAT THEY PUBLISH
EVERY YEAR -- THROUGH SIAC IT
ACTUALLY DOES TAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
DIVERSIFY THEIR POOL IN SO
CONCENTRATING AND 50% IN ONE
THING AAIN -- IS REALLY KIND OF
INCONSISTENT WITH THE OTHER ON A
STATE BODIES THAT OVERSEE HOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INVEST.
AND AND FURTHER -- THERE'S NOT A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HERE SAYING
THAT THEY'RE UP AGAINST THE 30%
IN FACT ONLY DID THE SURVEY OF
THE COUNTY TREASURER'S.
THE HIGHEST AMOUNT THAT
ANYBODY'S INTO THESE FOUR IS ONE
POINT 5%.
THE NOR NEAR THIRTY LET ALONE A
DEMAND FOR FIFTY I UNDERSTAND
HEARING FROM THE SPONSORS THAT
THEY'RE REALLY GOING TO BE GOING
MORE AFTER CITY MONEY.
ANDSPECIAL DISTRICTS MONEY
BECAUSE THE COUNTIES ARE NOT
REALLY USING THIS YET -- I THINK
ONE COUNTY TREASURER DID SEND A
LETTER OF SUPPORT HIS LAST
TREASURER OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
REPORT INDICATED HIS 0% OF HIS
TREASURY IN THESE ACTUAL
INSTRUMENTS SO.
ON WE WOULD PREFER TO SEE IT
HELD AT 30%. FOR US AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TALKING WITH
AUTHORS OFFICE BUT THOSE ARE THE
REASONS THAT WE COME HERE ON THE
SECTION OF CODE THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
AND SENATOR MORE LIKE CERTAINLY
HAS DEEP FAMILIARITY WITH AND WE
TAKE IT VERY SERIOUSLY AND THEY
THEY JUST LIKE TO FOLLOW THE LAW
AND THE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
INTENT IS TO DIVERSIFICATION.
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE POSING
WITH AMENDED THAT WILL
ABSOLUTELY CONTINUE TALKING WITH
AUTHORS OFFICES.
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HANGING
WITH US TODAY BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
A BUSY ONE A GOOD HAVE YOU HANG
WITH US HERE I SEE THERE'S ANY
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL IF YOU
COULD.
PLEASE ADVANCE THIS TIME.
LAST CALL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONVERSATIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MISTER VICE CHAIR CRAFTING.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR GOOD TO
BE BACK NAY -- THE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO THIS MONTH BY I LOST
TO ROBERT CITRON.
RUNNING FOR TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR FOR THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE IT'S GONE BY RATHER
QUICKLY BUT I I ENJOYED TWELVE
YEARS -- AS TREASURER TAX
COLLECTOR -- BEING APPOINTED
AFTER HE RESIGNED.
AND I WAS IN THE OFFICE FOR JUST
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AND AND I GOT
A CALL.
FROM.
THE TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR OF
NEVADA COUNTY [inaudible]
CHRIS DAVIS [inaudible]
MY REMEMBER.
AND IT IT TURNED OUT THAT.
THE NEVADA COUNTY GRAND JURY HAD
JUST RELEASED A REPORT THAT
CRITICIZED HER.
BECAUSE SHE PUT HER MONEY.
IN COMMUNITY BANKS.
AND DIVIDE MY GOODNESS YOU KNOW
IN IN THE REPORT CAME OUT ABOUT
THE SENATE JUST MET MY TO COME
OUT JUST BEFORE THE JUNE.
JUST.
BEFORE THE COUNTY GOT CRAZY.
BUT HERE'S YOU KNOW ROBERT
CITRON EARNING.
REALLY HIGHER INTEREST RATES AND
HERE'S CHRIS DAVIS JUST IN BANK
ACCOUNTS AND SO SHE WAS
CRITICIZED -- HARSHLY BY THE
GRAND JURY.
AND SO SHE SHE CALLED ME BECAUSE
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAD.
ESTABLISH AN OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
AND ONE OF THE GENTLEMAN ON THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
WROTE A LETTER TO THE EDITOR AND
I GOT PRINTED THE REGISTER THAT
YOU KNOW HOW TERRIBLE IT WAS
THAT.
THIS TREASURER HAD JUST PUT
MONEY IN BANKS.
SO SHE WANTED TO KNOW HOW CLOSE
I WAS TO THIS GUY [inaudible]
AND A AND SHE SAID YOU KNOW -- I
TOLD HER I DON'T KNOW THIS GUY I
I I I I I DON'T KNOW CONTROL
ROOM.
WELL SHE SAID.
YOU CAN TELL HIM TO KISS MY
BLANK.
AND YOU CAN TELL MY OF A PRETTY
BIG BLANK AND ARE JUST REALLY
WAS REALLY REALLY UPSET THAT HOW
CAN I BE YOU KNOW CRITICIZED
BECAUSE MY MONEY WAS SAFE YOUR
MONEY IS GONE -- SO IT JUST SORT
OF FUNNY SO HERE I'VE.
BEEN INVOLVED IN SECTION FIVE
THREE SIX A ONE AND INDEED I
THINK GOVERNMENTS LÏNG POINTED
OUT.
THAT IS A FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AND UNITED MY OWN INDEPENDENT
RESEARCH YOU KNOW ONLY ONE
CARRIES UP TO ONE AND A HALF
PERCENT.
SO WE'RE NOT EVEN PUSHING A
THRESHOLD SO.
ARE WE WERE A DISCUSS
CAPITALIZATION RATES -- SO I
JUST I JUST HAD SOME IDEAS
MISTER CHAIR BECAUSE FOR ME THAT
THERE'S THERE ISN'T A NEED TO GO
FROM.
ABOVE -- THIRTY I'VE I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN SO MANY DISCUSSIONS
ON THE LIMITATIONS OF CERTAIN
INVESTMENT CATEGORIES DONE LOTS
OF BILLS IN MY TWENTY YEARS.
BUT I'M JUST WONDERING IF
[inaudible]
A CINNAMON.
MCCARTY IF WE COULD JUST LIMIT
THIS TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS WHY DO
WE BOTHER THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
AND IT HAVE A SPECIAL.
JUST A SPECIAL CODE SECTION FOR
SPECIAL DISTRICT OR MAYBE WE
HAVE A TO A SPECIFIC.
PORTFOLIO SIZES BECAUSE IF YOU.
IF YOU HAVE ONLY A MILLION
DOLLARS THEN GOING.
TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT
MAKES SENSE.
IN THE MID THEN THAT WOULD MAKE
THAT THAT WOULD WORK.
THEN YOU'D BE NEEDING A 50% OR
THE THIRD OPTION WAS WHY DO WE
EVEN HAVE LIMITS AT ALL.
AND JUST [inaudible]
GO.
YOU KNOW LIKE THE REAL TO A
SEVEN DID YOU DO WHATEVER YOU
WANT.
AND YOU'VE GOT OVERSIGHT AND BE
CAREFUL.
NUMBER YEAH WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU.
AND AND BY THE WAY MY INTRO I I
DID MENTION YOU CELLS WAITING
FOR YOU TO SELL OUT BECAUSE I
KNEW IF ANYBODY OF OUR HUNDRED
TWENTY WHAT'S THE WAY ON THIS
TOPIC.
YOU'RE THE ONE AND I'VE TALKED
TO YOU AT LENGTH ABOUT --
INVESTMENTS TO COUNTIES IN YOUR
BACKGROUND SO LOOK FOR TWO TWO
YEAR -- INPUT O THAT STAND --
THAT SUGGESTION IS ONE THAT WE
ARE -- CONSIDERING THE THE
ASSOCIATION -- SUBMITTED TO US I
GUESS THERE'S A HYBRID THERE
BETWEEN WHAT WE HAVE NOW WHEN
YOU'RE SUGGESTING SO THERE'S
COUNTY POOLS.
A SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND CITIES
THE THESE TWO GENTLEMAN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY BANKS ARE ARE
EXCITED MEN TALKING WITH THE
CITY SACRAMENTO ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO INVESTMENTS
HERE AND WITH.
IT AND THIS IS A BIG DEAL
BECAUSE OF SMALL BUSINESSES AND
OTHERS HAVE BIG PROBLEMS ACCESS
TO CAPITAL THIS HELPS OUR LOCAL
ECONOMY THRIVE AS WELL SO.
ON TO TO TO THROUGHOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CITIES I THINK
YOU KNOW WOULD BE A CONCERN BUT
WE WE WE ARE.
IN -- WILLING TO DISCUSS.
THE PROPOSAL TO TO LIMITED TO TO
CERTAIN A JURISDICTIONS
POTENTIALLY.
EXEMPT -- EXCLUDE COUNTIES.
BECAUSE IF IF WE'RE GOING 250%
THEY MUST HAVE SOME AWFULLY TINY
PORTFOLIOS BECAUSE OUR MOST
TREASURED TAX WORKERS ARE
ELECTED.
SO THEY CAN HELP A LOCAL BANKS
THAT'S A NO BRAINER RIGHT AND
THAT'S JUST A NO BRAIN IT SHOULD
IT SHOULD BE PUT IN TWO FIFTY
AND AS MANY BANKS AS THEY CAN'T
WRITE.
AND AND THEN I CAN COME CLOSE.
230% OF THEIR PORTFOLIO.
MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD GO
THROUGH YOU AND AND I KNOW --
THE OPPOSITION AND NOW I'M
CENTER MORE LACK TALKED ABOUT
THE JURISDICTIONS EARNING THE
APPROACHING CLOSE 230% SPANDEX
ALLOW -- OF ART SUPPORTERS TO TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE HERE
ABSOLUTELY WE'RE GONNA LOOK FOR
A QUICK RESPONSE F THAT WORKS
TO GERMAN OR MR GOLD IF YOU LIKE
TO BE A RETIREMENT AS WELL.
YEAH -- YOU KNOW MY RE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF TO SEIZE THE FLAMING
RIVER CITY BANK -- WE DO HAVE
CLIENTS I MENTION THE FUTURE
SEGREGATION ENTITIES THAT WE
BANK WE DO HAVE CLIENTS WE HAVE
FULL COMMERCIAL RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THEM JUST LIKE WE DO WITH.
FOR PROFIT ENTITIES THEY HAVE
THEIR THEIR LINES OF CREDIT WITH
US THEIR LOANS WITH US I WHICH
WE HELP TO GET THEM GOING -- AND
THEY KEEP ALL OF THEIR DEPOSITS
WITH US THEY DON'T TAG KEEP TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
THEY THEY HAVE A FULL COMMERCIAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH US.
IN.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME THAT
TRYING PARCEL THAT OUT TO TO
OTHER BANKS OPTICALLY BIG BANKS
THAT ARE BASED IN THE AREA THAT
ARE GOING TO TAKE THE MONEY BACK
TO NEW YORK FOR CHARLOTTE OR
WHEREVER ELSE IT IS.
SO -- I THINK -- THERE ARE SOME
SOME ENTITIES LIKE THE BIG
COUNTY POOLS WITH RICHARD YOU'RE
THINKING OF I BELIEVE WHERE I
GET EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
BUT THAT DOESN'T APPLY TO ALL OF
THE PUBLIC SECTOR ENTITIES.
RIGHT NOW IT'S WHY WE SHOULD
MAYBE.
TAYLOR THE BILL.
YOUR YOUR TO YOUR MARKET TARGET.
I'M ALL FOR THAT.
WHY MAKE EVERYBODY ELSE NERVOUS
BECAUSE?
MISTER CHAIR PLEASE BE SO WE
RECEIVED A PROPOSAL MONDAY
EVENING THAT I THINK TRIES TO
BIFURCATE THE BILL IN THAT
FASHION WERE VERY OPEN TO TRYING
TO FIND COMPROMISE AND WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING THIS ISSUE.
WITH THE DEER THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS NOW 418-224- MONTHS
AND THE PROPOSAL THAT IS UNDER
CONSIDERATION IS TO LEAVE THE
PROVISIONS OF LAW THE SECOND
SECTION OF THE BILL IF YOU WILL.
TO TO STATUS QUO SO NOT TO
INCREASE THE PERCENTAGE THERE.
WHICH DEALS WITH COUNTY POOLS.
BUT TO GO AHEAD AN UNMANNED FROM
3250%. FIVE THREE SIX A ONE
POINT EIGHT SO I THINK IT IT IS
SORT OF THAT DISCUSSION WERE ON
AN INDIVIDUAL BASIS THOSE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
IN THOSE MUNICIPALITIES -- WOULD
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE.
USING RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS.
AND WE THINK THAT'S A REASONABLE
COMPROMISE AND AND WERE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO PURSUING THAT
IF IF THAT REMOVES THE
OPPOSITION.
WOULD -- BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE THE TREASURE TAX COLLECTORS
TO GET AT THE GET FIND A HAPPY
GROUND.
I'M I'M SUPPORT OF THAT THANK
YOU MISTER WILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT SOME IS
MCCARTY YOUR WORK OBVIOUSLY WITH
YOUR GETTING WORK IN THE SLAYING
AND THEN -- THE VICE CHAIR ON
THAT AS WELL THAT WOULD BE
WONDERFUL -- VERY GRATEFUL WHAT
WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US TODAY
THOUGH -- IN APPRECIATE THE
SUMMER WORKING WITH US IS A IS A
SUNSET -- THAT.
THAT WOULD.
TRIGGER IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX ON
JANUARY FIRST.
AB SO AGAIN IF WILL INCREASING
THE CAP.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
ENOUGH RAMPS THAT OFFRAMP.
IT WOULD BE THAT JERRY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY SIX DATE.
SO THERE IS A SUNSET IN HERE --
TO BE ABLE TO COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS AND WILL ALSO LOOK FOR
A MOTION FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WITH A MOTION BY CENTER HER TACO.
IN THE MEMBER FOR CLOSING
COMMENTS PLEASE.
WE CERTAINLY I THANK YOU FOR THE
DEBATE I APPRECIATE THE
SUGGESTIONS AND WE HAVE A
HEARING NEXT WEEK ON THE BANKING
COMMITTEE WILL CERTAINLY -- LOOK
TO INCORPORATE SOME OF THIS
BEFORE THEN AND HOPEFULLY I
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION AND WITH
THAT HAS HE RIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SOLOMON
AT THIS MOTION BY CENTER TYLER
DOES DO PASSED TO BANKING AND
JUST A REMINDER TO THE COMMITTEE
THE AMENDMENTS -- THE SUNSET.
FOR THE INCREASE CAP WILL BE
TAKEN IN BANKING SO ARE THOSE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN IN
BANKING THIS IS.
THE OFFICIAL MOTION IS A DO
PASSED THE BANKING.
MANCHESTER ROLL CALL PLEASE WIRE
I REQUIRE I'M MORE LAW.
YEAH.
THE AYE HERTZBERG RICARDO.
HELLO I NIELSEN I YOU'LL SAID I
WIENER [inaudible]
YEAH.
KERN ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP A REAL OPEN WE
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S TIME TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GRATEFUL FOR THE EFFORT.
NEVER GOT THAT ONE OF BEFORE
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ALL.
WELCOME IS THE NUMBER GIPSON TO
THE ICE THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS
SUMMER WE ARE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLE ON ONE ITEM MR SOME WOMEN
IF THAT'S OKAY THESE -- THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE THIRTY ONE
THIS HAS A MOTION OF DO PASSES
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY.
CENTER TARA I KNOW YOU WANT TO
BE TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE YES
SO I WILL -- BE CHANGED MY BUT
TODAY FROM OF STRAINING TO AND I
AND THE COURTESY I AND I HAVE
RESERVE MY RIGHT -- TO VOTE NO
ON THEFLOOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER TANTO.
I CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE DO PASSES AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY MESSENGER MISLAID
TESTER CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WIRE [inaudible]
MORE LAW [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
NEW WILL SURVIVE.
DID YOU GET. FOR CALLING
[inaudible]
PERFECT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WE NEED.
TO MAYOR MARK MORIAL
[inaudible]
WHY?
YEAH WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE --
ON ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY ONE WE DID HAVE
STATEMENT BY -- THE GOOD SENATOR
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FROM SINGER
MISSING CHESTER MORE TIME LET'S
OPEN THE ROLE.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
RICARDO [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible] FOR ONE
FOR ONE ALL RIGHT THAT CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FOUR ONE VOTE WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO A SIMILAR GIPSON WANNA
APOLOGIZE TO THIS IN THE NUMBER --
AS WE'VE BEEN KEEPING YOU
WAITING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I'M SORRY THAT WE WENT
INTO THE AFTERNOON SERRANO THAT
YOU ARE BUSY -- MR CINNAMON YOUR
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS IS -- WE
GET LIKE A BIPARTISAN HIS.
THIRTY TIMES SO -- JEEZ.
MR SOMEONE WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
STATEMENT IN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SHERMAN
MCGUIRE AND ALSO SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BUILD A NINE FIVE FIVE
WHICH SEEKS TO PROVIDE THE WATER
REPLACEMENT -- DISTRICT KNOWN AS
A W. W. R. D. -- THE RESOURCES --
TO CONDUCT A REGIONAL ASSESSMENT
OF THE WATER SYSTEMS ACROSS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TERRITORY --
THIS BE OKAY HAS COME OUT OF
ABUNDANCE OF THE BILL THAT I DID
LAST YEAR ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WHERE IT'S TOOK
OVER.
OF THE AUTHORITY FOCUS I FAILING
WATER SKI MY DISTRICT CALLS THE
TIVO.
THIS WILL PROVIDE AN ASSESSMENT --
ACROSS THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TERRITORY SO THAT WE CAN ASSESS
OF SMALL THE WATER OF AGENCIES
MAKING SURE -- THAT QUALITY
WATERS PROVIDED TO THE RESIDENCE --
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
WE ALSO HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE --
FROM AT W. RG TO WISH TO MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH
INTEREST SOMEONE WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR THE ABILITY TO WORK WITH YOU
SIR.
WELCOME TO COMMITTEE IF YOU GIVE
US YOUR FIRST LASSEN
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU BOB READ
WITH READ GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL.
AND GIVEN THE THE LATENESS OF
THE DAY BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE NOT
GONNA OPEN UP FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU
ALL CAN COME FORWARD LOOKING FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT.
WITH MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY THE
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
THOSE WERE IN OPPOSITION.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WE HAVE A MOTION A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
TYLER THIS IS A DO PASSING AFTER
RESOURCES AND WATER.
LOOKING FOR ANY CONVERSATION --
THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
HEARING SEEN.
NINE THIS IS THE DO PASSING
AFTER RESOURCES WATER.
GIVE US ONE MOMENT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS A NUMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PROVIDE US WITH ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS RESPECTFULLY AS RIVAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS GOING TO
SERVE YOU TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE I'M MORE
LOS.
MORE LIKE NINE BELL.
YEAH I HERTZBERG RICARDO.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
YES AND I WIENER.
THE CURRENT ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE MR SOMEONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU RATE OVER HERE
THE ROLE OPEN AND HAVE SOME
FOLKS OUT ON THANK YOU.
THIS YEAR WE GOT A DOUBLE HEADER
COMING ON RIGHT HERE.
WE GOT ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AN
ITEM TWENTY ONE ITEM FIFTEEN IN
ITEM.
TWENTY ONE I TO FIFTEEN IS AB.
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN WE WELCOME.
THE OTHER RUBIO HOT DAY WATCH
OUT REGINALD WITH THE ORIGINAL
RUBIO YOU'RE RIGHT HERE.
RIGHT THAT IS A GOOD ONE EIGHT
EVERY GO.
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL THAT THE
SIM THE WOMAN -- IS HERE TODAY
WE WANT A WE LOVE HAVING THE
SOMEONE COMMITTEE SHE'S
WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH -- BETTER
IS A MEMBER IAN THE FLOORS YOURS
AN ITEM FIFTEEN ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB ONE ONE ONE EIGHT
THE AGE FRIENDLY CALIFORNIA ACT
AS A NOTE THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL REMOVED THE
OPPOSITION RECEIVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE OPPOSITION FOR THEIR
CUT COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH
MYSELF AND THE BILL'S SPONSORS.
AS YOU'RE ALL AWARE OF THE SHARE
OF THAT CALIFORNIA POPULATION
REACHING RETIREMENT AGE IS
GROWING RAPIDLY.
IN FACT THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATES THAT BY TWENTY THIRTY
JUST ELEVEN YEARS AWAY THIS
POPULATION WILL GROW BY FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE.
I THIS RAPID GROWTH RATE
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE TO ACT TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S AGING POPULATION
HAS ACCESS TO ACCESSIBLE
COMMUNITIES.
AND THE CARE AND RESOURCES THEY
NEED AND DESERVE.
THAT IS WHY I AM VERY EXCITED TO
AUTHOR A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
WHICH WILL LAUNCH CALIFORNIA TO
THE FUTURE AS AN H. FRIEND THE
STATE.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
DIRECT THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
APPLY TO BE A MEMBER OF THE A A
RP IS NETWORK OF EIGHT OF EACH
FRIENDLY STATES AND COMMUNITIES.
MANY CITIES ALREADY SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF UTILIZING THE AGE
FRIENDLY NETWORK AS A PATH
FORWARD TO CITY TO CITY PLANNING
INCLUDING.
BERKELEY SAN FRANCISCO
SACRAMENTO LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO
WAS HOLLYWOOD IN CINEMA COUNTY
JUST TO NAME A FEW -- AS A
MEMBER OF THE NETWORK CALIFORNIA
WILL DEMONSTRATE ITS COMMITMENT
TO OUR AGING POPULATION BY
ENCOURAGING STATES POLICYMAKERS.
PLANNERS AND DEVELOPERS TO USE
A. R. P.'S COLLECTION OF
RESOURCES INCLUDING EXAMPLES OF
BEST PRACTICES TOOL KITS DATA
AND DELIVER THE LIVABILITY INDEX
TO DEVELOP COMMUNITIES IN AN
EIGHT FROM THE MANNER -- WITH ME
TODAY IS AN HIDDEN MEMBER OF A A
RP TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND
ASSIST IN ANSWERING ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH ROSA MEMBER WE WANNA
TAKE MOM TO RECOGNIZE THIS AND
SHE HAS BEEN HERE ALL DAY HI AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT SHE'S BEEN
CAMPING OUT AND READY TO GO.
I AND WE JUST WANNA APOLOGIZE
MA'AM FOR KEEPING YOU WAITING
HERE TODAY THANK YOU FOR HANGING
WITH US THE FLOORS SOURCE --
GOOD AFTERNOON A CHAIR MAT WHERE
AND VICE CHAIR MCLOUGHLIN.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
AS WAS SAID MY NAME IS ANN
HAMPTON AND I SERVE AS A SENIOR
VOLUNTEER WITH A A RP CALIFORNIA.
AND EYES AS IN THAT CAPACITY I
WORK WITH THEM ON THEIR
STRATEGIC H. FRIENDLY TEAM.
PRIOR TO THAT I WAS FOR ABOUT
ELEVEN YEARS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT AGING
ADULT SERVICES FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
IN ADDITION TO THAT I HAVE ABOUT
FORTY YEARS WORKING ON PUBLIC
POLICY SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
WITH OLDER ADULTS AND YOUNGER
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES.
SO ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS A. R. P. MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
EIGHTEEN THE H. FRIENDLY
CALIFORNIA ACT OF NINETEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN AS WAS SAID ON
THE AGING.
POPULATION CALIFORNIA HAS HAD
UNPRECEDENTED GROWTH IN THIS IS
YOU SAID IN TEN YEARS WILL HAVE
ANOTHER FOUR MILLION FOLKS
JOINING THIS GROUP -- IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT ABOUT 85% 87% OF THIS GROUP
OF PEOPLE REALLY WANT TO STAY IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES SOMETIMES WE
SAY PEOPLE WANT TO STAND ON
HOMES BUT THE TRUTH IS PEOPLE
WANT.
TO STAY IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY'VE LIVED IN THAT THEY HAVE
PROVIDED -- GROWS TO AN
OPPORTUNITIES AND A COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY LOVE BUT IN SOME CASES
PEOPLE NEED THE OPPORTUNITIES
AND THE OPTIONS TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT.
IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A STRATEGIC
PLAN TO ADDRESS THIS GROWING
DEMOCRATIC GRAPHIC SHIP.
A PLAN THAT WILL PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD NEW
LIVABLE INFRASTRUCTURES THAT
MEET THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE OF ALL
AGES FRANKLY. ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
INSURERS AT THE STATE LEADERSHIP
MOVES TOWARDS CREATING
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE LIVABLE FOR
ALL.
AN ACTION THAT A. R. P. STRONGLY
BELIEVE IT NEEDS LEGISLATIVE BY
AN IS THERE ARE REPORT AND
POLICY IMPLICATIONS IN FRONT OF
US.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE AS
WAS SAID THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH TO INCLUDE ELEMENTS
OF THE LITTLE BILL LIVABILITY AS
OUTLINED IN THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION INTO THE GENERAL.
PLANNING GUIDELINES TO ENCOURAGE
STRONGER CONSIDERATION FOR OLDER
ADULTS I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
THE DOCUMENT NOW YOU'D FIND THAT
OLDER ADULTS ARE.
BARELY MENTIONED IN THAT
DOCUMENT AND YET IT'S A DOCUMENT
COMMUNITIES USE ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
THESE ELEMENTS AS WE REFER TO
THEM AS THE EIGHT TO A MAN TO
LIVE ABILITY INCLUDE THAT.
THE THINGS THAT YOU WOULD THINK
OF RIGHT OFF THE TOP OF YOUR
HEAD OUTDOOR SPACES IN BUILDINGS
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING SOCIAL
PARTICIPATION.
CIVICS UNEMPLOYED APPOINTMENT
COMMUNICATION INFORMATION JUST
TO NAME A FEW.
AB ELEVEN EIGHTEEN ALIGNS WITH
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO CREATE A MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING.
THAT WILL INCLUDE A STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE RESEARCH
SUBCOMMITTEE WITH AN INTEREST IN
BUILDING.
H. FAMILY CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS BILL WILL ENROLL
CALIFORNIA IN THE NETWORK -- I
MENTIONED THAT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION THAT'S WHERE THIS
BEGAN IN TEN DIFFERENT CITIES
ACROSS THE WORLD -- AND THEN
THEY APPROACH CHAIR P. TO BE THE
UNITED STATES OF PHILLY AT SO
NOW THE WORK.
OF LOCAL A WHICH COMES THROUGH
US -- AND THIS S REALLY THE
WORK BEGAN AND IT'S STILL GOING
TO HELP COMMUNITIES PREPARE FOR
THIS RAPID.
AGING POPULATION BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT THE ONLY ONES OUR WAY.
WITH THIS ACTION CALIFORNIA WILL
JOIN FOR OTHER STATES WHO HAVE
MADE THIS COMMITMENT NEW YORK
COLORADO MASSACHUSETTS IN
FLORIDA.
SOME OF THEM WITH.
A SWORD THIRTY SECONDS MA'AM I
APOLOGIZE OKAY SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS -- THIS BILL
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY
VERY GRATEFUL IN AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US TODAY YOU'RE ALWAYS WELCOME.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSS
ON BEHALF THE CITY OF GLENDALE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
WE LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT ABILITY TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
CURRENCY NINE WHEN I WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME ANYONE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED.
CURRENCY NO OPPOSITION WOULD
LIKE TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WE HAVE A MOTION.
BY CENTER TACO THIS IS A DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD LIKE ME TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONVERSATIONS MISTER
VICE CHAIR -- I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE.
GOING TO DEAL WITH THE AGING
POPULATION I CERTAINLY RESEMBLE.
GRAPHIC THEY WERE ALL HEADING
THAT WAY.
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF OUR BUT
LACKS RETIRED YOU BILL FOR
CONGRESSMAN BRAD SHERMAN.
AND WE WORK TOGETHER AND THE
CINNAMON TO BOB NAY WAS GONNA
CARRY THE BILL.
AND THEN HE DISAPPEARED SO I
THOUGHT WELL I'LL JUST CARRY IT
MYSELF IT.
RELATED TO CPA'S.
AND AND THEN I GOT HAMMERED
BECAUSE I WAS TOLD IT WAS SELF
SERVING.
AND SO I HAD TO WITHDRAW THE
BILL I YOU KNOW I WOULD HAVE.
BEEN IN FRONT BENEFITTED FROM
THE BILL THAT I'M NEW HERE.
RIGHT SO I I DIDN'T QUITE.
GET IT -- IT WAS JUST LIKE OKAY
LET'S JUST DO THIS SO I'M.
MIKE MY QUESTION ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS MISTER CHAIRS -- I
HAVEN'T SEEN A BILL WHERE
SOMEONE.
IS THE SPONSOR WHO WILL THEN BE
THE PROVIDER OF THE SERVICES.
AND I'M LIKE YOURSELF COME FROM
IS SUPERB IS ORIEL.
BACKGROUND SO USUALLY YOU'RE
YOU'RE USED TO LOOKING AT
CONTRACTS RELATING DEPARTMENTS
THE COULD CONTRACTS AND SO.
I I WAS CONFUSED WHEN I SAW THE
ITEM SO I SO IF YOU COULD JUST
KINDA.
HELP ME OUT HERE -- ON ON HOW
THIS WORKS WILL WHETHER THE
POLICIES OF THE STATE.
AND YOURS IS FOR FREE OR IS IT.
A GRAND TOUR YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
WE GOT IT OUT OF A PROBE CELL.
WHICH YOU KNOW IT'S NOT.
THIS BILL IS NOT THE SAME AS
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES IT'S
REALLY ABOUT POLICY.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DOCUMENT THAT WE'RE REFERRING.
TO AND YOU READ THROUGH IT IT'S
A GREAT DOCUMENT I MEAN IT
REALLY IT IS WHAT OUR
COMMUNITIES USE -- FOR GUIDANCE
IN OUR LOCAL IN OUR HOMES -- BUT
THERE'S NOT MUCH IN THAT
DOCUMENT THAT RELATES TO OLDER
ADULTS AND I KNOW YOU COULD SAY
WELL IF IT BENEFITS.
YOU KNOW THE THE DOCUMENT TRIES
TO BENEFIT EVERYBODY BUT THE
TRUTH SO THE TRUTH IS THAT OLDER
ADULTS HAVE -- ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND WANTED TO REMAIN.
BE COMPENSATED FOR THERE'S NO
THERE'S NOT REALLY ANY DOLLARS
INVOLVED IN THIS EXCEPT FOR IT
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY PLACING
LANGUAGE INTO THE PLAN ITSELF.
AND THEN LOCAL COMMUNITIES HAVE
THAT AS GUIDANCE AS THEY MOVE
FORWARD.
HELLO [inaudible]
WE'RE ASKING -- P. R..
HALF OF THE STATE TO JOIN A. A.
R. P.'S NETWORK OF AGE FRIENDLY
STATES AND COMMUNITIES RIGHT.
IT WAS SAD.
I CLUB.
OR IS THAT WELL I GUESS YOU
COULD THINK OF IS A SPECIAL CLUB --
AS I SAID THERE'S ONLY FOUR
STATES INVOLVED RIGHT BUT IS
CALIFORNIA THERE'S THIRTY SIX
COMMUNITIES -- INCLUDING CITIES
AND TOWNS AND COUNTIES SO -- IN
MANY OF THOSE COMMUNITIES HAVE
NOT PUT DOLLARS IN TO THIS
EFFORT A LOT OF THE SEPARATIST
WORK THROUGH BY VOLUNTEERS OF
CENTER MAKE LIKE MYSELF.
THAT ARE MORE LIKE -- SKINNER
BROUGH QUICK.
SENATE RESEARCH.
I JUST WANT TO CLEAR THIS ISN'T
ABOUT SERVICES PROGRAMS FINAL
COMEY DARE PETE'S.
THE SOCIALLY IN PLEASE PUSH BACK
ON ME ALIGNING THE GOVERNOR
THIRTY TAKING ACTION TO BE ABLE --
TO RIGHT TO MOVE ON THIS WITH
THAT TO HIS PLAN AND NOW WE'RE
ALIGNING REST OF THE STATE WILL
AND THE WAY I SEE IT.
IF YOU WOULD -- CENTERED MORE
LIKE AS I SEE IT IS IT JUST A
STRATEGIC PLAN TO THE COUNTIES
THE CITY'S DEVELOP STRATEGIC
PLANS I MEAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS DO
THE SAME THING ON WHAT WE SEE
THE VISION OF YOU KNOW MOVING
FORWARD IS ALL IT REALLY IT'S
JOINING NETWORK SO THAT.
THAT EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY CAN HAVE THE
SAME -- STRATEGIC PLANNING -- IT
DOESN'T IT'S NOT MONEY BASED I
THE WAY I SEE IT AS YOU CONNECT
TO THEIR NETWORK INSTEAD OF
REINVENTING THE WHEEL YOU'RE
JUST SAYING OKAY WELL HOW CAN WE
BEST SERVE THAT.
THE AIR PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY SHARON
ON SIDEWALKS FOR EXAMPLE AND
THEN JUST BEING ABLE TO GO TO
ONE PLACE AND SAY HEY THIS IS
WHAT EVERYBODY ELSE IS DOING AND
SO THAT WERE OUT THAT ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES ARE CONSISTENT WITH
EACH OTHER.
AND WE DON'T HAVE ONE COMMUNITY
THAT YOU KOW THE SITE WIDE I'M
JUST USING YOU KNOW EXAMPLE THE
SIDEWALK IS THIS WAY BY BACK
COMMUNITIES THAT WAY IF WE HAVE
A STRATEGIC PLAN.
AND WE HAVE ONE YOU KNOW CENTRAL
PLACE TO LOOK AT IT THEN I KNOW
THAT CONSISTENTLY ALL OF THE THE
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO TO SAY
HEY THIS IS WHAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE AND THIS IS HOW
WE CAN HELP THE OF THE THE BABY.
WILL POPULATION HAVE THAT OF ME
WITH YOUR VISION -- WE'VE GOT
THE GOVERNOR THAT SIRI YES.
ANNOUNCED AN INITIATIVE WE WE
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN A COUPLE
BILLS IN THE SENATE YES I'M IN
YOUR WAY.
HOW DOES THIS ALL DOVETAIL
TOGETHER ON WHAT'S THE VISION?
SO I WOULD SAY THAT HAVING RUN A
OF SITTING COUNTY DEPARTMENT FOR
ELEVEN YEARS AND HAVE RUN A LOT
OF PROGRAMS OR WORK IN PUBLIC
POLICY.
IN MANY WAYS THIS IS YOU COULD
SEE THIS AS THE UMBRELLA FOR THE
REST OF THE WORK.
BECAUSE COMMUNITIES CAN CHOOSE
WHAT IT IS THEY WANT TO WORK ON
SOME CITIES HAVE DECIDED WELL
THERE'S A DOMAIN SO I'M GOING TO
WORK ON TO SOME CITIES HAVE
DECIDED WELL I'M GONNA WORK ON A
LATE MAYBE I'LL ADD ONE BECAUSE
I I DON'T WANT TO JUST DO HEALTH.
I WANT TO DO ALZHEIMER'S
SPECIFICALLY SO IT'S REALLY
ABOUT WHAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WANT TO DO THIS ASSEMBLY
LANGUAGE THAT GOES INTO THAT
DOCUMENT.
THAT PROVIDES SOME --
INFORMATION TO THEM ABOUT WHAT
MIGHT BE POSSIBLE AND THEN BY
JOINING THE NETWORK YOU DO GET
ACCESS IT WAS WAS SAID EARLIER.
TO OUR PLANNING DOCUMENTS ARE
RESEARCH ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE TO YOU THAT WE'VE
ALREADY DEVELOPED FROM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY NOT JUST FROM
COMMUNITIES AND IN CALIFORNIA
BUT THIS IS AN INITIATIVE OF
COURSE THAT'S ACROSS THE COUNTRY
SO.
THAT'S WHY THERE'S NOT DOLLARS
INVOLVED IN IT.
IT'S MORE OF A MASTER PLAN FOR
THE COMMUNITIES LAST QUESTION
AND I'M NOT SEE THE OFFICE.
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH AS A
SUPPORTER OF THE BILL.
AND SO THAT WAS ALSO A CONCERN
THAT THEY WERE JUST SORT OF
IMPOSING SOMETHING.
ARE THEY IN SUPPORT OF THE
TYPICALLY AS LEGISLATION WAS
FORD DEPARTMENTS ARE GOING TO
ENGAGE THIS EARLY.
SO -- HEY IT'S ME IT'S A MORE
COMMON THAN NOT THAT DEPARTMENTS
WON'T TAKE A POSITION ON THE
BILL SO ALL AND THEN I THINK.
YEAH NO NO ABSOLUTELY.
NO NO NO NO DON'T DON'T ON
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
LIKE TO GET IT THE NIGHT BEFORE
RIGHT NO I TRUST ME I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND ABSOLUTELY -- FOR
TWELVE YEARS YEAH YOU KNOW RIGHT
RIGHT WHAT'S GOING ON WELL AND I
THINK -- YOU KNOW YOU ASK
QUESTION ABOUT -- THE GOVERNOR'S
ORDER AND SO THAT THE GOVERNOR
IS SPECIFICALLY IS ASKING
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A MASTER
PLAN AND I THINK I SEE IT AS A
TOOL FOR DEVELOPING THAT PLAN SO
THAT IT'S CONSISTENT WITH.
WITH YOU KNOW REALLY WITH THE A.
R. P. -- THEY'VE ALREADY DONE
THE RESEARCH FOR THEM AND SO
IT'S JUST BUT MY MY OPINION JUST
CONNECTING THEM TO THESE ARE THE
RESOURCES WHEN YOU'RE CONVENING
THE STAKEHOLDERS YOU CAN LOOK AT
THE THE THIS PLAN ALREADY TO SAY
OKAY THIS IS WHAT THEY RECOMMEND
CAN WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT.
SO I ALSO LOOK AT IT AS A TOOL
AND OF COURSE THE YOU KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD ENGAGE I THINK
IF THEY NED THEY NEEDED EXTRA --
OUT PERSON ALRP EXTRA MONEY FOR
THIS BUT BECAUSE IT'S NOT.
THERE'S NO MONEY INVOLVED THE
DEPARTMENT WARNING GATES THIS
EARLY.
MY OPINION -- THEY WOULD IF
THERE WAS A COST OR ADDITIONAL
WORK FOR THEM SO TO ME THAT'S A
GOOD THING THAT THEY'RE NOT
ASKED TO DO MORE IF ANYTHING
THIS WILL HELP THEM WITH AND
CREATING THAT MASTER PLAN.
BY PROVIDING THE TOOLS THAT ARE
ALREADY AVAILABLE.
WHEN I GO TO CENTER TITLED WAS
FRAZIER OF GOOD ON THAT?
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FREHLEY
JIMMY I I'M I'M SO I KNOW I LOVE
THE YOUR GOOD LUCK THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE.
WE OFTEN DO MORE RESEARCH.
ABSOLUTE ABSOLUTE MACINNES ROGER
SIR TARA -- ANYTHING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S IN
GERMAN THE COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE
A MOTION A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY SENATOR HER TITLE THIS IS A
TO PASS YOUR PREPARATION.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
SIMILAR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH REMEMBER THANKS TO THE
CONVERSATION SESSIONS THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR BEING HERE TODAY AS
FAR YOUR TICKET FOR THE
CONVERSATION AS WELL.
THANK YESTERDAY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HI WHERE I'M MORE ALONG.
GAIL.
WELL I HERTZBERG RICARDO.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
YES AND I WINNER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN AND ALLOW MEMBERS AT ON
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE THE LAST ITEM -- FOR
MISS RUBIO THEY WERE GONNA GO
STRAIGHT TO MISS BURKE THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY THE TAX LEVY.
IT'S RUBIO FORESHORES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THE OUT THE FOR
THIS ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT BILL FIFTEEN NINETY HERE
TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTED IN
COMMENTS FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS
WHICH WOULD REMOVE THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
REQUIREMENT. FOR THE BILL AS
WELL AS THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN COMMON SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS -- AB FIFTY NINETY AS
PROPOSED -- TO BE AMENDED WOULD
CREATE A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
TAX CREDIT FOR LOW OR MODERATE
INCOME FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WITH THE WORSENING HOUSING
CRISIS OPPORTUNITIES FOR FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS ARE LIMITED DUE
TO INCREASING COSTS ESPECIALLY
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES OF
LOW OR MODERATE INCOME.
THIS INCREASING COSTS INCLUDES
UNFORESEEN EXPENSES THAT CAN
OCCUR VERY SOON AFTER PURCHASE
SUCH AS AN ANTICIPATED REPAIRS.
NISSAN FORCING EXPENSES CAN ALSO
LEAVE FIRST TIME LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOME BUYERS.
ARE EXASPERATED AS THEY STRUGGLE
TO MAINTAIN HOME OWNERSHIP WITH
THE SKYROCKETING RENTAL AND
HOUSING COSTS ACROSS THE STATE
A. B. FIFTEEN NINETY CREATES A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE. FOR FOR LOW
TO MODERATE INCOME INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES LOOKING TO PURSUE
THE PATHWAY TO HOME OWNERSHIP.
THIS BILL PROMOTED FINANCIAL
PROSPERITY AND PROVIDES NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA TO
INVEST IN THE FUTURE BY BECOMING
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS -- IN IF
I MAY JUST CONTINUE THE MY
FRUSTRATION.
WITH A LOT OF THE RENTAL OR A
LOT OF THE WHOLE.
HOUSING CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN
CENTERED AROUND -- PUTTING
PEOPLE IN APARTMENTS -- AND
THAT'S HOW I FEEL AND I THINK --
WE CAN DO MORE FOR OUR FOLKS BY
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BOBBY HOME OWNERS -- THE THE
NUMBER Y. AT ONE WAY OF CREATING
WEALTH IS HOME OWNERSHIP AND IF
WE CAN PROVIDE THIS INCENTIVE
FOR LOW TO MODERATE INCOME FOLKS.
I THINK WE ARE NOT ONLY
PROVIDING A STABLE HOME BUT ALSO
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD WEALTH --
THOSE OF YOU THAT AT THAT HAVE A
PROPERTIES YOU KNOW EVENTUALLY
THOSE PROPERTIES ARE GOING TO BE
WILL TO YOUR CHILDREN AND I
THINK THAT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO TO RE WE INVEST.
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP AGAIN MY
FRUSTRATION HAS BEEN THAT WE
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW WITH.
MODERN WHAT IS IT UP THE WHOLE
HOUSING COSTS BUT WE WANT TO PUT
PEOPLE IN APARTMENTS I THINK
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR LOW
TO MODERATE INCOME FOLKS TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OWN THEIR OWN
HOMES SO -- WITH THAT -- WITH ME
TODAY.
I LOST MY MY TRAIN THOUGHT IS
OCCURRING TRACY ON BEHALF OF OUR
SPONSORS -- BUT THE CALIFORNIA
REALTORS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PLEASE OF COURSE YOURS YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES SIR COULD YOU SEE
HIS HER THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING OF OF RATHER GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
CREAM THREE CM HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS VERY PROUD TO BE THE
SPONSOR OF AB FIFTEEN NINETY IN
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY HAVE --
IN VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE OF
THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND
AND COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE BILL
AND AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RATTLED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WHAT A
COUPLE COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM WE
WELCOME YOU BACK SIR.
FORESHORES BORROW SOME OF THE
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT
THAT ON THANK YOU SO MUCH WOULD
LIKE TO RECEIVE IS ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL BE PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
WE LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT WE'RE
NOT GONNA ASK FOR THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED. TO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HEARING SCENERY BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
THRESHER.
I JUST WANT TO CONGRATULATE
ASSUME AND RUBIO YOU GOT IT
THROUGH PROBES YES I DID I DID
SOMETHING LIKE THIS LAST YEAR
FOR FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS IT
DIDN'T GET OUT OF A BROKE.
SO AB.
AT EIGHT PM ASSEMBLY LITTLE
BRUISED BUT YES WE GOT IT --
OVER.
BUT I JUST WANTED.
A YOU KNOW WE WE'VE HAD LOTS OF
DISCUSSIONS THIS KENNEDY ABOUT
TAX CREDITS SO I'M.
YOU KNOW DISCOUNT.
BEEN KINDA NERVOUS ABOUT HIM.
NO IN A COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND IF
I MAY YOU KNOW JUST RESPOND I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTOOD THE DOOR
STAND -- BAD BY YOU KNOW AS A
LIVING IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA I
CAN TELL YOU FIRST HAND THAT
IT'S VERY REALLY REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR EVEN SOMEBODY THAT
IS A MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
TO PURCHASE.
A HOME -- BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW
ALL OF THE FINANCIAL.
BURDENS AND NEVER YOU KNOW DON'T
EVEN TALK ABOUT THAT A HOUSING --
COSTS IN LA AND SO.
I AM NERVOUS ABOUT IT TOO BUT I
THINK THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO REALLY GIVE FOLKS A REAL
LIVE OF REAL OPPORTUNITY TO OWN
A HOME AND BUILD THAT WALL THAT
WE ALL.
YOU KNOW WE ALL KEEP TALKING
ABOUT -- PULLING PEOPLE ALL OF
PART OF POVERTY AND I THINK THIS
MIGHT BE A GOOD INCENTIVE FOR
FOR FOLKS TO REALLY THINK ABOUT
OWNING HORNS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS SO MUCH WOULD LIKE TO
RECEIVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WITH EMOTION.
WITH A MOTION BY CENTER NIELSEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER NIELSEN
ADISA BEFORE WE GO TO CLOSING
COMING JUST WANNA SAY THIS FOCUS
IS.
REALLY ON THOSE AREAS THOSE
FAMILIES -- INDIVIDUALS NOT TO
EXCEED A 120% IT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
IN REGARDS TO HOMEOWNERSHIP.
THEY ARE -- MAKING TOO MUCH
MONEY -- TO BE ABLE TO GO ON THE
LOW DOSE LOW MODERATE BUT IT'S
ONE OF THE HARDEST TO HOUSE INTO
A VERY GRATEFUL FOR THIS -- IN
FREE WORK -- MISS RUBY REJECT
CLUBS THANK YOU I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH WITH THE
MOTION ON THE FLOOR THIS IS TO
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS MISSING CHESTER.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI.
I'M MORE LONG.
BELL.
WELL I HERTZBERG FURTADO.
OUR AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I WINNER. TWENTY TWO IS
A FOUR ZERO VOCAL READY TO ROLL
OPEN IN AT FOLKS HONEST COME
BACK THANK YOU AYE LAYING SHE
DOUBLE HEADER RIGHT THERE WITH
YOU.
SHOP REVEAL.
GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU SO THE
WOMAN FOR A JOB.
AS GERMAN WE HAVE SEEN BOTH.
WOMEN CHAIR WOMEN.
COME ON UP A MAN -- WE HAD --
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL --
CHAIRWOMAN BURKE HANDLES ALL
ISSUES.
FINANCE -- IN REVENUE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE -- ONE TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU SHE'S
BEEN WORK IN -- SO HARD THIS
YEAR ONE ON THE WAY FAIR.
INTO LIVING THE DREAM ON CLOSING
THE TAX LOOPHOLE ON THAT ACT --
EXACTLY.
SO -- IN TODAY SHE'S GONNA BE
BRINGING FORWARD AB EIGHT NINETY
ONE I ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
SOON FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
BILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SINCE HER AND AS
SENATORS I WANTED BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
COMMITTEE MA'AM IT'S IN COMMENTS
FOUR AND FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS.
AND ALWAYS AS ALWAYS THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS MEASURE AB EIGHT NINETY
ONE REQUIRE CITIES AND TOWNS
WITH POPULATIONS GREATER THAN
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND TO ESTABLISH.
A PARKING PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
THE PARKING LOCATIONS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN THEIR
VEHICLES.
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY
CLARIFY THAT A COUNTY WITH A
POPULATION OF ONE MILLION OR
LESS SHALL BE DEEMED COMPLIANT
WITH THE BILL IF THE CITY
LOCATED IN THAT COUNTY HAS
VOLUNTARILY ADOPTED AS A PARKING
PROGRAM.
THAT MEETS THE REQUIREMENTS.
AB EIGHT NINETY ONE PROVIDES
LOCAL PROGRAMS WITH THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ESTABLISH RULES
AND REGULATIONS THAT FIT LOCAL
NEEDS AS WELL AS AN APPLICATION
PROCESS THAT CAN INCLUDE A
BACKGROUND CHECK FOR
PARTICIPANTS.
PROGRAMS COULD BE CREATED UNDER
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO BE
ENCOURAGED TO COORDINATE WITH
LOCAL NONPROFITS AS WELL AS CITY
AND COUNTY AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND ACCESS TO SOCIAL
SERVICES -- THAT LEAD TO LONG
TERM HOUSING.
AB EIGHT NINETY ONE SHOULD BE
SEEN AS A COMPLEMENTARY TO
CALIFORNIA'S ONGOING EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS OUR HOUSING CRISIS AND
IS NOT INTENDED TO SUPPLEMENT.
PLANNING OR FACILITATING LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS TO PREVENT AND
END HOMELESSNESS THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE THAT ARE LIVING IN THEIR
VEHICLES HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO
STAY OVERNIGHT WELL THE WORK TO
TRICK TRANSITION TO A MORE
PERMANENT HOUSING.
WITH ME TODAY WHO HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY PATIENT -- PROFESSOR
GARY PAINTER THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MANAGER
SPRINTER WE WALK ME THREE OF TWO
MINUTES THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
THANK YOU -- AS YOU MENTIONED
I'M A PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S PRICE WILL PUBLIC
POLICY AND I'M ALSO THE DIRECTOR
OF THE HOMELESSNESS POLICY
RESEARCH INSTITUTE WHICH WAS
RECENTLY.
LAUNCHED ONE YEAR AGO I I OFTEN
CALL EACH PEER I JUST IT FOR
SHORT BECAUSE THAT'S A MOUTHFUL --
IT COMPRISES THIRTY OUR
RESEARCHERS FROM A VARIETY OF
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS THINK
TANKS AND RESEARCH ORGANIZATIONS
WERE WORKING COLLECTIVELY TO IN
HOMELESSNESS IN LA COUNTY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO STATE MY
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY ONE WHICH REQUIRES
JURISDICTIONS TO DEVELOP.
A PARKING PROGRAMS IF IT MEETS
THE REQUIREMENTS OUTLINED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE.
RECENTLY H. BRI PUBLISHED AN
ANALYSIS OF SAY PARKING PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE WEST COAST OF UNITED
STATES ALL OF WHICH HAVE
COLLECTIVELY HOUSE OVER.
THOUSANDS OF PARTICIPANTS INTO
HOUSING THIS ANALYSIS FOUND ALSO
BASED ON DATA FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DEMOGRAPHIC
SURVEY.
IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
THAT 35% OF THOSE WHO ARE
HOMELESS ACTUALLY RELY ON THEIR
CAR AS THEIR PRIMARY MODE OF
SHELTER -- ACCORDINGLY SAY PROBE
SAY PARKING PROGRAMS ARE AN
IMPORTANT POLICY INVESTMENT FOR
HOMELESS NEIGHBORS THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DATA ALSO
NOTED THAT THE MAJORITY OF LA
COUNTY RESIDENTS WHO LIVE IN
THEIR CARS -- I HAD BEEN FORCED
TO DO SO BECAUSE OF A LOSS OF A
JOB AND THE MAJORITY OF THESE
RESIDENTS WHO ARE LIVING IN
THEIR CARS ARE ACTIVELY SEEKING
WORK OR ACTUALLY ARE CURRENTLY.
FULL TIME OR PART TIME EMPLOYED
THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDE VEHICLE
DWELLERS A SAFE AND LEGAL PLACE
TO PARK AND SLEEP IN THEIR
VEHICLES OVERNIGHT.
AND THESE PROGRAMS ALSO PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR EACH TO
BRING SERVICES RANGING FROM
HYGIENE TO HELP THE JOB
PLACEMENT TO HOUSING TO
VULNERABLE FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS.
IN SOME ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
NINETY ONE WOULD PROVIDE A
SECURE AND HUMANE SPACE FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
LIVING IN THEIR VEHICLES THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE JURISDICTIONS
TO ESTABLISH AND PLAN FOR SICK
PARKING PROGRAM'S.
CLOSE THEM OVERNIGHT AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE EACH ONE OF
YOU TO VOTE I ON A. B..
EIGHT NINETY ONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR FEDERAL GRATEFUL -- FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN YOUR WORK
ESPECIALLY IN LA COUNTY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WOULD LIKE TO
BETTER OPEN UP TO ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE THIS BECAUSE FOR THE
BILL.
GIVE US YOUR FIRST LAST NAME IN
ORGANIZATION WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU TAKE A BREAK
A WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORK CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANKS RANG WITH US
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LAST CALL WHEN I WOULD LIKE TO
GO TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE WHO
MAY BE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
LAST CALL.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THE VICE CHAIR FOR CHORES.
THE PROFESSORS BEEN HERE ALL DAY
WE SHOULD BECAUSE BRAIN A LITTLE
BIT.
SO WE HAVE THESE MODELS ARE
SANTA BARBARA SAN DIEGO.
HOW HOW HOW?
HOW THEY WORK AND IF YOU HAVE
YOU VISITED?
THE I'VE I'M NOT PERSONALLY
VISITED ANY OF THEM WHAT I HAVE
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS WE'VE
ANALYZED TIME DIFFERENT REPORTS
AND THINGS THAT HAVE COME OUT
FROM THEM -- TO ASSESS HOW
EFFECTIVE WITH IN THOSE AREAS
HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN ABLE TO KIND
OF ACHIEVED THEIR PROGRAM GOALS.
AND ARE THE GOOD MODELS.
I'M DAVE THEY PROVEN TO HAVE
ENOUGH ADVOCACY THAT I THINK
WHAT WE SHOULD THINK HARD ABOUT
IS THIS FEELING THAT A SINCE
WE'RE IN A CRISIS MODE YOU KNOW
THE I I KIND OF YOU THIS AS A
CRISIS INTERVENTION AND AND
UNFORTUNATELY TO DATE MANY
PLACES HAVEN'T DONE.
PROPER EMERGENCY PLANNING FOR
HOMELESSNESS AND NOW AS WE SAW
WITH THE NUMBERS GOING OUT -- IN
A WAY I THINK IT'S TIME.
TO IMPLEMENT SOMETHING LIKE THIS
TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT AGAIN
IN LA COUNTY FOR INSTANCE 35% OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS LIVE IN
THEIR CARS RIGHT YOU MENTION
THAT.
HAVE YOU DONE ANY ANALYSIS ON SB
TWO ZONES.
ON SB TWO ZONES SB TWO ZONES
pAVAIL TO WHICH REQUIRES THAT --
CITIES HAVE OF ZONING AREA WHERE
THEY ARE ABLE TO PUT A HOMELESS
SHELTER YEAR ROUND.
THESE TWO HUNDRED BEDS.
AND I WAS HOPING THAT MAYBE
YOU'VE DONE SOME RESEARCH.
ON THAT BECAUSE THAT WOULD LEAD
TO A FEW OTHER QUESTIONS WHAT.
WE TWO HUNDRED BEDS IN LOS
ANGELES WOULD NOT ACCOMMODATE
OUR 35%.
BY ANY STRETCH NO I I HAVE A
LET'S SAY A FEDERALLY I'VE GOT I
MEAN WE'VE CERTAINLY -- LOOKED
AT AT DIFFERENT LEVELS OF RIGOR --
ALL OF VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
KINDS OF PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS.
AND WHAT YOU KNOW THE EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THAT THAT ALL ARE
NEEDED GIVEN THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW -- BUT WITH AN
EYE TOWARD THINKING ABOUT
PERMANENT SOLUTION BUT JUST FOR
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND ARE.
COUNTY SUPERVISOR I SERVED AS
CHAIR OF THE COMMISSION AND
ALMOST AS FOR ABOUT EIGHT YEARS --
AND SO I'VE KIND OF BEEN.
MARINATED IN THE SUBJECT THAT'S
WHY.
YOU KNOW WE WE TRY TO DO.
BUT THE WALL SEVEN THE SENATE
DID A SOMEONE TO THE SENATE BILL
TWO I CAN'T MEMBER WHO THE
AUTHOR WAS BUT IT WOULD REQUIRE.
PUTTING A HOMELESS SHELTER IN
YOUR CITY AND YOU HAD TO ZONE
FORT I'M FINDING -- A REAL
DISAPPOINTING -- RESPONSE TO
THAT.
I I YOU KNOW I CAN CERTAINLY
AIMING THE CITIES IN MY COUNTY
THAT DON'T HAVE.
OR IT WILL OR IT DON'T HAVE AN
SB TWO ZONE OR IF THEY DO THEY
DON'T USE IT IT IS STILL.
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE OKAY WE'VE WE
WE CHECK THAT OFF AND AND IT'S
NOT BEING BEING DONE.
SO.
THE REASON I BRING THAT UP IS AN
OKAY NOW WE FOLLOW IT THROUGH
NOW TO A PARKING AREA.
SO NOW.
WHEN?
FIGURE OUT HOW DO YOU INITIATE
THIS AND AND HOW DO YOU.
IMPLEMENTED AND THEN AND FOLLOW
THROUGH ON IT BECAUSE I THINK SB.
TWO IS LACKING THE FOLLOW
THROUGH.
IS ARE TRYING TO HELP ON THIS IF
THAT MAKES SENSE BUT I'M TRYING
I DO GET IT TOOK ME A MINUTE BUT
I GOT IT NOW SO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS SB TWO THEY DIDN'T
FOLLOW THROUGH.
ON THE MANDATE THAT SAID THAT
THAT THAT SO AREAS NEED TO BE
ZONE FOR THE TWO HUNDRED BED
EACH CITY I KNOW ONESELF FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH THAT AND YOU'RE
JUST ASKING DOES THIS BILL
REQUIRE HAVE WHAT OF THE DAY
IT'S PROBABLY MOST OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES UTILITY UTILIZE
THAT TO ALL.
RIGHT SO IF I HAVE CITIES THAT
ARE NOT UTILIZING THAT TOOL I
MEAN AT THIS POINT EVEN OUR
GOVERNOR IS SUING CITIES THAT
ARE THAT ARE NOT PRFORMING TO
THEIR STANDARDS WHICH HURTS
RIGHT BUT IT TAKES MORE.
IT JUST TAKES ONE SORRY YOU
BROUGHT IT UP.
I READ IT SO I MEAN THERE ARE
TEETH RIGHT THERE ARE YOU THERE
ARE THERE ARE TEETH -- WE WOULD
HOPE THAT.
WE WOULD NEED TO USE THEM AND I
KNOW IN MY DISTRICT THIS WAS A
BILL THAT THAT ACTUALLY MY
CONSTITUENTS AND SOME OF MY
CITIES ACTUALLY ASKED TO HAVE
PUT IN PLACE -- BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO PARTICIPATE AND I THINK
THAT FOR US LIKE THE PROFESSOR
SAID ESPECIALLY LOS ANGELES WERE
WERE IN IN CRISIS MODE.
AND WE HAVE TO UTILIZE EVERY
TOOL IN OUR TOOL SHED AND NOW
THAT I KNOW ABOUT SB TO TRUST ME
I WILL CHECK WITH MY CITIES AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE WAY THAT
THEY SHOULD BE.
ON THOSE -- YOU KNOW IT'S ON
YOUR CITIES AND GOOD WORDS RANDY
IS ON THE SAID OVERLY A MILE AND
A HALF SQUARE.
AND WHERE WE PUT IT I SO I HAVE
I FIGURED OUT YEAH YOU WERE CITY
AND THEN YOU CAN HELP PAY FOR
THEIR RIGHT.
SHOULDER AND TRY IT YEAH -- SO
WHY WOULD WE NEED LEGISLATION TO
DO THIS WHY THIS WE'VE GOT
CITIES THAT ARE DOING IT
VOLUNTARILY.
WHY WOULD WE HAVE TO MANDATE?
AT I THINK LIKE I THINK I MEAN I
AM EVERYTHING WE JUST SAID AND
WE'RE IN A CRISIS MODE AND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO DO --
TRUST ME THE LAST THING I WANT
TO DO RIGHT NOW IS BRING YOU A
BILL WHERE PEOPLE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO A PARKING
LOT TO TO BE SAFE AND TO HAVE A
PLACE TO SLEEP.
IT'S THE LAST BILL OF ALL THE
THINGS WE DO HERE THAT I WANT TO
I NEED TO DO.
BUT PEOPLE NEED A SAFE PLACE TO
STAY AND RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING IN THEIR CARS ESPECIALLY
IN THE SOME OF THE CITIES THAT I
REPRESENT.
AND IF THE CITIES AND ALL CITIES
ARE DOING IT LIKE YOU JUST SAID
THE EVEN THE ONES THAT ARE
MANDATE AREN'T DOING I IF I CAN
PUT THESE ARE THE TEETH.
IF I CAN PUT TEETH INTO THE IDEA
THAT WE NEED TO CREATE A SPACE
THAT NOT ONLY GIVES PEOPLE A
SAFE PLACE TO PARK SO THAT THEY
CAN SLEEP AT NIGHT.
BUT ON TOP OF THAT CONNECTS THEM
WITH SOCIAL SERVICES THEN I'VE
DONE MY JOB A LITTLE PIECE OF MY
JOB TO DEAL WITH A CREW CRISIS
SITUATION THAT WE ARE AND SO
THAT WOULD BE MY ANSWER THE
MANAGER AT OR THAT WORKS HERE
MATH BUT I THINK THAT YOU'VE.
ALSO.
BEEN TRYING TO BE FLEXIBLE RIGHT --
ABSOLUTELY HE'S -- ABSOLUTELY IN
YOUR ALSO FOCUSING ON WHERE WE
HAVE THE MOST ACUTE CHALLENGE
YES LARGEST COUNTIES.
IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA WORKING
ON A LOCAL FLEXIBILITY WHICH YOU
KNOW EVERYONE APPRECIATES.
AND THE FACT THAT WE ACTUALLY
NEED TO GET THIS THING DONE YES
THANK YOU AND YES I AGREE WITH
THE CHAIR.
WHICH REALLY THAT NO THAT'S TRUE
I TOTALLY AGREE WE ARE AT A
CRISIS POINT AND WE NEED TO BE
ABLE AND I THINK IT'S NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH RIGHT.
SO WE'RE GONNA NEED -- THAT'S
WHY WE'RE INVEST IN THE TWO
BILLION IN.
FRONT OF COMMERCE HOUSING WHICH
IS ABSOLUTELY NEEDED AS WE ARE
GONNA SEEN TEN BILLION OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS AND HOMELESS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MOVING
FORWARD AND WE NEED PROGRAMS
JUST LIKE THIS IS A SMALL PIECE
THIS IS A PIECE BY THINK MUCH
MORE THAN THAT.
I MEAN IT'S BUT IT'S IT'S A
CRITICAL PIECE THAT WE NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH.
PLEASE VICE CHAIR AND THEN I
KNOW CENTER ABOUT I JUST THINK
IT'S IT'S SUCH CRITICAL
DISCUSSION -- BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
WERE WERE IMPOSING ON LOCALITIES
WHICH YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN HAVING
THAT BATTLE ALL YEAR IS ALWAYS
AYE ALL EVERY YEAR YEAH -- BUT
I'M JUST WONDERING IF SB TWO
ZONES WOULD BE A GOOD PLACE TO
PARK CARS. TO GET THE CITY'S
GOING AS I WONDER THERE'S A
MERGER HEAR ME COULD BE BUT I
THINK ANY EXAMPLE LIKE IN CINEMA
COUNTY SO WE THAT THAT THE BEST
AREA THAT WE FOUND IS THAT A
FAIR GROUNDS SO WE HAVE -- COLD
WEATHER PARKING. FOR FIVE AND A
HALF MONTHS OUT OF THE YEAR WE
CONTRACT WITH CATHOLIC CHARITIES --
WARM SHOWERS ONE HOT MEAL A DAY
AND RESTROOMS IN A SAFE PLACE TO
BE ABLE TO PARK -- IN SO THAT
DID.
AND I DON'T EVER WANT TO ASSUME
OR PUT WORDS IN THE GERMS MATH I
THINK WITH THIS BILLS PROVIDING
IS AN OPPORTUNITY ONE SAYING THE
LOCALITIES Y'ALL GONNA MOVE YOU
GOT TO MOVE ON THIS.
AND WHERE YOU PUT THAT.
ULTIMATELY IT'S GOING TO BE YOUR
DECISION EARLY AND I THINK
THAT'S THE PIECE WOW YES THERE
WOULD BE -- SOME STICK TO THIS
IT IS ALSO PROVIDE AN INCREDIBLE
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT LOCALS THE
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH THE
LOCALS HATE.
ON IS NONEXISTENT IN THIS IT IT
PROVIDES FLEXIBLY WHERE THEY
THINK ARE THE BEST PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO HOUSE SERVICES LIKE THAT
WOULD BE.
YES AT ANY.
THE CHAIR KNOWS ME VERY WELL.
I'M NOT SEEING A LONG LIST OF
OPPOSITION.
SITTING HERE JUST TRYING TO YEAH.
I UNDERSTAND [inaudible]
GO.
EXCELLENT SO WE'RE GONNA THINK
RICHARD THANK YOU THANK YOU NO I
IS RIGHT HERE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND I THINK YOU.
I'M TRYING TO GET MY MY INTAKE
PROFESSOR FOR CAM K<c.cyan>.</c>
WHAT ARE THE LEAST?
HAVE YOU TALK.
NO IT'S IT'S TRUE IN AT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AS VESTER TO THE
SUPPORT IN BEHALF CONVERSATION
AND BRING TO LIGHT SO -- IN LOVE
THE VICE CHAIR AND SO GRATEFUL.
THAT HE IS -- IS HE IS HERE SO
MY GOODNESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA GO.
TO CENTER BELL AND THEN
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THIS
PRESENTATION I DO BELIEVE THAT --
CENTER HER TITLE HAS SOMETHING
TO BE ABLE TO GIVE OUT HERE
TODAY -- AS WELL CENTER WINNER
SO -- WE'RE INTRODUCING ABOUT
LOT OF MY TIME IN MY COMMITTEE
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
AND IT'S INVOLVING -- ANOTHER
BUILDING UP FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
THAT DEALS WITH -- PARKING.
IN THE CITY FOR HOMELESS.
AND THAT'S TRUE BILL IT'S
RELATED -- TO TRYING -- TO
ACCOMMODATE -- HOMELESS PEOPLE
PARKING IN THE CITY AND GIVING
THEM A LITTLE MORE TIME.
TO PARK HAVE [inaudible]
HAVE -- AND THEN WE HAVE THE
LEGAL CITIES WE HAVE LOS ANGELES.
ALL THE OTHER CITIES -- OPPOSING
THE BILL.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE
RESTRICTIONS.
ON THEIR ABILITY TO BOOT.
IF TECH AIDS.
WILL PEOPLE ON SO FORD HAS HAS
THIS BILL -- LOOKED AT THAT BILL
AND HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THAT BILL
AS A COMPLEMENTARY -- TO WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
IN HONESTLY THAT'S WHAT CITIES
ARE DOING RIGHT I KNOW AND I I'M
AWARE OF THE BILL BUT NO WE
HAVEN'T LOOKED AT IT AT WE
HAVEN'T LOOKED AT IT IS
COMPLEMENTARY OR OR OR ANYTHING
WE I MEAN. FOR US.
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW I KNOW
CITIES HAVE AN ISSUE A LONG LIST
OF ISSUES WITH THAT AND AND OUR
OUR OUR OUR LIKE THE CHAIR
MENTIONED I THINK OUR HOPE WAS
TO CREATE SOME FLEXIBILITY SO
THAT THERE WASN'T THAT SAME
OPPOSITION AND I THINK YOU
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT.
SAME OPPOSITION OR HAVE FROM
THEM OR SIGNED A DEAL WITH THE
POLICE ENFORCEMENT POWERS THAT
WERE JUST GO IN AND IN EARLY WE
WERE THINKING MAYBE -- AWAY
RATHER THAN GIVE A TICKET -- GE
IMPOUNDED CAR.
THEY CAN GIVE A INFORMATION
ABOUT A CITY PARKING AREA THAT
WAS ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS.
RIGHT WE'RE ALSO STILL GIVING A
LOT OF TICKETS AND RAIN OPPOSING
A LOT OF FINANCIAL.
BURDEN ON SOMEBODY'S ALREADY
HOMELESS.
GIVE THEM -- HELP THEM FIND A
LOCATION WHERE THEY CAN'T WORK.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE'S ALWAYS
PEOPLE THAT ARE.
GETTING YOU KNOW THEY'RE OUT
THERE GETTING A LOT OF TICKETS.
AND I HEARD IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THERE WAS SOMEBODY GAVE
ME A NUMBER A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND TICKETS A YEAR.
ON THIS KIND OF THING
[inaudible]
NAY [inaudible]
SO SO.
YES I KNOW IT DEALS WITH -- A
POVERTY TAX IS KIND OF LIKE A
PROPERTY TAX OF YOUR WRITING
WHILST ACTS YEAH RIGHT -- THAT
THEY PAY IN EFFECT YOU KNOW.
SO.
WHAT KIND OF MAGNITUDE YOU THINK
YOU NEED TO HAVE WITH THOSE?
PARKING PROGRAM HOW BIG SHOULD I
MANY.
PLACES THAT YOU ESTIMATE ARE
NEEDED TERMS OF A DEMAND THAT WE
HAVE.
I MEAN.
LOOK AT DOWN.
I MEAN I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO LA
COUNTY AND I KNOW THAT BOTH THE
COUNTY OF LOOK AT SOME OTHER
UNINCORPORATED AREAS THE CITY OF
AUSTIN'S WOULDN'T SOME OF THEIR
AREAS AND AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY
LIVING IN THEIR CARS AND LA
COUNTY IS.
AROUND.
TWENTY THOUSAND AND SO THAT'S
NOT TWENTY THOUSAND CARS BUT
IT'S TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE SO
PEOPLE HAVE IDENTIFIED
SUFFICIENT SITES. TO FILL THAT
PARTICULAR DEMAND BUT THEN YOU
HAVE TO DECIDE HOW TO IMPLEMENT
ITS AND AND WHAT'S NICE ABOUT
THIS BILL FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
IS THAT IT PROVIDES KIND OF THE
IMPETUS TO DO A EMERGENCY PLAN
FOR HOMELESSNESS AS IT RELATES
TO PARKING.
AND IT DOESN'T SAY YOU HAVE TO
DO IT THIS WAY OR THAT WAY BUT
YOU CAN DO IT WITH IN THAT THE
SORT OF RESOURCES YOU HAVE BUT
AGAIN 200-00 PEOPLE IN LA COUNTY.
AND THEN YOU CAN THINK ABOUT
THAT RATIO IN OTHER PLACES AS
WE'VE SEEN THE HOMELESS NUMBERS
GO UP IT IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S A
PART OF THE SOLUTION THAT MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE IN THE SHORT RUN
HERE [inaudible]
OKAY -- SO I THINK I THINK THE
BILL'S COULD BE.
MADE COMPLIMENTARY AROUND AYE
THAT'S SORT OF WHAT I'M THINKING.
AS I REVIEW THE BILL FOR NEXT
WEEK'S HEARING ON THE BILL SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND ARE COMMITTEE.
SO I I I LOVE TO HAVE YOUR TALK
TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT -- TO SEE
IF THE YOU HAVE SOME GREAT IDEAS
ON HOW TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH RIGHT AWAY I
HAVE ANOTHER THING I WANT TO
TELL YOU.
I HAVE -- WHEN I TEN YEARS AGO I
HAD THIS SEVENTY YEAR OLD?
THAT WAS A FOSTER -- INTERJ HE
WAS -- FOSTER KID THAT WAS
INTERNING IN MY OFFICE.
HE'S HE WAS SEVENTEEN THEY WENT
THROUGH A LOT OF BAD THINGS WHEN
HE WAS A KID.
NOW IN THE PRICE SCHOOL GUINNESS
PHD [inaudible]
ALSO.
I JUST WANT TO LET EVERYBODY
KNOW THAT SO THERE'S DO GREAT
THINGS THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER VERY
GRATEFUL.
I WOULD LIKE TO RETURN OR THE
MAJORITY LEADER AND I JUST WANNA
DO A QUICK NOTE.
MAJORITY LEADER SUPPOSED TO BE
ON A PLANE IN JUST A BIT AND
WE'RE DOING WELL THAT ONE SO AT
THE LEADER.
OF THE MAKE IT VERY FAST YOU
KNOW I HAVE A BILL ON THE STREET --
COURSE IDEA BUT BUT ON YOU KNOW
I GOTTA TELL YOU SOMETHING.
WE GOT A CHANGE OF THE GAME.
THIS BILL REQUIRES BY JANUARY
FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO IT.
SHOULD BE DONE LAST WEEK OKAY
IT'S IT'S JUST ENOUGH ARE GONNA
VOTE FOR THIS THING.
BUT I WANT TO CHANGE THE DATE I
WANT TO MAKE IT TWO THOUSAND
DODGE YOU KNOW WHATEVER IT IS
THE DE DID MAKE ENERGY BILL
WHATEVER WE GOT TO DO.
WE GOT JUST EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGE AND WE IN GOVERNMENT
ARE JUST WORKING TOO SLOW ON
THIS STUFF.
AND IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT AND AND
GIVEN PEOPLE AND I I DON'T CARE
IF PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE
EVERYBODY ELSE IS UNCOMFORTABLE
THE PROBLEM IS HORRIBLE IT'S
HAVE AN EFFECT ON EVERYBODY.
SO THIS YOU KNOW THIS NOTION OF
PUTTING THIS IN EFFECT BY
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO TO ME.
YOU KNOW ALL VOTE FOR TODAY BUT
I MIGHT STAND UP ON THE FLOOR
AND MAKE A RUCKUS ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THEY SHOULD BE.
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY OR MAKE AN URGENCY BILL
AND GET THE STUFF ROLAND BUT WE
WE ALL OF US THROUGHOUT THE CITY
CALIFORNIA HAVE TO TAKE IT
UNBELIEVABLE HAVE A SENSE OF
URGENCY ABOUT THIS.
AND I I THINK WE HAD A CHANGE OF
THE GAME AND I THINK TOO MANY
PEOPLE.
WHO ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
MECHANICS OF STUFF ARE ARE ARE
CONTROLLING THE TED TO DO THEY
SAY THE TAIL IS WAGGING THE DOG
OR WHATEVER?
WE GOT A CHANGE OF THE GAME
BECAUSE ARE THE PEOPLE ALL
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
EVERY CORNER BALL FIFTY COUNTIES
RIPS AT WITH THAT A MOVE THE
BILL.
THANK YOU IN MOTION FOR IN TURN
OVER CENTER WINNER -- GREAT
THANK YOU -- SUPPORT THE BILL I
DON'T I DON'T MY ONLY CRITIQUE
OF IT IS I WISH IT UP BY THE
CITY'S INCOMES UNDER THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND I KNOW
THAT.
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS A
COMPROMISE PROCESS.
ARE BY NATURE AND FRANKLY --
HOMELESS PEOPLE NEED A SAFE
PLACE TO SLEEP AND THE SMALLEST
CITIES DECIDED TO IN THE BIGGEST
CITIES BUT I UNDERSTAND THE
DYNAMIC IN THIS BUILDING.
THAT SMALL CITIES SOMEONE'S GOT
EXEMPTED -- SO.
I THINK IT'S IN TERMS OF THE SB
TWO IS ON THE PHONE A COMMENT
TOTALLY BROKEN YES THE TWO ZONES
AND CITIES PUT IT OUT.
YOU KNOW FAR AWAY DISCONNECTED
FROM EVERYTHING WE'RE TRYING TO
TIGHTEN THAT UP THIS YEAR SO
HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE A BETTER SB
TO SITUATION.
SO THAT WE HAVE MORE SHELTER IN
MORE PARTS OF THE STATE.
BUT I ALSO JUST LOOKING BIG
PICTURE I KNOW -- I SOME MEMORY
THAT YOU FULLY AGREE WITH ME ON
THAT -- THAT -- I TOO I SHARE
WITH CENTER HERTZBERG ON DESIRE
TO HAVE MORE OF A SENSE OF
URGENCY -- IN THIS BILL IN THIS
BUILDING.
AND THAT URGENCY SHOULD EXTEND --
TO THE NEED FOR A DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF ACTUAL
HOUSING.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE BECAUSE YEAH.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE THE THAT'S
LOOKING BIG PICTURE HERE.
YES YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE YOU KNOW
ARE ALREADY LIVING IN THEIR CARS
WE JUST WANT TO SAY PLACE FROM
THE BUT JUST STEPPING BACK.
AND LOOKING BIG PICTURE.
THE MORAL FAILURE THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING IN THIS STATE
BECAUSE WE ARE FORCING PEOPLE TO
LIVE IN THEIR CARS.
WHAT KIND OF SOCIETY?
FORCES PEOPLE TO LIVE IN THEIR
CARS.
I AND WE HAVE DONE SO NOT
BECAUSE SOMETHING HAPPENED TO US
WE'VE DONE THIS TO OURSELVES.
BY MAKING IT HARDER AND HARDER
AND HARDER. TO HAVE ENOUGH
HOUSING.
BY GENERATING THIS THREE AND A
HALF MILLION HOME DEFICIT.
BECAUSE WE BANNED APARTMENT
BUILDINGS WITH BAND AFFORDABLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND A LARGE
MAJORITY OF THE STATE WE HAVE
SAID IT'S GOING TO TAKE YEARS
AND YEARS TO GET ANY KIND OF
HOUSING.
APPROVED.
AND WE ARE GOING TO CREATE THE
SHORTAGE AND THAT'S WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS EFFECTIVELY DONE
OVER YEAR OVER THE YEARS.
AND YOU KNOW SOME OF THE CITY
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT TODAY.
ALSO ARE IN THE HABIT OF
OPPOSING ANY EFFORT TO SET STATE
STANDARDS TO SAY YOU NEED TO
BUILD ENOUGH HOUSING.
SO YES LET'S DO THIS LET'S HAVE
THE PEOPLE LIVING IN CARS.
IBM SEE FOR AN ENVIRONMENT.
BOAT WE WE HAVE TO KEEP.
IT FRONT AND CENTER THAT THIS IS
THIS REPRESENTS A FAILURE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE TO AGGRESSIVELY
BUILD ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT
KINDS OF HOUSING EVERYWHERE IN
THE STATE -- BECAUSE THAT'S DOT
SO HUMANE THING TO DO IT'S THE
COMPASSION AND PROGRESSIVE THING
TO DO -- AND JUST LAST HAS NEVER
LOSE SIGHT OF THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE ARE
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHEN
YOU SEE SOME SMALL CITIES WERE
EXEMPTED I THINK ALL CITIES WERE
IN BUT ANYWAY WE CAN TALK MORE
ABOUT THAT'S GOOD TAX -- NO NO
NO YEAH.
OKAY I WAS LOOKING IN ANY AND
ROLL MY EYES I SEE THERE YOU GO.
THIS BILL AND THERE IS YEAH.
YEAH YEAH YEAH.
ALL RIGHT THIS GO TO THE VICE
CHAIR.
OBSERVATION -- BECAUSE WE ALL GO
OUT AND SPEAK IN.
HAD ONE RATHER SUBSTANTIAL
INDIVIDUAL THAT I'VE GOT AN IDEA
ON HOMELESSNESS AND AND AND HIS
IDEA WAS THAT THERE A LOT OF US
PARKING STRUCTURES BUT THAT
MILLION ORANGE COUNTY BUT IN.
CERTAIN LITTLE POCKETS.
HE SAID THEY GOT THEY GOT.
FLOORS THAT ARE NOT BEING USED
FOR PARKING SPACE AND MAYBE WE
OUGHT.
TO USE SOME OF THOSE EVEN FOR
THE YOU KNOW PUTTING IN UNITS
THERE ARE SOME SOME PARTITION.
THAT MIGHT BE A GOOD OPPORTUNITY
FOR SAY A CITY LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO THAT.
DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF BILLABLE
SPACE BUT MAYBE HAS A LOT OF
PARKING STRUCTURE WILL.
OR HUNTINGTON BEACH.
BUT IT'S INTERESTING THE IDEA IS
A COMMON SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THE PERSON.
IN A LOOK TO THE CHAIR WOMAN --
FOR SOME FROG IF YOU REAL QUICK
IF THAT WORKS FOR YOU -- CENTERS
PERSON AT LEGALLY HAVE TO GET ON
A PLANE HERE QUICK STYLE -- HE
STARTS BOARDING -- YEAH.
I WAS NO I DON'T WANT HIM TO
LEAVE WE STILL I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
CENTER HERTZBERG DOES RECEIVE
THEIR IT IS TWO WEEKS IN A ROW
CENTER TITLE. THREE AND A FOUR
EIGHT SO -- WE'RE GONNA DO -- WE
HAVE AN AWARD IS WELL TO BE TO
PRESENT AS AN HERTZBERG HOW GO
RIGHT AHEAD CENTER TITLE.
THAT ARE HERTZBERG AT TODAY YOU
ARE PRESENTED WITH THE AWARD AT
THE FOOT OF THE RICARDO LARA
WARD.
HI THAT'S PRESENTED TO THE
MEMBER WHO IS -- THE THE ONE
THAT IT WAS LATE THE MOST -- AND
THAT GOES.
TO THEN HERTZBERG THANK YOU SO
MUCH EASILY CENTER WIENER AND
NOW HE'S -- HE'S ON IT --
VENTURE WE'D LIKE TO BE TO OPEN
UP I YOUR QUESTION I WILL
ABSOLUTELY OKAY THINK SO MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP THE ROLE
HERE REAL QUICK THAT'S OKAY
WE'RE GONNA QUIT PIES -- IN IN --
OPEN UP THE ROLE AND HAVE THE ON
THE SERVER NOW PLEASE COME
FORWARD -- IN IN I AM WE OKAY SO
.
I MEAN IF THAT WORKS THAT
[inaudible]
ALL. FOR THAT LITTLE
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE SATISFIED
THAT.
YEAH ANY KANSEN CHU MEETING LAST
TIME I TRIED TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT A BILL TWO PHONE.
OPTION IF WE THEY SEND THEM
[inaudible] TO YEAH.
YEAH.
HOW WE SET OUT OF THE SCANDAL
RAIN COULD MORE WITH THE MOTION
BY CENTER HERTZBERG THIS IS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS
WITH A CLOSING?
STATEMENT BY THE SILLY WOMAN IF
IT WORKS FOR FOLKS WE'RE GONNA
TAKE ACTION AND ITEM NUMBER TEN
MISSING CHESTER DICK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WIRE HI.
I'M MORE LAW.
MORE LIKE DIED DOWN. FOR FOR A
GUIDE RICARDO [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
WILSON NOW WHERE.
WIENER AYE YOU HAVE A FIVE FIVE
TO VOTE THE VOTE IS FINAL AND
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE AND ITEM
NUMBER INTO ANYTHING WHICH
RENDON CHAIR HAVE ANYTHING
PROFESSOR.
LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA GO A
LITTLE OUT ORDER THEY WERE GONNA
HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON AND THEN
OPEN UP THE RULES WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE ACTION RIGHT NOW AND ITEM
SIX SEVEN AND FOURTEEN ITEM SIX
SEVEN IN FOURTEEN THAT START
WITH ITEM.
SIX THIS IS AB SIX HUNDRED THIS
HAS A MOTION TO DO PASSED TO THE
FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO A
SLIGHT GESTURE CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO REPORT THREE THAT IS
THE FINAL VOTE FOR THREE FINAL
VOTE FOR THREE THE BILLS THAT
WERE CLOSE THE ROLE.
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB.
SIX THIRTY TWO THIS IS A MOTION
TO DO PASSED TO THE FLOOR
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ONE
VOTE MISS LANE CHESTER
[inaudible]
L..
I HERTZBERG.
WITH REGARD RICARDO.
HOW ARE YOU?
THAT IS A FINAL VOTE OF SIX TO
ONE SIXTY ONE THE BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM FOURTEEN AB.
TEN NINETY FIVE THIS IS A MOTION
OF DO PASS TO THE FLOOR CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE ZERO THIS
LANCASTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MORE LAW.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG I RICARDO.
I TO FOURTEEN HELLO I WE'LL SEND.
WIENER.
WIENER I HAVE.
BUT THEY WERE VERY.
YEAH AND FOURTEEN FIVE ZERO THAT
IS A FINAL VOTE OF FIVE ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE IN THE
ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN BECAUSE I'D
ASK FOR SOME AMENDMENTS THEY
TOOK THEM SO I WANT.
TO YOU NEVER ASKED FOR MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN AND THEN DON'T
VOTE ON SOMEBODY'S BILL THAT'S
BAD FORM.
IT TOOK A THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB NINE THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOR ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS MISSING
JUST HERTZBERG.
THAT IS THE FINAL VOTE.
FIVE ONE THE BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSE THE ROLE.
PLAYED IN GENERAL COMMITTEE CAN
YOU GIVE US A COUPLE MINUTES
WE'LL GET SITUATED ORGANIZE
READY TO ROLL ENGAGE ATTY THANK
YOU SO MUCH
.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR OF THE
PATIENTS DID TODAY WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THEIR CONSENT COUNTER
WE HAVE ONE ITEM OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THIS ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS A VETERANS AFFAIRS --
VETERANS AFFAIRS CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX ZERO MUSLIM CHESTER ABSENT
MEMBERS PLEASE.
HERTZBERG. SIX ZERO THE FINAL
VOTE.
THE BILL THAT WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
GO IN FILE ORDER FROM THERE ON
OUT OF REMAINING BILLS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB.
ONE THREE THREE AT THIS AS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MOTION CURRENT
LOTUS SIX ZERO MISS LANCASTER.
HERTZBERG. SIX ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT FINAL VOTE [inaudible]
WERE.
THE BILL WE ARE COMPLETE ON THAT
ONE A FIVE ITEM NUMBER. TWO
EIGHTY THREE OH FIVE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT LOTUS SIX YEAR MUSLIM
CHESTER HERTZBERG. SIX THERE THE
BILL'S OUT FINAL VOTE.
THE ROLE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB FOUR NINE EIGHT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS A VETERANS AFFAIRS KERN
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO SAN CHESTER.
BELL BELL I HERTZBERG RICARDO.
HELLO I SIX ZERO FINAL VOTE THE
BILLS THAT WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
NOW MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. EXCUSE ME AB FIVE
THIRTY THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO
THE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO MISS
LANE CHESTER HERTZBERG. SIX ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT FINAL VOTE
RECALLS THE ROLE FOR NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
DO PASSES AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
KERN VOTE IS SIX ZERO MISS LANE
CHESTER HERTZBERG.
FINAL VOTE SIX ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE.
PLAYS IN GENERAL NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOR THE
MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS CURRENT VOTERS FIVE
ZERO WAS LANCASTER HERTZBERG.
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN I FINAL VOTE
SIX ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB.
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE AT THIS AS A
MOTION OF DO PASSING AFTER
RESOURCES IN WATER THIS NATURE
CERTAINLY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CHOIR I WHERE I
HERTZBERG.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI. SIX ZERO FINAL VOTE
THE BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE FORTY FIVE OCCUR AT
SEIZING THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE BANKING THE AMENDMENTS WILL
BE TAKEN IN BANKING.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOR IS ZERO
MISS LANE CHESTER HERTZBERG.
WIENER.
WIENER HI. FIVE ZERO THE BILLS
OUT FINAL VOTE WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE FOR NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO
NATURAL RESOURCES A WATER.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO MISLI
CHESTER HERTZBERG [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER I ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
FINAL VOTE FOR CLOSING THE ROLE
ITEM FIFTEEN AB ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
FOR ZERO MISS LANE CHESTER.
MORLOCK [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
BUT AT THE BILL'S OUT FINAL VOTE
FOR CLOSE THE ROLE ITEM SIXTEEN
AB TWELVE ZERO EIGHT CURRENT
VOTE IS FOR IS ZERO THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE FLOOR
MISLIM CHESTER.
WELL.
ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG RICARDO
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT. SIX ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WERE CLOSE IN THE ROLE FINAL
VOTE FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO MISS
LANCASTER [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
THAT'S THE FINAL VOTE THE BILL
IS OUT.
CLOSE THE ROLE. FIVE ZERO TWO
MORE LEFT THE MEMBERS -- FILE
ITEM TWENTY AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX ZERO THIS LANCASTER
HERTZBERG. SIX ZERO THE BILL IS
THAT WERE CLOSE THE ROLE.
KIND OF A LAZY GERMAN FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE THE FINAL ON A. B.
FIFTEEN NINETY THE MOTION IS
PASSES A MINUTE IS AN
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOR IT TO ZERO
MISSING JUST HERTZBERG.
WIENER.
WIENER I FIVE FIVE ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT WERE CLOSE THE ROLE.
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN -- NEXT WEEK
WILL BE THE CALM BEFORE THE
STORM.
SO IT WON'T BE TOO BAD NEXT WEEK --
IN IN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS AFTER
THAT PROBABLY FIVE TO SIX HOURS.
SO -- WE GOT SOME MEDIA ONES
COMING DOWN.
GOOD TIMES THIS SO MUCH -- WE A
LOT OF THE TIMES -- WE'RE GONNA
BE ADJOURNING THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALL THE WORK ON ALL SIDES IN
DUPRI SHE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
STAFF THANK YOU SO MUCH